OKAY. GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE HEARING DUE
TO THE CONTINUED STATE HOME
ORDER WERE PRACTICING SAFE
SOCIAL DISTANCING. A HEARING
HEARING REMAIN THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WALK TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASS BE
WARNED AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BEING MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING
WHETHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT
A VIDEO VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK
WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES TESTIMONY TODAY.
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM. WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STUFF IN
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOL FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR WHEN THIS
IS USING THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM
THE V. THE W. V. R. OR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS R. T. S.
BECAUSE GOVERNMENTS LOVE A GOOD
ACRONYM. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE MAY HAVE SOME
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. AS WELL AS A
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
AND OTHER LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES. WE BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALLING
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR OH TWO THAT'S. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR OH TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN THIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. AND I WILL SAVE YOU
END UP IN THE WRONG QUEUE
THAT'S FINE JUST REMIND US
WHETHER YOU'RE SUPPORTING OR
OPPOSING. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE I WATED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY. PROBLEMS FOR THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
THE CAN AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE TWO
THAT'S. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE
NINE TWO ZERO NINE TWO. AND MY
STAFF WILL TO HELP. I ALSO WANT
TO KNOW THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING.
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
PRESS. LETTER ON THE COMMITTEES
WEBSITE. THANK YOU BEARING WITH
US. AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. THEN I HAVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SB TWENTY FIVE
PROBABLY EURO HAS BEEN PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. SB IS EIGHT
NINETY FIVE AND FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. AND WITHOUT WE WILL
MOVE TO OUR BILLS HEARD IN FILE
ORDER ACTUALLY WE ARE MOVING A
LITTLE ESTABLISH A QUORUM- WE
PLEASE TAKE ROLE. FRIEDMAN HERE.
FRIEDMAN HERE FOR A YEAR LARA
HERE BOB. DOWN HERE CUNNINGHAM
COMING. EGGMAN HERE GARCIA
GARCIA HERE MATHIS HERE ABOUT
THIS YEAR MCCARTY. OKAY YEAH
LOS. THEIR SOUND. OKAY WE HAVE
A CORE WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
TAKE NINE NINE FIVE SENATOR
HOPKINS FIRST. MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND WE HAVE A
SECOND WELCOME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND ALLOW HIM TO. I WANT
MY I THINK YOUR MICROPHONE NOT
ON LET'S LET THEM PUT THE MIKE
ON FIRST. OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR ABOUT THAT. YEAH. I'M
PUSHING THE ONLY BUTTON I HOP
WAIT OKAY ONE MORE TESTING GOT
IT THERE YOU GO WELL LET ME.
REPEAT MY THANK YOUS TO YOU
MADAM CHAIR- FOR LETTING ME
GIVE ME THE COURTESY TO GO
FIRST I APPRECIATE IT A GREAT
DEAL SO MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES
I RISE TO PRESENT SB NINE NINE
FIVE WHICH EXTENDS THE SUNSET
OF EXISTING CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT OR
SEQUESTERING MINING PROVISIONS
AND ENABLE SMALL SCALE HOUSING
PROJECTS TO BENEFIT FROM THE
STREAMLINING AS WE- THAT'S BEEN.
NINE FIVE AS PART THE WORK DONE
ON A HOUSING PRODUCTION PACKAGE
OF BILLS TO ADDRESS THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR HOUSING
SUPPLY. AND PRODUCTION IN OUR
STATE. I WANT TO THANK THE
GROUP OF LEAD SENATORS ARE
SENATORS MCGUIRE WHO IS. WITH
ME TODAY AND WILL BE COMMENTING
AND- HERE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AS THE LEADER OF THE
GROUP. ALONG WITH SENATORS
CABALLERO DIRECTED TO SORROW.
TO ROSS SO- GONZALEZ HILL ROTH
AND RUBIO THEY STEPPED UP TO
LEAD THE DISCUSSION ON THE
ISSUE AND I APPRECIATE THAT. I
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE WORK OF YOU MADAM CHAIR-
YOUR ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING MR CHIU ASSEMBLY
HOUSING CHAIR REGARDING THE
LEGISLATION THE ASSEMBLY HAS
PUT FORWARD TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING SHORTAGE. SB NINE NINE
FIVE IS A KEY PART OF THIS
PACKAGE OF BILLS. IN THAT IT
ENSURE SMALL SCALE HOUSING
PROJECTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR AB
NINE HUNDRED PROGRAM RELIEF.
AND IT PUTS IN PLACE TOOLS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO CONDUCT-MORE EFFICIENT SEQUEL REVIEWS.
BY UTILIZING THE MASTER AND
FOCUSED ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT. FOR THE POLICY WALKS IN
THE ROOM TO ME I ARE IN THE FEI
ARE PROCESS. FIRST I WANT TO.
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT DO THE
FOLLOWING. INCORPORATE A
STATUTORY DEFINITION OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE NEW
STREAMLINING PROVISIONS FOR
HOUSING PROJECTS BETWEEN
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARSAND A
HUNDRED MILLION. IT CLAY IF.
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THE NEW
STANDARDS IN THE BILL WILL
APPLY PROSPECTIVELY TO NEW
PROJECTS AT OR ABOVE THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
THRESHOLD. BUT RETAIN THE
CURRENT BILL PROVISIONS FOR THE
HOUSING PROJECTS BELOW THE
THRESHOLD. AND ABOVE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. FURTHER TO
ADDRESS GREENHOUSE GAS
MITIGATION ISSUES THE FIRST
PRIORITY IS GIVEN TO MITIGATION
THAT PROVIDES DIRECT ONSITE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. IF THAT
IS NOT FEASIBLE MITIGATION MUST
PROVIDE LOCALIZED ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS IN CALIFORNIA. IT ALL
IF OFFSETS ARE USE THE FIRST
PRIORITY FOR OFFSETS WOULD BE
ONES THAT AR ON SITE. OR IN
THE SAME COMMUNITY AS THE
PROPOSED PROJECT IF THAT IS NOT
FEASIBLE OFFSETS MUST BE IN
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES OR THE
OFFSETS MUST PROVIDE LOCALIZED
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS IN
CALIFORNIA. FURTHER AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT IF THE COMMUNITY
IN WHICH THE PROJECT IS LOCATED
HAS AN INCLUSIONARY ZONING
ORDINANCE. THAT ORDINANCE WOULD
PREVAIL AND GOVERN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STANDARD
REQUIRED IN THE BILL. FURTHER
pEXPRESSLY STATING THE SEQUEL
ENVIRONMENTAL BASELINE FOR
PROJECTS WILL BE THE SAME AS
UNDER SEQUEL GUIDELINES AS THEY
EXIST TODAY. FURTHER ADDS
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY THAT BOTH
SUPERIOR AND APPELLATE COURT
COSTS WILL BE PAID BY THE
APPLICANT. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR IN HER INCREDIBLE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE TO STRENGTHEN THE
BILL WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
PRESERVING. THE AB NINE HUNDRED
PROGRAM. AS A MANY- RECALL IN
TWENTY ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
AB NINE HUNDRED THAT
ESTABLISHED. A NEW PROCESS
UNDER SEQUEL TO STREAMLINE
COULD MEAN RECORD PAPERWORK. AN
EXPEDITED LEGAL CHALLENGES FOR
LARGE MULTI BENEFIT HOUSING
CLEAN ENERGY AND MANUFACTURING
PROJECTS THAT HAVE A CAPITAL
INVESTMENT OF OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. AB NINE
HUNDRED SUNSETS ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THIS
BILL EXTENDS AB NINE HUNDRED
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND IT
EXPERIENCE IT SO THAT IT WOULD
APPLY TO MUCH SMALLER HOUSING
PROJECTS. AND THIS IS REALLY SO
THAT ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS OF
THIS TOOL NOT JUST THE LARGER
CITIES BUT RURAL COMMUNITIES AS
WELL. FOR CURRENT AB NINE
HUNDRED LAW NOW SAYS ONLY
PROJECTS OF A HUNDRED MILLION
AS I SAID. SB NINE NINE FIVE
LOWERED THAT THRESHOLD TO
FIFTEEN MILLION SO THAT THOSE
SMALLER HOUSING PROJECTS
QUALIFY. LIKEWISE THE BILL
REQUIRES. THAT HOUSING PROJECTS
HAVE AT LEAST 15% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THAT'S THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE REQUIRED IN STATE
LAW TODAY. AND TODAY AB NINE
HUNDRED HAS RESULTED IN AT
LEAST FOURTEEN SEPARATE MEGA
PROJECTS REPRESENTING ABOUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN INVESTMENT
OUR STATE. ACCORDING TO THE
INFORMATION FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH AND
THE SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH.
THESE PROJECTS ARE PROVIDED
OVER TEN THOUSAND NEW HOUSING
UNITS. CREATED THOUSANDS OF NEW
HIGH WAGE CONSTRUCTION AND
PERMANENT JOBS. I UNDERSTAND
THAT STAKEHOLDERS WOULD LIKE TO
MODIFY THIS PROGRAM TO ENACT
WHAT THEY ARGUE ARE NECESSARY
ENVIRONMENTAL UPDATES I BELIEVE
AMENDMENTS WERE. DAY ARE STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION WHILE
PRESERVING THE IMPORTANT
BENEFITS OF THE EXISTING AB
NINE HUNDRED PROGRAM. I THINK
MOST OF YOU KNOW- BALANCING THE
INTERESTS OF DEVELOPERS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY THE
LABOR COMMUNITY AND OTHERS.
ISN'T EASY BUT AB NINE HUNDRED
AND THE PROGRAM HAS PROVEN TO
BE SUCCESSFUL WHILE STILL
PROVERBIAL. REVIEW I MEAN IN
FACT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT-
MOST OF THESE PROJECTS HAVE HAD
TO CLEAR THE HURDLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
WHICH MAKES PERFECT SENSE THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH. SO
CAN BE LOOKED AT THAT THERE IS
A HIGH HURDLE AS IT SHOULD BE
THAT THESE PROJECTS HAVE TO
MEET IN ORDER TO BE SUPPORTED I
TAKE IT IN ADDITION ADDING TO
HOUSING PROJECTS TO THIS
PROGRAM WILL GIVE US ANOTHER
TOOL TO TACKLE OUR STATES LONG
STANDING HOUSING PRODUCTION
DEFICIT. EARLIER THIS YEAR AS I
CLOSE. I WOULD DIE. POINT OUT
THAT I MADE A PLEDGE THAT THERE
WOULD BE HOUSING PRODUCTION
COMING OUT OF OUR HOUSE I KNOW
IT'S A HUGE CONCERN IN THIS
HOUSE. THE BIGGEST ISSUE IN OUR
STATE PRIOR TO CODED AND SO
REMAINS. IS THE HOUSING ISSUE.
WE HAVE LESS MONEY TO PUT
FORWARD WHICH ALL OF US WERE
CONSIDERING PRE MARCH AND KOBE
ED IN TERMS OF WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO PUT FORWARD. TO HELP ON
THE HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SIDE. THIS
WILL BE A TOOL. SB NINE NINE
FIVE IS A KEY PART IN
FULFILLING THIS PLEDGE TO
SPURRING PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I LOOK FORWARD
MISTER REQUIRE. CLOSE FOR TO
YOUR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THE COURTESY AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MADAM
PRETEND I KNOW YOU HAVE TO GO
TO. RUN THE LEGISLATURE- BUT I
DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REALLY HARD WORK AND DEDICATION
TO THIS ISSUE. AND I ALSO WANT
TO ESPECIALLY THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE. AND
FOR ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS- I
THINK THAT. WE HAVE TAKEN WHAT
WAS A GOOD BILL AND YOU'VE MADE
IT EVEN BETTER BILL. AND I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR STOCK
AT BLUEBIRD ARE STAFFED LARGELY
BY FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS-
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH ONCE
AGAIN. SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR ON BEHALF OF THE PROTEIN
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT- LAWRENCE'S
BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH AS
WELL- IF IT'S ALRIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIM OUT BY
NAME- AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AND IF IT'S ALRIGHT
MANAGER I'LL COME UP TO THE
TABLE TO BE ABLE TO SIT IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. SURE I
THINK WE'LL HAVE QUESTIONS
AFTER WE HEAR FROM THE THANK
YOU SINCE I DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT
TO TEST WE DO HAVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
THEY'R GOING TO BE ON THE
PHONE LINES. OKAY SO- LET'S GET
THE SUPPORT WITNESSES.
OKAY I
THINK WE NEED TO ASK THE
OPERATOR THEN TO BRING US UP
HUNDRED CASPER. THE OPERATOR
CAN'T ACCOUNT FOR. CANTOR
CASPER'S LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU ALL
HEAR ME. YES WE HEAR YOU. OKAY
WONDERFUL GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS KINDRA
CASPER OF DLA PIPER SPEAKING
TODAY AND SUPPORT OF AT THE
NINE NINE FIVE ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENT ONE HIGHWAY ONE. EIGHTY
NINE HUNDRED PROGRAM IS A VERY
IMPORTANT EFFECTIVE TOOL TO
HELP BALANCE THE VARIETY OF
INTERESTS. OBJECT UP OVER
MILLION HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND- AS STATED EARLIER FOR UP
BY HOUSING PROJECT AS WELL. THE
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED PROGRAMS AT
THE HIGH BAYERN MENTAL STANDARD
FOR PROJECTS TO MEET AND
EXCHANGE FOR AGREEING TO BUILD
THE PROJECT TO THESE HIGH
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS- THE
PRODUCT APPLICATION IT'S
REWARDED WITH- A STREAMLINED
JUDICIAL TIMELINE- I ALSO
REPRESENT. WE ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CERTIFIED UNDER THE EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED PROGRAMS ONE OF WHICH-
HAS ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY
THAT THE LOCAL AGENCY AND HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO- UTILIZE- THAT- IN
MY JUDICIAL TIMELINE. AND IT'S
BEEN AN EXCELLENT BENEFIT FOR
THE PROJECT. I ALSO HAVE A
PROJECT CALLED THAT SIXTY TWO
ZERO YEP APART THAT THAT IS A
CERTIFIED PROJECT IS COMMITTED
TO MEETING ALL OF THESE KIND OF
ARNOLD. AS WELL AS- THAT NOT
CREATE THEN A PERMANENT
CONSTRUCTION JOB ON AND HAS NOT
YET BEEN APPROVED. BY THE LOCAL
AGENCY SO IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
I KNOW THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROJECTS IN IN THAT GAME ABOUT
AND IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT-
THAT WE GET THAT- EXTENSION.
DONE AND WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
EFFORT- BY THE COMMITTEE AND BY
THE POTENTIAL OFFICE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU- OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP UP THE
WITNESSES FOR. SB NNE NINE
FIVE. AND WHEN READY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ASK THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL CHECK TO
LET US KNOW WHEN THEY ARE. I
THANK YOU SB NINE NINE FIVE.
NINE NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO QUEUE UP.
THANK YOU ONCE THEY'RE FINISHED
QUEUING UP YOU CAN START.
ALLOWING THE TESTIMONY. THIS IS
FOR SUPPORT.
WELL WELL THE
OPERATOR IS DOING THAT COULD
THE WHO EVER MADE A MOTION JUST
CLARIFY THAT THAT MOTION TO
PASS AS AMENDED. CAN YOU
CLARIFY THAT THE MOTION WAS TO
PASS AS AMENDED FOR THE RECORD
YES OKAY. YEAH THE WAS TO PASS
AS AMENDED ITS WANT TO CLARIFY.
WELL THE OPERATOR THREE NOT TO
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF SO PLEASE COME TO THE-
MICROPHONE WILL TAKE THAT
TESTIMONY NOW. AND AGAIN FOR
ALL WITNESSES ON THE PHONE OR
IN PERSON ITS NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING ERIN LEHANE FOR THE
BUILDING TRADES WE HAPPEN.
THOUSAND WE HAPPILY SUPPORT
NINE NINE FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM. SEEING NON OPERATOR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. WE CAN
HEAR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
FOR THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES
LISTENING IT IS JUST NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT DO YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THERE. YEAH
MORE. THIS. ALRIGHT. ALRIGHT.
HOWEVER MAYBE YOUR HONOR. YEAH
YEAH. YEAH ALL OF. RIGHT. OKAY
MOREOVER HEARING. FOR THOSE
WATCHING AT HOME WE'RE JUST
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES
WITH THE TELEPHONE LINE AND WE
WILL RESUME THE MEETING AS SOON
AS WE HAVE WITNESSES QUEUED UP.
HI. DOES THIS MORE LAUGHTER.
SINCE THEN HE'S A. RIGHT BACK
WITH. OF OUR CALL FOR. MADAM
CHAIR GO GO AND TRY CALL FOR
AGAIN GO HAND ALL WE DO IS A CO
FOR THE LINE OF SIXTY FOUR. I'M
SORRY YOUR QUESTION FROM THE
LINE. ARE WE HAVE THE- FROM
NINE SIXTY FOUR YOU HAVE
TESTIMONY FROM LINE SIXTY FOUR
IN SEPTEMBER MONEY SUPPORT OF
SB NINE NINE FIVE OKAY COLOR
PLEASE NAME AN ORGANIZATION
OKAY THANK YOU. CHAIRWOMAN
FRIEDMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE CITY AND
AMERICA'S PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ON BEHALF OF OUR
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S NORTHERN COUNTY. I
RISE IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OPERATOR
AND NEXT CALLER IF THERE IS
MORE. OPERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I NUMBER. EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY ONE EIGHTY ONE GOING
A GOOD MORNING MEDICARE AND
OKAY THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BECAUSE
YELLOW JACKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OPERATOR. OPERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JUST
HIRE TO FILL PROBABLY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE HELP THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE NUMBER AT
ONE FORTY EIGHT. THAT IS GREAT
ON BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC
NORTH AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE FIFTY
FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
BERNADETTE BOOKLETS THAT WITH
THE UNIFICATION OF COMMERCE
THEMES THAT ARE LOCAL TO THIRTY
AT ACADIA COUNTY PROUD THAT
CENTER ACTING MOVIE MISSPELL I
WE REPRESENT ABOUT EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED PLAYED WEARING. LINE.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
GIVE ME FAN ON TOP OF BRIDGE
HOUSING SUPPORT ALSO WANTED TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
JUST QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT
EVIDENTLY I GAVE THE WRONG
ACCESS CODE IT IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO THAT'S
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO IS THE CORRECT ACCESS CODE
THAT NEXT CALLER IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY TWO.
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHT
WE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE MEASURES
DURING YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE NINETY SIX. ROBERT GAINERS
AND ALLIED TRADES DISTRICT
COUNCIL THIRTY SIX- OVER TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST WROTE OUR
SISTER DISTRICT COUNCILMAN OR-
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
STRONGLY THEM NOW TALK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO CENTER- CAMPUS
YOU GREAT THANKS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE SIXTY. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS STEVEN BOOKER
OF THE POLITICAL RECTOR AND
COMMUNITY AFFAIRS LIAISON FOR
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL SIX
SEVENTEEN OF SAN MATEO COUNTY.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR I CAN FOR
ALL OUR HARD WORK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE SIXTY.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT IF AMENDED AS DESCRIBED
IN THE LETTER WE SUBMITTED TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. LINE SEVENTY FOUR.
THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN AUTOMATICALLY PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
IS BEING HELD PROPERTY DO
SUPPORT ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE THREE PIECE COLLECTION
WHICH INCLUDES FAMILY PEOPLE
FOUNDATION. FOR WITH THE
SUPPORT OF COMMANDED POSITION
ALTHOUGH WE BELIEVE THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED SAYING
COMMITTEE- SHOULD SHOULD IRAQ
ARE CONCERNED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
FIFTY ONE. SHARE AND MEMBERS
CARE ABOUT THE BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF PASADENA AND SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND AT ONE TWENTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MICHAEL LOPEZ WITH YOU A LOCAL
ONE ONE FOUR SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY- WE STAND BEHIND THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT
NOW LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT HUGE
ADVOCATE FOR ENGAGING SOMEONE
OF LEGAL COLLUDED TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT WHAT I THINK.
THAT ARE ACTIONS WERE GREAT
LEARNING. ANNEX A PREVAILING
WAGE AND SKILL PROGRAMMERS
THANK YOU KNOW OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE GET BACK. LINE. SEVENTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS RON MILLER EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE L. A. ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS FORTY EIGHT
LOCAL UNIONS AND DISTRICT
COUNCILS I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SENATOR ATKINS FOR THIS
MONUMENTAL EFFORT TO PROTECT
THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE WELL THE BUILDING
TRADES WHEN WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE TWENTY.
GOOD MORNING PATRICK BOYLE LOW
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
THREE- ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED. GOOD MORNING
THE POPULAR BUSINESS REP FOR
THE PLUMBERS AND PIPEITTERS
LOCAL FOUR FOUR SEVEN IS STRONG
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE THIRTEEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIRMAN IS 100% YOU
REPRESENTED THE CEMENT MASONS
LOCAL SIX HUNDRED AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB NINE NINE
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE SEVEN
ONE. MONTEREY WITH CALIFORNIAN
BE PORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
SIX ONE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SAM CRANKY REPRESENTATIVE
COUNCIL SICK PAINTERS IN OUR
TRADES AND WE STAY TOGETHER
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES AND
SUPPORT SENATEBILL NINE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE TWENTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR JACK
BUCKHORN C. E. O. OF THE NORTH
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR.
LINE THIRTY. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE RICK SMILED THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF LABORERS NUMBER HAVE
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND PLUS
MEMBERS AND PUBLIC CALIFORNIA
WE STAND THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IN PROTEST
MAPPING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE NINE FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE SEVENTY
SIX. HI MY NAME'S TRINITY
PRESSED WITH HIGH REPRESENT
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES SUPPORTERS
SENATE BILL NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE ONE SIX.
NINE ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KHAN THEY DID A GREAT
JOB PER PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS UA LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN AND I'M CALLING THE STATE
ARE ORGANIZATIONS. SUPPORTS THE
NINETY NINE NINE FIVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE THIRTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARK UDALL
BESIEGED WITH THE HE CROSSES
BORDERS LOCAL SIXTEEN WE STAND
WITH STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. ONE
SEVENTY. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUST THE SAME WITH OPERATING
ENGINEERS AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT. SB NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE FIFTEEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHUCK CARLSON BUSINESS
MANAGER FOR IBEW LOCAL FOUR
THIRTEEN SANTA BARBARA AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK
AND WE STAND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE TWENTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
JEFF TURNER LOCK SECRETARY
TREASURER OF THE HUMBOLDT DEL
NORD BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE NINE FIVE WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE AT
ONE FORTY THREE. CAN LUNCH WITH
PLATINUM ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY BUILDERS GROUP
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
NINE FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE THIRTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MARTY BETTER AGAIN WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL ELEVEN
WE STAND STRONG SUPPORT-
DISABILITY AND- R. TWELVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS REALLY
APPRECIATE ARE YOU GUYS HAVE
TICKETS PARKING DIRECTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY TWO.
HI THIS IS A CHRIS NITER
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
ON BEHALF OF OUR FORTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE FIVE
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK-
THAT- SP CRACKED CENTER ATKINS
IN SPANISH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT COLOR. LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING A LEVY OF
IT ALL ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE FORTY FOUR. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KATIE DONAHUE DROUGHT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
PAPERS AND SUPPORT AND WE THINK
PROGRAM ATKINS FOR HER WORK ON
THE STOCK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
FIFTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR NAMES MARK RODRIGUEZ I
WORKERS LOCAL FORTY THREE
REPRESENT VENTURA SANTA BARBARA
LOS ANGELES SAN BERNARDDINO
RIVERSIDE AND ORANGE COUNTIES-
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU PRO TEM
ACTORS FOR ALL YOUR WORK. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND
SIXTY THREE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BRIAN HOLD PROUD MEMBER
OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL FOUR TO EIGHT AND
BAKERSFIELD CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
TWENTY. GOOD MORNING LAURIE
DAVISON OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL TWELFTH WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE FORTY THREE. YES DANNY
THEY'RE BOTH THAT SECRETARY
TREASURER FOR LABOUR'S
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF NORTH
AMERICA LOCAL TO TWENTY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON. ONE
SEVEN EIGHT YOU CAN CALL BACK.
NEXT CALLER. LINE NINETY TWO.
NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HE OPERATOR LET'S MOVE TO
THE NEXT CALL. I AM TWENTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NATALIE
HAD WE HIGH REPRESENT THE OVER
ONE THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN OF I
B. W. FIVE FIVE ONE IN OUR
BUSINESS MANAGER JOHN MCINTYRE
WE CAN INVOLUNTARY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TREATMENT FOR SB
NINE NINE FIVE AND WE EXTEND
OUR THANKS TO COACH CANNOT
CANCEL ADVOCACY AND WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. ONE ONE
HUNDRED THREE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM AND MEMBERS MIKE WELL
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADE IN SUPPORT OF
THAT'S BEING NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE THIRTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIN BOSTON THE
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
FOUR EIGHT FOUR AND ENTER A WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. NINE NINE FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE TWENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR NUMBER OF ORINDA
LAFAYETTE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND WE HAVE A SUPPORT OF
CEMENTED POSITION AS DESCRIBED
DESCRIBED IN THE LETTER
SUBMITTED TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS DAVID
HANSON REPRESENTING- LOCAL
THREE NINETY EIGHT PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS- WE ARE STAYING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE SIXTY FOUR.
YES THIS IS JOHN HUSING
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PRINTERS ALLIED TRADES WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
FOR THE SENATE BILL NINE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU. Q. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE SIXTY SIX. MY
NAME IS CURTIS DAY REPRESENTING
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTY PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES LEAVES THEM
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
AND SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
NINE FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE GO TO LINE ONE SIX SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY WILL
GO TO LINE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD NINE NINE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ASKING US TO DO
A LOCAL TO FIFTY PRACTITIONERS
AND JOINED THE STATE BY TRADE-
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WHAT. THANK YOU LINE. ONE
THIRTY FOUR NINE ONE THREE
FOUR. ARE YOU COMING FOR A
SECOND HERE'S BILLION
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TREATMENT SUPPORTIVE
SB NINE NINE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE ONE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY LINE ONE EIGHT ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MAD MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MATT KREMIN SHALL BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU KNOW
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO
LINE NUMBER FORTY LINE FOUR
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN FOUR
ZERO WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE
FEATURE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS CHAD RODEO SECTOR
TRIGGER BRICKLAYERS NOW I GRASP
WHAT THE LOCAL FOR. WE'RE
JOINING WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADING SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
NINE FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BECAUSE OF
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
THAT IS LINE ONE ZERO TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IN ONE ZERO TWO WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF
YOU CAN CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE.
LINE ONE ZERO TWO WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON NEXT COLOR. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE OPERATOR. BONTA LINE
TWENTY THREE LINE TWO THREE. HI
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR- MANY
CANALS CO MONTEREY SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT WITH STATE
BILLINGTREE TO SB NINE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD
WORK. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN LINE AT
ONE EIGHT ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KATHLEEN BARBER ON THE
TRAINING DIRECTOR FOR THE SAME
pUNTIL COUNTY ELECTRICAL JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
FIVE WHEN WE- THANK-
REPRESENTATIVE ACTIONS FOR THE
COMMISSION USED. THANK YOU NEXT
CALL PLEASE. WE GO TO LINE AT
NUMBER ONE FIVE SIX ONE FIVE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE
MODERATE MIKE REALLY REPRESENT
DISTRICT OFFICE SIXTEEN PAIRS
KNOWLEDGE TRADES WITHOUT THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES WITH
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
NINE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL ME AT MY NUMBER. OF
FORTY FIVE LINE FOR FIVE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JIM ELROD
I'M THE BUSINESS MANAGER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND WE STAND
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SIX LINE. SIX SIX.
HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
HAPPENING ISSUE SO I REPRESENT
LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT PROSTITUTES
LATERS WE HAVE OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS STRONG SUPPORT
AND SENATE BILL NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GOT A
LINE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT MINUTE
FIVE EAT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRIAN GREGORY I'M A TRUSTEE FOR
THE SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
ELECTRICAL APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
NINE NINE FIVE. AND ON BEHALF
OF OUR VERY HARDWORKING
APPRENTICES WE WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE PRO TEM ATKINS FOR YOUR
HARD WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN LINE AT ONE EIGHT TWO
SEVEN. NINE ONE TWO SEVEN IF
YOU WANT TO CHECK YOUR MUTE
FEATURE WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN.
VANDERLEI NUMBER ONE SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CARLOS
FLORES REPRESENTED DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTER'S
PALETTE TRADES AND WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
NINE FIVE. THANK THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU.WE
HAVE MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO LINE ONE TWO TWO.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR-
COMMITTEE ON JOHN MORALIS
REPRESENTING THE TEACHERS ON
KERN COUNTY AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO
LINE ONE AND THIRTY EIGHT LINE
WANTED THREE EIGHT. BRING ON
THE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE ONE FOUR NINE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS GRETCHEN NEWSOM
ON BEHALF OF IBM W. FIVE SIX
NINE AND I'M THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED UNITED ELECTRICITY ARE
PROFESSIONALS ACROSS SAN DIEGO
TO CARROLL COUNTY. STANDING IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE FIVE
ALONG WITH A BUILDING TRADES
AND THANKING SENATOR I CAN FOR
HER EXCELLENT WORK ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND WHY
NUMBER. SIXTY TWO NINE SIX TWO.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RJ FOR
ARE YOU LOCAL THIRTY EIGHT
BUSINESS TAKING SURVEYS JUST GO
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE NINE FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
Y. NUMBER THIRTY FOUR LINES
THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR JOBS
BODY REPRESENTING THE KERN INYO
AND MONO COUNTIES BUILDING.
TRADES CAL WE STAND STRONG OF
FIVE NINE NINETY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER WE HAVE
LIGHT. ONE NINE ONE SIXTY TWO
ONE SIX TO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RANDALL
MAY NOT REPRESENT MISTER
CALPERS SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BE JUST A
MOMENT. WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWO THAT IS LINE
TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DANNY RIGHT
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
TWO FOUR SIX IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT THING IT'LL BE
ANOTHER MOMENT- WE'VE GOT ONE
PERSON IN THE QUEUE TO BE JUST
A MOMENT OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR. ONE MORE MOMENT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. Q. THAT
IS GOING TO BE MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE ONE
NINE AND NINE JUST A MOMENT.
OKAY THEY MAY HAVE DISCONNECTED
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND. EIGHTY NINE NINE ONE EIGHT
NINE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS YOU
CAN THROW WITH THE BAY AREA HOW
THE ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
NINE FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OTHER AT MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND ONE NINE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GLOBAL
EXPRESS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
YOUR LOCAL FIVE EIGHTY TWO
PLUMBERS AND SPEAKER STINKERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
NINE FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE WILL REMIND
EVERYONE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
AND YOU'D LIKE TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE YOU WILL PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MORE MOMENT
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO OH SEVEN TWO ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS TOMMY FILED BY A REPRESENT
I. B. E.W. LOGICAL WORKERS
LOCAL LOGIN ON THE APPLE ARE
CLOSE TO TWELVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
OF S. B. NINE NINE FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT'S LINE. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN ONE TO SEVEN GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU
PLEASE AND MUTE. OKAY THERE IS
NO RESPONSE IT YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH THIS IS GREG LEWIS-
SEVEN SIXTY ONE IN BURBANK AND
WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. NINE NINE FIVE. THANK YOU
BURBANK NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BUT
MY NUMBER FIFTY THREE THAT IS
LINE AT FIVE THREE. HELLO
TIMBER DANDO LOCAL UNION UP FOR
EIGHT FOR PLUMBERS PIPEFITTERS
AND WELDERS AND APPRENTICES IN
FULL SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE NINE
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE LINE SEVEN FIVE.
HI MY NAME IS EARL HAMPTON ON
THE CALIFORNIA STATE CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIAN WITH IBEW LOCAL
FIVE NINE FIVE. AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. AND MY
NUMBER ONE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. OKAY GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ROB STOKER ON
BEHALF OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE OH FOUR WHICH
ENCOMPASSES FORTY NINE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS IT
BALANCES THE NEED. FOR HOUSING
AND JOB CREATION WITH IMPORTANT
STANDARDS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY NUMBER
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RENDON LEVIN BURKE WITH YOU A
LOCAL Q. FOUR SIX RIGHT NOW
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADE IN OR CLOSE UP SB NINE
NINE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NICE COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE Y. NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE- ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT THANK YOU.
HE WE A I HAVE LINE ONE NINE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THE
DAY GEORGE LABORS INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF NORTH AMERICA LOCAL
THREE TWENTY FOUR REPRESENTING
SOME ALMOST LAKE MENDOCINO
HUMBOLDT DEL NORTON APPLE
SOLANO CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
NINE FIVE ALSO LIKE TO. THANK
MISS ATKINS THE OTHER AUTHORS
AND CO AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME- ACTUALLY WE HAVE
ONE MORE PERSON IN THE QUEUE-
JUST ONE MOMENT. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY ONE LINE AT FIVE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RADI
KOLOS- WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PIPE TRADES DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN REPRESENTING
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND. MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND WE ARE
FULL SUPPORT OF S. NINE FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE TWO ZERO NINE- THEY
MAY HAVE DISCONNECTED ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MEDICAL ROLLER WITH A LAYPERSON
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER OF YOUR IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. NINE NINE FIVE YOU MAY
GET INTO THE QUEUE BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN
ZERO- WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ANDREW DAVEY ARE
YOU A LOCAL FOUR FOUR SEVEN
SACRAMENTO PALMA PIPEFITTERS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL BE JUST ONE MOMENT. I
NUMBER TWO ZERO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE IS JOHN RECTOR
I'M WITH OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL THREE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IT'LL BE JUST
ONE MORE MOMENT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MY PREVIOUS. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE TWO ONE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE HAVE A DISCONNECTED
DO I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE- QUEUE UP I DON'T KNOW
WHICH IS GOING FIRST I THINK
BRANDON DAWSON. FROM THIS YEAR
CLUBS FIRST ARE THEY ON THE
LINE OKAY MISTER YES MISTER
DAWSON IS ON THE LINE. MISTER
DAWSON HI YES GO AHEAD PLEASE.
OKAY WELL BEHIND BURNING ALSO
DIRECTED PERSONA THANK THE
AUTHOR- THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL- OUR ORGANIZATION OPPOSED
AB NINE HUNDRED ONE AFTER TO DO
EXTENDED OR EXPANDED BUT IF YOU
DID ADDRESS THE NINE NINE FIVE
WILL DO- THE PROJECT SUPPORTED
AB NINE HUNDRED STREAMLINING
SHOULD TRULY BE ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERS. WHICH IS WHY WE OPPOSE
SB NINE NINE FIVE AS IT
CURRENTLY IS INCORRECT- UNLESS
AMENDED SO WILL NEED TIME TO
REVIEW THE EXACT LANGUAGE FOR
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
COACHING JUST MENTIONED BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITTEE
OFFERING THEM AND APPROACHED
HIM- PROTECTING THEM. I DO YOU
DO YOU JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
TO DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF
REQUIRING THAT THESE PROJECTS
THE OLD ARE REDUCTIONS IN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED INTO
REDUCTION IS KEY TO MEETING THE
STATE CRIME RECORDS AND PROVIDE
MEDICAL BENEFITS AFTER THE
SOURCE CODE. PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL EQUITY AS A RESULT IN
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AIR
QUALITY INTEREST FOR HER KIDS
SO REQUIRE THESE PROJECTS THAT
WOULD DEVELOP SB KNOW NINE FIVE
TO ACHIEVE AT LEAST A TWENTY.
PERCENT DARK. WELCOME THE
BOSTON GLOBE. AND I COULD ALONG
TERM. SO WITH THAT I THINK YOU
YOUR WORK AND BILL I WILL ASK
YOUR TO MELISSA. TLC THANK YOU.
SIR AMERICA ON THE LINE PLEASE.
YES THANKYOU IN GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBER SMALLER AMERICA
WITH THAT. LEAGUE OF COUNTRY
THAT. WE ARE REVIEWING
COMMITTEE'S AND THEN AND JUST
TO SAY WE REALLY AT. CHAIRED
AND THE KEY STAFF WERE THE-
WERE ON THE OFF STAFF WORK THE
CHANGES WE'RE GOING TO BE
REVIEWING THE AMENDED LANGUAGE
A DETAILED SO FOR THE RECORD MY
COMMENTS TODAY. ARE TO REFLECT
OUR POSITION OF RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE LOOKING AND KILLING
WHICH CURRENTLY IN PRINT. WELL
I MEAN I FIVE ADAM CAT OF
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS PROJECT
INCLUDE HOUSING WITH THAT. AT
HOUSING PROJECT DEDICATED AS
AFFORDABLE WHICH WE UNDERSTAND
WILL BE FURTHER CLARIFIED AND
AMENDMENTS THE BILL DOES
PHILLIPS AND STREAMLINED BUT IT
COULD BE A GOOD THING CATEGORY
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS. WHICH
INCLUDE PROJECTS LIKE STADIUM
AND GENERALLY WE DO BELIEVE
THAT GIVING SPECIAL PEOPLE
BENEFITS PROJECTS LIKE SPORTS
STADIUMS THE END IS NOT A GOOD
QUALITY. AND SUCH LARGE
PROJECTS ACTUALLY HAVE MORE.
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS NOT LAST.
BITING X. REVIEW THE PRICE AND-
TREATMENT FOR ANY CHALLENGES TO
THE PROJECT IN THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM. IF I COULD SCHEDULE
BENEFIT TO THE CALIPERS AND SO
IF EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED IT'S TO
BE EXPANDED RESPECTFULLY WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS CAUTION
COMPETE ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT QUALIFYING PROJECTS TRULY
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA GOLD
ADVISEMENT. SHIPPED LOOKING HOW
DEFINITIONS AND I GOT. WELL HOW
DO YOU PUT YOUR CONNECTED.
ASIAN FOR JOBS REQUIRING
VOLUNTARY OFFSET DIRECTLY
BENEFIT THE LOCAL AREA WITH THE
PROJECT IS TAKING PLACE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS LIKE
REDUCTIONS IN VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED ENERGY AND WATER. AND
IMPORTANTLY INCLUDING
SAFEGUARDS AGAINST DISPLACEMENT
I'M ABOUT SUPPORTING. WE ARE
THE AUTHOR TO BETTER ALIGN THE
BENEFITS FOR PROJECTS- UNDER
EXTENSION EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED
WITH THE STATE ADVANCED VIEW OF
WHAT ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
IS AND AGAIN WE THANK PROCAMP
HAVE STAFF AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING OUR
CONCERNS AND OUR RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AT UNLESS AMENDED TO
THE BILL IN PRINT TODAY BUT AS
STATED WE WILL LOOK AT THE
COMMITTEE MOMENT IN MORE DETAIL
AND REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
WORK THAT WENT INTO THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. Q. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
NINE NINE FIVE YOU MAKE IT INTO
THE QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD IF
YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER PHONE
YOU MAY NEED TO PICK UP THE
HANDSET EFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. AGAIN IF YOU ARE I
OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINE NINE
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CAN STONE OF
CONNECTIVITY AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITE ELECTED BOTH AMENDED
AT THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
FOR THE PHONES THANK. THANK YOU
MEXICO THE RETAILER GO TO. ONE
THREE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
OPPOSITION AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BUT ON MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY LINE AT ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO. YEAH MORE NEED MY
NAME AGAIN OF AFRICA'S- WITH
THAT HELP AND SAID THE LION
KING RICHARD TO RESPECT OPPOSE
AT NINE NINE I THE REPAIRS
OVERSEE EIGHT FIVE MY TO CALL
THE BRENDAN DOCKS AND ALSO MY
TECHNICAL MATTER. IN ADDITION A
LOCAL TO REGISTER UP WITH FOR
THE UNIFICATION WHICH OUR BRAVE
I'VE GIVEN BY NAME. PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL. WHAT KIND OF
CHAPTER AND ALL LEADER COUNTY
ATTEMPTING TO COMPLETE. DURING
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. HEY WE
GOT A LINE IN TWO HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN LINE. TO FOUR. THIS IS
GREAT LOWER RIVER THE NINE
FIVE. NINE NINE FIVE. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. HELLO MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
LINE AT ONE FOUR SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MARINO LINE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM AND ALSO FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR
MY COLLEAGUE IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE- UNFORTUNATELY AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I GO TO MY
NUMBER HUNDRED AND ELEVEN LINE
IT Q. ONE ONE. THAT LINE HAS
DISCONNECTED WE GO TO LINE
NUMBER. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE LINE AT ONE EIGHT SEVEN
NINE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JACK
AVERY ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE OPPOSED TO
MY MENDED I MEAN WE SUBMITTED
OUR MEN MEN WITH AFTER ACTING
OFFICE AND PORTAL WITH HER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHAT ARE MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT LINE AT ONE EIGHT NINE
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING VENTURA
NUMBERS THISIS RICHARD MARCUS
AND ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS AND
SEVEN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE P. L. A.
LANGUAGE IN SECTION FIVE OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. EIGHT NINE NINE FIVE YOU CAN
ENTER THE QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE
THEN IT IS ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THEN ZERO. EVERYONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO WITH THAT. WE
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
SENATOR MCGUIRE I APPRECIATE
YOUR STAYING HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FOR THE BILL. SO
WITHOUT ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE OR ANY OF
THE WITNESSES. YES MISTER
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU CENTER
REQUIRE FOR US BEING HERE TO.
ANSWERS SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS BILL FIRST OF ALL- WAS IT
WAS AN AMENDMENT TAKEN TO
DEFINE THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
PROJECT THAT HAS TO BE DEVOTED
TO HOUSING. WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC AMENDMENT REGARDING
THE ISSUE OF HOUSING WE'RE
SAYING THAT ANY HOUSING IS
BUILT AT LEAST WITHIN THE-
UNDER- 99515% WOULD BE
AFFORDABLE BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC. IF SB THIRTY FIVE X.
IN- IT'S A TWO THIRDS ONE THIRD
MIX- IN THAT IS TWO THIRDS-
HOUSING WINTER COMMERCIL BUT
IF THERE IS ANY SB THIRTY FIVE
PROVISION THAT WOULD KICK IN
REGARDS TO MONEY. AND COULD YOU
REMIND ME. SO THE SB THIRTY
FIVE PROVISION THAT WAS THE-
THE SCOTT WINNER BILL FROM A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT. IT'S SO
RIGHT NOW IT IT IS JUST THE
FIFTEEN FOR. 15% AFFORDABLE I'M
IN SO WILL TAKE AN EXAMPLE OF
LIKE A AND IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
A LARGE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT ULTIMATELY IT'S
GOING TO BE UP TO THAT- WHETHER
TO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR CITY
COUNCIL BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE MIX OF COMMERCIAL
HOUSING MAY BE. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHANGES IN REGARDS TO
THE HOUSING COMPONENT THIS
ISSUE IS THAT WE'RE NOW GOING
TO SAY THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
15% AFFORDABLE COMPONENT. NOW I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIRWOMAN BECAUSE THE
CHAIRWOMAN IS SAYING- ON HE
HOUSING PIECE. IS THAT- THE
INCLUSIONARY ZONING ORDINANCE
WOULD- TRUMP THE 15% AFFORDABLE
SO WE ALSO RESPECT THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCE
AMENDMENT THAT WAS PROVIDED BY
GERMAN FRIEDMAN IN INDIA IT
REALLY MAKES SENSE TO ALLOW
THAT FOR THAT LOCAL CONTROL
ESPECIALLY. IF IT'S A STRONGER
PROVISION- ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
15% BUT WHAT WOULD TO. PREVENT
LIKE SAY A PROJECT THAT THE
PROPOSES TO YOU KNOW WHAT 95%
COMMERCIAL AND 5% HOUSING- TO
QUALIFY A 5% OF THE HOUSING IS
DEVOTED TO IT MEETS THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
REQUIREMENT. WELL NO THAT THE
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE THAT
THAT'S JUST GONNA BE BASED ON
WHATEVER THE LOCAL HATS- SO
THAT'S THAT'S STRICTLY BASED
OFF OF LOCAL SO IF THERE IS IN
PLEASE SHERMAN PUSH BACK ON IF
YOU THINK COMING CORRECT ON
THIS. SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING
WITHIN THIS BILL NOW. WE'VE
CREATED A SECOND CATEGORY SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE HAVE THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CATEGORY
FOR THOSE LARGE- PROJECTS LIKE
WE SEEN WITH. STADIUMS SO-
UNDER THESE PROJECTS WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT THERE BEEN TEN
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS SINCE AB
NINE HUNDRED IS ADOPTED TEN
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS HAVE
EITHER BEEN BUILT. INDOOR
APPROVED OR GETTING BUILT NOW
IN THOSE THREE CATEGORIES
NUMBER ONE- THE SECOND A NEW
CATEGORY THAT WE'RE ADDING IS
WE'RE ACTUALLY ADDING THE SAME
JUDICIAL REVIEW SHOT CLOCK OF
THAT TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS.
FOR HOUSING PRICE. AT MILLION
DOLLARS GROSS COSTS OR MORE. IN
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE 15%
OF THE ENTIRE STOCK. AS
AFFORDABLE- AND- IF THERE'S
INCLUDE YOUR HOUSING- ZONING
ORDINANCE. WHETHER IT'S LA OR
SMALL COMMUNITIES WELL. THAT
WOULD BUT IF IT'S- MORE
AGGRESSIVE NOW I DON'T
UNDERSTAND ALL THAT BUT THAT
MIGHT. MY CONCERN IS THAT- THIS
CAN BE- AMENDED TOUTED AS A
HOUSING PRODUCTION BILL YEAH
BUT IF THIS IS. YOU KNOW ONE
GIANT LOOPHOLE TO. TO GET- 95%
COMMERCIAL PROJECT WITH A- VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE SHOULD DEVOTE
THE HOUSING- THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE SB THIRTY FIVE. WILL
MEETING S. B. FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY THIRTY FIVE THE
PROVISION THERE IS IF YOU HAVE
TO RESEARCH HOW. DOES TO THIRTY
HOUSING ONE. AT COMMERCIAL AND-
WILL BE ALLOWED TO. I THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION. THE
SECOND IS HOW. A IN TERMS OF
THE 15% INCLUSIONARY- HOUSE
HAVE FORMAL TO FIND. WE JUST
SAY FOR HOUSING SO THAT WOULD
BE WITHIN OUR THREE CATEGORIES
OF MIND A MODERATE LOW AND VERY
LOW. BUT WE DO NOT DISTINGUISH-
WHICH CATEGORY WOULD BE THAT
WOULD RECEIVE PREFERENCE WITHIN
NINE NINE FIVE. SO. THE
MODERATE. YEAH THE MODERATE TO
INCOME- WOULD QUALIFY FOR YEAH
MADRE YEAH WITHIN THOSE THREE
CATEGORIES AND I THINK THAT'S
THE OTHER IMPORTANT PIECE ABOUT
THIS IT WOULD ALLOW SOME
FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RIGHT- DEALING WITH
THAT 15% TO BE ABLE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT WHATEVER THEIR NUMBERS
MAY BE WHERE THEY NEED SHORT
AND ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE TO-
WORK THAT 15% DEPENDING ON
WHERE THE GREATEST NEED IS.
RELATED TO AFFORDABLE OKAY I
MEAN I CAN APPRECIATE THAT BUT
I THINK A- CENTER YOU YOU HAVE
A- COMMUNITIES ARE SIMILAR TO
MY COMMUNITIES WHERE. MY
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE THEY'RE
COMPLAINING THAT THE- THAT THE
THAT THE STATE IS TALKING ABOUT
THE- BUILDING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ALL THEY SEE IS- A
LUXURY HOUSING BEING BUILT. ON
AND- YOU KNOW WHY MODERATE TO
MODERATELY AFFORDABLE IS BETTER
THAN LUXURY. THE CONCERN IS
THAT. YOU KNOW THESE BILLS THAT
ARE BEING TOUTED AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SOLUTIONS ARE NOT. MORE
DIRECTLY- AND TO A GREATER
EXTENT- FOCUSING ON THE LOW AND
VERY LOW INCOME- SITES I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT POINT
THINKING WHO DOES HAVE A VERY I
THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT
WITH THAT IN REGARDS TO THIS
POINT IS THAT. WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT- ARE INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE ACROSS
THE STATE- EIGHT EXISTED PRIOR
TO THE CALL THE CRISIS IN IT IS
MORE EXASPERATED NOW IS IN
REGARDS TO THE ARE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK. WHAT I'LL SAY
IS- THAT THERE'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT IN REGARD TO
ADDING THAT 50% AFFORDABLE INTO
THIS MIX- THIS- WE HAVE NEVER
TOUTED THIS IS A 1100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILL BUT-
THIS YOU WILL SEE HOUSING
PRODUCTION AS PART OF THIS BILL
I DIDN'T SEE NINE. WAS FOR.
PASS IT WAS PASS BY THE STATE.
APPROXIMATELY TEN TO TWO
HUNDRED UNITS HAVE EITHER BEEN
BUILT. PERMITTED AND OR UNDER
CONSTRUCTION- AND NOW WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS WE NEED TO BE A
STRENGTH IN THIS- BY ADDING IT
CAN PERCENT OF- AFFORDABLE
COMPONENT. BUT I DO HEAR YOU
CENTER MURATSUCHI YOU'RE
ACTUALLY RIGHT IN REGARDS TO
THE CRISIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR ACCOUNT. LAST
QUESTION IS- IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THAT THE
PRO TEM IS NOT ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENT AS
IT RELATES TO THE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED REDUCTION- IF THAT IS
CORRECT YOU WILL. EXPLAIN WHY.
LOOK I THINK THAT HERE'S WHERE
WE ENDED UP I THINK WE THROUGH
THE COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
CHAIRWOMAN- COMMITTEE STAFF
INTO THE LEADERSHIP OF THE PRO
TEAM I THINK THAT- WE HAVE- A
BILL THAT IS MUCH MORE FOCUS ON
METRICS RELATED TO I. GHG.
REDUCTIONS AND- MISTER SOLOMON
YOU ARE CORRECT THAT WOULD AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THAT WE ARE
NOT. MOVING FORWARD ON THAT AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT I THINK ON
AB EIGHT NINE HUNDRED AND NOW
SB NINE NINE FIVE. WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE BALANCING
ACT- AND WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY THANKS TO
THE COLLABORATION BETWEEN-
PROTEIN MACHEN'S AS WELL AS THE
CHAIRWOMAN. IS A BILL THAT-
BRINGS FORWARD A MORE
AGGRESSIVE. A MORE AGGRESSIVE
APPROACH WHEN IT COMES TO-
WAYNE THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF THESE POTENTIAL PROJECTS.
AND LOOKING AT THE ACTUAL
ECONOMIC REALITY THAT WE'RE IN
NOW OF TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
GET- BOTH COMMERCIAL. RETAIL AS
WELL AS HOUSING BILLS- IN FOLKS
HIRED- AND THAT'S THE OTHER
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
BILL. IS THAT- IT IS FOCUSING
ON GETTING FOLKS CONNECTED TO
FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES- IN
WHAT WE KNOW IS SINCE THIS AB
NINE HUNDRED. APPROXIMATELY TEN
THOUSAND JOBS BEEN CREATED ON
THESE PROJECTS- BUT- AND THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF. F. A
STRIP SEAT BASED IN. THANKS TO
AGREEMENT I'D IS STRUCK TODAY
WE ENHANCED WHEN IT COMESTO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
MITIGATION SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
TOP PRIORITY WHEN IT COMES TO
MITIGATION WILL THOSE
MEDICATIONS. SIDE THEN A FEW.
OF THE MANY CONTENT SITE WILL
BE NEXT YEAR AND COMMUNITIES
AND IF YOU CAN DO THAT IT WOULD
BE WITH THE STATE OKAY IN THE
OTHER SICKENING. PIECES ON THE
HOUSING. WE ARE LOOKING AT HOW.
STANDARDS AGAIN. MUCH IMPROVED
FROM THE ORIGINAL AB NINE
HUNDRED- YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND OTHER ISSUES.
CERTAINLY I MEAN I APPRECIATE
TO. YOU KNOW THAT THAT- WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO RAISE THE
STANDARDS ON- IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. CONSIDERATIONS
SINCE AB NINE HUNDRED WAS WAS
ORIGINALLY PASSED HI I JUST
WANTED TO ASK ONE LAST. THE
QUESTION WHICH IS SAID TO BE
ON. THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
CITES A TWENTY NINETEENTH
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
REPORT- THAT. THAT TALKS ABOUT
THE PROBLEMS OF REVIEWS OF PAST
AB NINE HUNDRED PROJECTS-
DISCUSSES DISCUSSES THE OF A
PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF HOW IT
LOOKS LIKE. THE GHG EMISSION
REDUCTIONS HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
MANIPULATE MANIPULATION- AND
THAT- YOU KNOW YOUR OWN SENATE
ALSO RESEARCH ACTUALLY
RECOMMENDS THE ELIMINATION OF
THE USE OF GAC BASELINES AT TO
PROVIDE MORE ROBUST- LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS WITH ONE
OF THE OPTIONS BEING
RECOMMENDED THE VEHICLE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED TO THAT
THRESHOLD- COULD YOU COULD YOU-
RESPOND TO WHY THIS THIS BILL
IS NOT. DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT- THE
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH-
RECOMMENDED 100% SO I THINK ON
THE ISSUE OF VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED- I THINK THAT WE
ACTUALLY ARE SEEN- IMPROVEMENTS
AND ENHANCEMENTS UNDER SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY THREE- IN AS
YOU ALL KNOW THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH. HAS ALSO
BEEN FOCUS ON THE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED ON THE ISSUE OF THE
STUDY- I WILL GO BACK TO MR
SOMEONE IN IN READ- THE STUDY I
HAVE NOT READ JUST BE VERY
CANDID WITH YOU THE ENTIRE
STUDY. I THINK THAT IS CRITICAL.
WHAT IS IN FRONT OF TODAY IS
MUCH DIFFERENT THAN WHAT AB
NINE HUNDRED WAS- A FEW YEARS
AGO. AND IT'S THANKS TO THE
HARD WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE- IS
WELL AS THE COMMITMENT AND
LEADERSHIP APPROACH. AMERICANS
AGAIN WERE MOVING NEEDLE SO. ON
CREATING A NEW BASELINE WHEN IT
COMES TO THOSE SECRET STANDARDS
TO THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
ENHANCED- ENFORCEABLE STANDARDS
WHEN IT COMES TO GHG MITIGATION
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL-
AND WE ARE SUBJECTING HIGHER
SECRET STANDARDS TO HOUSING
PROJECTS AS WELL. BUT THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT- WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO CONTINUE TO TACKLE- YOU KNOW
THAT THE PROTEIN IS ONE OF THE
LEADING VIRAL VOICES- AS WELL
AS VOICES FOR. HOUSING IN THIS
LEGISLATURE- AND THIS MOVES US
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION KNOWING
THAT WE NEED TO DO MUCH MORE
WORK WHEN IT COMES TO-
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BOTH
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY AS WELL
AS THE GOVERNOR TO CONTINUE.
ACCENT NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER AND REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. IN LEADERSHIP
ARE TRULY. OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NO ONE ELSE- SO I WILL
I CLOSE BEFORE WE TAKE A VOTE I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO MEET WITH ME YESTERDAY AND
THE DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU AND
THE PRO TEM- AND THE HARD WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON THIS
BILL IT'S A COMPLICATED POLICY-
AND I THINK THAT THE BILL DOES
GO A LONG WAY ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE LOOPHOLES AND FIXES AN
OLD AB NINE HUNDRED. AND TO TRY
TO STRIKE THE BALANCE OF MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS A- BENEFIT
FOR PROJECTS THAT DEMONSTRATE
REAL ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
AND WELL I THINK THAT THE-
MEMONS. GOAL OF A LONG WAY AND
I KNOW THAT WE ARE VERY ALIGNED
IN TERMS OF THE GOALS THAT WE
HAVE I DO THINK THAT THERE'S
MORE WORK TO BE DONE WITH THE
DRAFTING AND- MAKING SURE THAT.
THE DETAILS ARE ARE REALLY IN
THE BILL SO THAT. THEY GIVE THE
OF CERTAINTY TO COMMUNITIES
THAT. DEVELOPERS CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF THE TRUNCATED
PROCESS. TO SHORT CHANGE- WITH
THE VERY LARGE PROJECTS- I
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT. WHAT I
SEE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
VAGUENESS WITH THE WORDS LIKE
USABLE BEST EFFORTS AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE AS WE GO FORWARD.
THAT THERE'S REALLY A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT DEVELOPERS
CHOOSE THAT MITIGATION FOR
INSTANCE ONSITE REAL WHEN
FEASIBLE. AND CONCERNED ABOUT
WHO DECIDES WHAT'S FEASIBLE
AND- TO THAT END I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE SOME- AGREEMENT HERE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO GIVE
INPUT AND- HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
SO THAT AT THE END WE ALL FEEL
COMFORTABLE. THAT WE SAFE GOING
TO DO THE MITIGATION THAT'S
FEASIBLE THAT THERE'S NO WAY
THEY CAN WE GO OUT AND SAY HEY
YOU KNOW I'M NOT FEASIBLE WE'RE
GONNA GO DO SOMETHING CHEAPER
SOMEWHERE ELSE. I THINK THAT
REALLY NAILING DOWN. HOW IT
WILL WORK IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPONENTS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT NEIGHBORHOODS
THEMSELVES GET THE MEDICATION
THAT THEY DESERVE. ALONG WITH
EXCELLENT PROJECTS SO IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU- AND THE
PROTON ARE WILLING TO ENTERTAIN
A KEEPING US INVOLVED IN JUST.
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE CONCERNS
ARE ADDRESSED SO I THINK THE-
AND I UNDERSTAND WHERE THAT
YOUR HOME IS COMING FROM IS
THAT THE WORD FEASIBLE IS
ACTUALLY IN LOVE WITH SEQUEL-
IN UNDERSTAND THAT IT SOUNDS
SQUISHY. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
CASE LAW AROUND IT CANDIDLY AND
AS YOU KNOW MEDICARE WE'RE
WILLING TO SIT DOWN ANY TIME IN
EVERY TIME YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TODAY TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
ON IT WAS COMMITMENT THAT. THE
PRO TEN EIGHT AND AGAIN THAT WE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY IN VERY
GREAT IT DOWN YESTERDAY AND
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AGAIN YOU CAN
SEE. COME AND I SAID I. THE
GOAL TO MAKE THAT WE GIVE
NUMBER FOR WORK. INSPECTION
DON'T GO TO PROVING IS A- SO I
APPRECIATE IN THE SECOND THIS
AS THE MOVES TO THE PROCESS.
I'VE MOSTLY A- THE WILL TO TAKE
THEM. AND TO HAVE THE AT THAT
SORT OF THIS LATE TIME IN THIS
TRUNCATED SCHEDULE THAT WE
HAVE- SO THANK YOU I'M VERY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. AND WITH THAT CAN WE
HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. I'M SORRY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE SIR THANK
YOU I'LL BE VERY QUICK IN ON
BEHALF OF- PROTEIN AMERICANS
AGAIN I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR WOMAN SHE HAS
BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH.
YOUR STAFF HAS BEEN WONDERFUL
TO WORK WITH. I THINK THAT
WHERE WE HAVE LANDED TODAY IS A
MUCH STRONGER PRODUCT MUCH
LONGER PRODUCT IN BRINGING
BALANCE ONE STRONGER WORK
PRODUCT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ISSUE OF. STRICTER
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS NUMBER
TWO CREATING A CATEGORY- WHEN
IT COMES TO HOUSING TO BE ABLE
TO HELP SOLVE THE HOUSING
CRISIS THAT EXISTS IN BIG
COMMUNITIES AND SMALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND THEN
NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL ESPECIALLY
IN CHALLENGE NUMBER TIME'S
MANAGER HAD TO BE ABLE TO CAL.
WORKING IS ABSOLUTELY KEY AS WE
MOVE INTO THIS DEEP ECONOMIC
RECESSION WERE STARING DOWN DUE
TO THE COVERED CRISIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS. WITH
THE CHAIR. THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
COMING OF A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PAY. AS A- IN
REFER TO. COMMITTEE SB NINE
NINE FIVE FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN
HI FLORA. FLORA ALL RIGHT CHAU.
JOE HI COMING HIM. CALLING HIM
ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI
GARCIA. MATHIS IN MY OFFICE ALL
RIGHT MCCARTY. MCCARTY ALRIGHT
HERE TO G. MARTUCCI NOT VOTING.
RIVAS RIVAS AYE STONE. THE BILL
HAS EIGHT BOOKS BILLS ABLE TO
BILLS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
HEY WE'RE MOVING ON TO S. B. AT
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN MISTER ALLEN
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
BEGIN TO QUEUE UP THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF S.
B. SEVEN FIVE SEVEN. MISTER
ALAN WELCOME. YEAH THANK YOU
THE CARD. BUT I DON'T CARE WHO
WILL BEGIN IN. OKAY WE CAN TAKE
OUT WELL ACTUALLY WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR I DON'T
THINK WE CAN TAKE ANOTHER
MOTION RIGHT NOW WELL WE HAVE
ALL OF WELL WE DO HAVE AN
OFFICE WHEN WE WAIT TILL WE
HAVE A- BREAK. WILL BE GOOD USE
OF TIME. WORKING FOR. THE SO
I'M WE DO HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND. WELCOME MR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I HAVE YOU TO GIVE
DETAILS THESE BILL BUT
EFFECTIVELY WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO EXPEDITE JUDICIAL REVIEW
FOR- LEADERSHIP TRANSIT
PROJECTS I KNOW YOU JUST HEARD
A LOT ABOUT LEADERSHIP. LOCUST
ON ALL THE BILL THAT WE HAVE TO
DO FOR LOS ANGELES IN ADVANCE
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY OLYMPICS
BUT- WE ALSO REALIZE THAT THERE
ARE SOME REALLY HIGH QUALITY
HIGH ENVIRONMENTAL VALUE
TRANSIT PROJECTS ELSEWHERE IN
THE STATE IS WHILE THEY WERE.
SEEKING TO INCLUDE SO HAPPY TO
TALK MOREABOUT THE DETAILS-
BUT I APRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE
HEARD THAT LONG BILL CLINTON
AND THAT SUPPORTS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO YOUR SUPPORT
WITNESS MICHAEL TURNER OPERATOR
IF MICHAEL TURNER ON THE LINE.
YES MISTER TURNER IS ON THE
LINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRAND
MEMBERS AS MICHAEL TERROR ON
BEHALF OF THE L. A. COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THINK OF
SENATOR ALAN FOR OFFERING THE
BILL AND LIKE TO ALSO THANK
SENATOR ATKINS BURGER CO
AUTHORSHIP. AND OF COURSE I
THINK YEAR THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH THE FINAL BILL
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
HELP SOME ADVANCE KEY TRANSIT
PROJECTS- NOT JUST IN LA BUT
ACROSS THE STATE OF THESE
PROJECTS ALL HAVE TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. AND ONCE AGAIN THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
THAT AND I THINK SENATOR ALAN
AND SENATOR AFTER THAT I WILL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF. THANK
YOU OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE UP FOR OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN AND WITNESSES
PLEASE JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION IF THERE IS ONE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD YOU MAY NEED TO PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WILL GO TO MY NUMBER NINETY
NINE LINE NINE NINE THE LINE IS
OPEN. NINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS IS OSCAR DAHLE SAID
WITH THAT YOU A LOCAL TO FIFTY
AND WITHOUT THE BILL INTRODUCED
WHAT- SENATE BILL SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. WE GO TO MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE LINE ONE
SEVEN FIVE. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS AS KIRK BLACKBURN ON
BEHALF OF CITY OF INGLEWOOD IN
SUPPORT. I WILL GO ON TO LINE
TWO TWO ZERO TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION ARE STILL
TEACHING DOESN'T YET HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE BILL AND PRINT IT
WANTED TO SPEAK TO JUST ONE
AGENCIES PROJECT. BUT AT THE
BILL HAD BEEN EXPANDED IT IS
SOMETHING WE ANTICIPATE A
SUPPORTING VERY SHORTLY TO
DIDN'T WANT IT PROVIDE
SUPPORTIVE COMMENT UP FOR THE
BILL HERE TODAY OKAY TO MOVE
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE. THANK
NEXT WE HAVE WHAT LINE. SIX SIX
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT RIGHT. THANK YOU LINE
SIXTY SIX IF YOU CAN CHECK YOUR
MUTE FEATURE WE DO HAVE THE
LINE OPEN. ENGINE MEMBERS AND
YOUR ENTRY ONTO THE HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI- WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL WE THINK THE AUTHOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR GOOD WORK.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE
LINE SEVEN FIVE. THE. YEAH YEAH
YEAH. GO AHEAD LINE SEVENTY
FIVE LINE IS OPEN. NINE SEVENTY
FIVE IF YOU CAN CHECK YOUR MUTE
FEATURE WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN
FOR YOU. HI MY NAME IS EARL
HAMPTON ON BEHALF OF IBEW LOCAL
UNION FIVE NINE FIVE WE ARE
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN THEIR SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR.
YEAH MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THAT IS LINE ONE
THREE TWO. I ONE THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE FEATURE. ONCE AGAIN LINE
ONE THIRTY TWO WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER SEVENTY. IT IS LINE
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT THE LINE IS
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE CREATURE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON THE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE LINE ONE THREE ONE.
ONE ONE THIRTY ONE THE LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO LINE SEVEN
TWO. NINE SEVENTY TWO THE LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY WE WILL MOVE ON
TO MY NUMBER FORTY TWO LINE FOR
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAVID
HANSON SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
START REPRESENTING LOCAL THREE
NINETY EIGHT- HEY YOU A LOCAL
THREE NINE EIGHT TWO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN-
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
GET INTO THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO. THANK
YOU WE HAVE ONE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY ONE ONE THREE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY ONE ONLINE IS
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. IN ONE THIRTY ONE IF YOU
CAN CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE.
OKAY THERE IS NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE ON THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
EIGHT LINE SEVEN EACH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING-
BENITO ROBINSON WITH THE PUBLIC
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL OF
LABORERS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THAT B. SEVEN FIVE SEVEN THANK
YOU. NEXT CALL OUR- I'M AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN YOU CAN ENTER THE QUEUE
BY PRESSING ONE THEN IF ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN LINE AT ONE ONE THREE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE ONE
THREE. IF IN ONE ONE THREE IF
YOU CAN CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE.
NO RESPONSE WE'RE GOING ON TWO
LINE NUMBER. OF FORTY THREE
LINE FOR THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FORTY THREE. ONE OF MY
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO LINE. SEVEN
TWO. NINE SEVENTY TWO THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SEVENTY TWO YOU CAN CHECK YOUR
MUTE FEATURE WILL. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO LINE TO
WORK YES GOOD MORNING HOLDEN
MICHELLE WITH THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THE CONCEPT OF THE BILL IN THE
COLORS ONE ONE THREE CONTINUED
WORKING- WITH THE DOCTOR ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
YOU MAY ENTER THE QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO. ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD AGAIN THAT IS
PRESSING ONE THEN IF ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE. YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE I DO HAVE MY
NUMBER- I DO HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SIX LET ME- TRY TO OPEN
THAT LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR COMMENT. NINE
SIXTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN FOR
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
THERE IS. A LEARNING TO USE ON.
HI THIS IS HAPPENING YOU SHOW
UP AND RUNNING BUT HE DROPPED
INSULATORS WE ARE A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
YOU WILL GO TO MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING WHEN MARK
TO BUILD HE CROSSES BORDERS WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. SEVEN FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
I HAVE MY NUMBER FORTY THREE
OUR LINE FOR THREE. YES THERE
GOES THE SECRETARY TREASURER
FOR LIGHTING THE LOCAL TO
TWENTY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. SEVEN FIVE SEVEN. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NOW THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM THE SUPPORTERS LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION CAN WE
PLEASE HAVE RICHARD MARX SON
AND ATTY LEAP UP. BOMB QUEUED
UP AND I THINK THAT MR MARKS ON
WILL BE SPEAKING FIRST. AND HE
IS ON THE LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. YEAH GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RICHARD MARX AND ON
BEHALF THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL.
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
VERY NARROW UP OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE. OF INCLUDING A
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL. OF THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE- THAT WAS
ENACTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED. A CREATE
SPECIFIC PENALTIES FOR FAILURE
TO COMPLY WITH THE STATE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENT- THE LANGUAGE AND
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN. EXEMPTS
CONTRACTORS WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT FROM
THESE PENALTIES. SETTING UP A
TWO TIER SYSTEM. IN THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE ONE WE'RE
CONTRACTORS CAN BE FINED UP TO.
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE AND-
POTENTIAL DEPARTMENT. AND
ANOTHER ONE WHERE THERE ARE
ONLY SUBJECT TO UP POTENTIAL A
SLAP ON THE WRIST OF SUBJECT TO
THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT. WE
OPPOSE THIS POLICY CONSISTENTLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. I THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR ANDY WE'VE
BEEN BOND JUDICIAL COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN UNLESS AMENDED THE
TYPICALLY TO EXTEND THE RULE
MAKING PROVISION IN THE BILL
FROM JULY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO JULY TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TO REMOVE
THE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAY
EXPEDITED REVIEW PROVISION-
PLEASE NOTE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL DOES NOT A PINE ON THE
MERITS WELL YOU ARE IMPORTANT
TO ME OF THE- JACK. THE COUNCIL
ROCK THE ONE YEAR DEAL IN
EMPLOYMENT OF ANY LETTER. THAT
THE COUNCIL AMEND OR DRAFT NEW
WILL THE COURT. JUST DELAY
ENSURES THAT THE COUNCIL MAY
FAITHFULLY UNDERTAKE THE
MONTHLONG INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
PUBLIC REVIEW AND FEEDBACK
PROPERTIES REQUIRED FOR THE
ADOPTION. OF NEW OR MODIFIED
RULES. AND IN THE CASE OF SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN THE PROPOSAL I
WON TWENTY TWENTY ONE DEADLINE
FOR ENACTING RULES SIMPLY IS
NOT ACHIEVABLE THE IMPOSITION
OF A TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DAY TIMELINE FOR REVIEW OF THE
TWENTY EIGHT BY TWENTY EIGHT
HELLER PROJECT. ON TOP OF
EXISTING CALENDAR PREFERENCES
THAT EXISTENCE EQUAL CASES IS
UNREALISTICALLY SHORT- FOR THAT
TRIAL COURT IN LOS ANGELES TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT
EACH OF THE CASES IS LIKELY TO
PREVENT. ESPECIALLY RELATED TO
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. EVEN WITH THE
LANGUAGE THAT REFERENCES TO THE
EXTENT FEASIBLE. AND IN FACT-THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS WHY
THE TIME FRAME IS FROM THE VERY
OUTSET NOT YOU THE BALL. THE
FIRST IS THAT HE COULD CASES
ARE INHERENTLY TIME CONSUMING
IN MOST CASES THERE ARE PARTIES
ON EITHER SIDE MANY. ARE FOR
DELAY OR CAN YOU IN THIS EVEN
IN THOSE. WHERE THAT AND- TO
HAPPEN. THERE'S ARE GOING TO BE
MAYBE FIVE TO SIX MONTHS BEFORE
A CASE. GET GET TO TRY A LITTLE
TO ADDRESS. AND THE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL WHAT X. FACTOR IT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DATE
ALL INCLUDES OKAY TWEET THANK
YOU UNREAL OF. US I CAN LEE
ACTIVE OKAY ALL AND AN AREA.
AND NON D. COULD YOU DO REVIEW
OR APPEALED THE MIDST OF THE
CASES BOTH CASES WILL REQUIRE A
STAY AT THE INITIAL. AND THEN
TO MAKE THE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
DATE TIMELINE ON FEASIBLE. AND
THEN FINALLY GIVEN THE CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCE THE PANDEMIC THE
COURTS AND I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE TO ANTICIPATED A
SIGNIFICANT PANDEMIC WITH MEDIC
GEN. RELATED TO UNLAWFUL.
ACTION HELLO. DO YOU WANT THEM
TO QUEUE UP BY PRESSING ONE
THEN ZERO HOWEVER THEY QUEUE UP
THEY CAN QUEUE UP BUT IT'S TIME
FOR ALL OPPOSITION OKAY IS TO
SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN. OKAY OF
THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU ARE A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE QUEUING
UP OKAY THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND-
YES MISTER MERCIFULLY. SENATE
ALLEN COULD YOU RESPOND TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL CONCERNS THAT
THAT SHE RAISED REGARDING GOT.
THE RESOLUTION THE IN HER
OPINION THE UNREALISTICALLY
SHORT TO IN A SEVENTY DAY. TIME
PERIOD FOR BUT I MEAN I KNOW
THERE WAS A CONCERN THAT'S
THERE WAS PROP IN THE LAST BILL
I MEAN I THINK THE ONE I
SUPPOSE THE BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE LAST ON THIS ONE IS
THAT. WERE REALLY THERE ARE
VRY FEW PROJECTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE COVERED UNDER THIS
BILL IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF
THINGS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAJOR TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS-
THEY'RE BEING YOU KNOW CARRIED
OUT BY PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT
HAVE YEAH THAT IS WHOSE
PROCESSES ARE FULLY. BEEN TO
THE PUBLIC INVENTED AND YOU
KNOW IT AND THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THEIR OWN PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT ROCESS- SO YOU KNOW
THESE ARE NOT PROJECTS THAT ARE
ARE. THEY STILL TO GO THROUGH A
FULL ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AS
PART OF THIS BILL BUT BUT WE'RE
NOT TAUGHT THIS BILL IS NOT
GOING TO. CREATE A WHOLE NEW
SLEW OF EXPEDITED REVIEW
PROJECTS AND WE'RE WE'RE- WE'RE
TALK ABOUT MAJOR PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS- FIVE TEN. PROJECTS
HERE A STATEWIDE- AND MAYBE
FIFTEEN THAT WILL BE COVERED
UNDER THE PARAMETERS OF THIS
BILL. SO I APPRECIATE THE
ARGUMENTS I'VE HEARD THEM FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS I ONLY THINK
WE OUGHT TO BETTER FIND OUR
COURT SYSTEM. WE PUT THEM IN A
AND IN A VERY DIFFICULT PLACE.
BUT YOU KNOW- WITH RESPECT HIM
DEEP RESPECT TO THE COUNCIL I
DON'T THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
CAMEL'S BACK THAT'S RIGHT WE
DON'T HEAR FROM HER ON THE LAST
ALRIGHT. I KNOW THEY'VE
TRADITIONALLY RIGHT I MEAN THEY
THEY'VE TRADITIONALLY OPPOSE
BILLS LIKE THAT HERE. YEAH HE
WAS AND THAT THE QUEUE IN THE
LAST BILL YEAH- SO WHY I WOULD
JUST WANTED I APPRECIATE THE-
THE RESPONSE AS I. TOLD YOU
YESTERDAY I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND- I.
SUPPORT TO. THE EFFORTS TO
EXPEDITE THE TWENTY BY TWENTY
EIGHT PROJECTS. SO THAT LOS
ANGELES IS READY- FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPICS-
AND- WE HAVE HOPEFULLY. OUR
TRANSIT TO UP AND RUNNING
BEFORE THE OLYMPICS- WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU CAN ADD ME
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE BILL- AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. THE JOHN THANK YOU
BRING THE BILL FORD THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND. WE
WERE I DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS JUST I WANT DO YOU WANT
TO. AT THANK YOU STAY AND ON
THE HARD WORK THE COMMITTEE.
WITH MY STAFF WITH OUR- TO GET
THIS BILL THE GOOD PLACE AND
SO. WITH THAT I ASKED FOR I
HAVE A- THANK YOU CAN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL POLICE WITH A MOTION
AND A SECOND. BILLS AMENDED.
OKAY ESPYS. FIVE SEVEN MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN HI FLORA.
FLORA HIGH CHAU. SHALL I
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GARCIA. GARCIA NOT VOTING
MATHIS- MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI AYE MURATSUCHI II
RIVAS. RIVAS SIZED. BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES THANK YOU MISTER
ALLEN YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY AN OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE START QUEUING
THE WITNESSES HE COMPLETES
ARGUING THE WITNESSES UP
OPERATOR FOR SB THIRTEEN HEALTH
MISTER ALLEN. EVEN IN A SECOND
THANK YOU HAVE ONCE MAJORS TO
YOUR YOUR ABLE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL THIS IS THIS IS A
BILL IT'S GOING TO SAVE THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY- VALUABLE TIME AND
RESOURCES BY ALLOWING THEM TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS ENCROACHMENT
ISSUES AND LET NEGOTIATIONS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IT PUTS SOMEONE
PARITY. WITH OTHER- IRAQI EVAN
SEES AFTER FOR. SOME REASON
THEY WERE KIND OF OUT OF WHACK.
WERE GETTING THAT A ADDRESS OF
THIS BILL AND- WITH TODAY I GOT
I'VE GOT- JEFF MOLONEY USED.
STAFF COUNSEL AT THE CENTER ON
CONSERVANCY TO SPEAK. ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN PLEASE. PUT OUR
MISTER MALONEY ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MISTER MALONEY IS OUT
ON THE PHONE AND HE HAS AN OPEN
LINE HI HI GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- MY NAME'S JEFF
BALLARI CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY. THAT QUICKLY THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THANKS OF COURSE TO CENTER
ALLEN TO TURN THIS BILL. AS YOU
OCCURRED THIRTEEN EIGHTY IS
RELATIVELY MINOR CHANGE THE
CONSERVANCY ENABLING
LEGISLATION PARTICULAR
POTENTIALLY THINK. POSITIVELY
IMPACT. AFTER GRANTS AND OTHER.
YES SIR AND YOUR EIGHTY
THOUSAND OF SPACE PARK LAND A
ROW. THE LA AREA. IT ALSO WERE
FIONA THOUSANDS OF A TO THE
STATE AND AREA LIKE LA YOU CAN
IMAGINE THIS MANY OF OUR PARK
LANDS. ABOUT MANY RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES IN OVER THE YEARS-
ESPECIALLY WITH THE IMPROVEMENT
OF GPS AND SPATIAL MAPPING
TECHNOLOGY WE DISCOVERED THE
EXISTENCE OF A WIDE RANGE OF
PHYSICAL. FROM PRIVATE
PROPERTIES ONTO STATE LAND.
TRANSLATOR CAN RANGE SMALL
VEGGIE GARDENS TWO DRIVEWAYS
SWIMMING POOL TENNIS COURTS AND
OCCASIONALLY EVEN BUILDINGS.
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE INSIDE
THE INCLUSIONS VIOLATION OF
STATE PROPERTY. CONSTITUTES
POTENTIAL DESTRUCTION ABOUT TO
HAVE A CHAT AND IT ALSO CREATES
LIABILITY FOR THE STATE SO
DEPENDING ON THE FACT THAT
SITUATION CONSERVANCY OF
SEVERAL OPTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
CORRECTIONS. FROM CRIMINAL FOR
SPENT TO I'M GETTING THE
PROPERTY OWNERS TO REMOVE THE
IMPROVEMENTS BUT THIS FELT BILL
OUT ANOTHER TOOL TO THE
CONSERVANCY'S. GET TO ADDRESS
SITUATIONS WORK MIGHT NOT MAKE
SENSE TO PURSUE CRIMINAL
CHARGES. OR FORCED THE MOBILE
OF THE TRUMP SPECIFICALLY
CONSERVATIVE THE RESOLUTION OF
A COURTROOM DISPUTES BY
ALLOWING THE- COUNTRY TO
ACQUIRE PORTIONS OF REAL
PROPERTY. AS A POTENTIAL
PARTNER THE PROPERTY TRADE WITH
THE CONSERVANCY WOULD ALLOW AND
COACHING PROPERTY TO TAKE TITLE
TO THE AFFECTED AREA. OKAY UP.
LANCE THE CONSERVING. GEN
WORKING WITH DID YOU ON THE-
HALF OF THAT AT THE ALREADY
ADDRESS WHERE STAFF. SO THIS IS
A ONGOING. AND ONE THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO GO IN THIS BILL
JUST PER MY NEEDED STRUCTURE AS-
TRAFFIC REDUCE LIVE. AND
INCREASED. EFFICIENCY SECOND
ANSWERING THAT THEY YOU FOR
LONG IS. OPERATOR DURING ON THE
RIGHT ON THE PHONE LINES. I'M
SORRY WEEK I COULD I REALLY
COULDN'T HEAR YOU. I'M SORRY
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES.
I DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE AS A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE OKAY DO WE HAVE ANYONE
WANTING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ON THE
LINES. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE THREE
EIGHT ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN YOU MAY NEED TO
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS IF YOU ARE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE. AS YOU'D
LIKE TO GET INTO THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION. OF F. B. ONE THREE
EIGHT ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FEAR AFTER TIME. ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN NINE
ONE SIX SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS NATALIE MAX ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD PLAN TRUST AND
SUPPORT. ANYONE ELSE ON THE
LINES. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB ONE
THREE EIGHT ZERO YOU MAY ENTER
THE PHONE QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD. NO ONE QUEUING UP PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DOES ANYBODY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR OR THE WITNESSES.
SEEING THAT MR ALLEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I KNOW WHAT THIS
IS THE CONSERVANCY OFTEN HAS
THESE VERY MINOR ENCROACHMENTS
SOMEONE'S. BUILDING A DRIVEWAY
OR SWIMMING POOL ON CONSERVANCY
LAND THAT STATE LAND THAT THEN
TRIGGERS. DO YOU HAVE A VERY
SIMPLE LAND SWAP. HE JUST ENDS
UP BEING MORE COSTLY AND TIME
CONSUMING THAN- THE THEN THEN
THE NEEDS TO BE AND THAT
SOMETIMES I IS OFTEN MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN IT'S WORTH THIS
ADDRESSED THIS ISSUE TO MAKE IT
A LITTLE EASIER FOR THEM TO DO
THEIR WORK AND FOR THEM TO WORK
WITH THE COMMUNITY. AND UP AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE RUNNING THE
BANK. THANK YOU FOR THE MOST A
SECOND FROM A ROLL PLEASE. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI FLORA.
LAURA CHAO CHAO HIGH
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH
GARCIA GARCIA HI MATHIS. MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI. RIVAS
STONE. BHILAI SEVEN VOTES THANK
YOU THE BILL IN COMMITTEE NOTES
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR IT
ABSENT MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON
TO. DO WE HAVE ANY AUTHORS HERE
PRESENT. THANK YOU COULDN'T SEE
WHO IT WAS. WE'RE MOVING ON TO
SB NINE EIGHTY NINE MISTER A
SENATOR DOLLY MOVIE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER DALI WOULD YOU LIKE 2%
WE LOVE. THE AREA OF WORRY LIKE
WHERE YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I- THIS
IS A BILL TO. INCREASE THE
TERRITORY BOUNDARIES FOR THIS
YEAR ABOUT A CONSERVANCY TO ADD
SISKIYOU COUNTY. PARTS OF
SHASTA THE PARTS OF TRINITY.
CERTAIN ABOUT CONSERVANCY HAS
HAD AN EXCELLENT TRACK RECORD
UNIFYING IN COMPLETING FORCE
MANAGEMENT. THE RESILIENCE
PROJECTS WITHIN THEIR REGION
ENSURING THAT THESE VERY
IMPORTANT HEADWATERS REMAIN
HEALTHY AND ARE FORCED OR MORE
FIRE RESILIENT. GIVEN THE GIVEN
THE STATUS OF THINGS WITH KOBE
NINETEEN IS NOW MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TO KEEP OUR FORCE
FIRE RESILIENT GIVING THE FACT
THAT. MORE PEOPLE ARE VISITING
THESE AREAS DUE TO ACTIVITIES
BEING CLOSED DOWN. BY
INCREASING THE BOUNDARIES OF
THE CONSERVANCY TO INCLUDE THE
TRINITY WATERSHED. IT ENSURES
THAT THESE HEADWATERS REMAIN
TOGETHER UNDER. ONE MANAGEMENT
ENTITY TO ENSURE THAT THESE-
IMPORTANT MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
CAN CONTINUE IN A ROBUST MANNER
MEMBERS THIS IS YOUR FOR BILL-
I SIMPLY ENSURE THE IMPORTANT
WATERSHEDS ARE INCLUDED UNDER
THE SAME CONSTRAINTS THE
UMBRELLA. FOR RIVAL AND I WILL
BE. THERE CAN AMENDMENT AND I
WOULD APPRECIATE AND I HAVE A-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR SMILE
EVEN THE RASCAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND JUST TO CLARIFY THE
MOTION WAS FOR THE BILL AS
AMENDED CORRECT. OKAY OPERATOR.
IN THE LINES AT FEW OF THE- FOR
A- NINETY NINE. OUR FIRST
WITNESS WHO HOPEFULLY IS ON THE
PHONE IS LAUREL HARKNESS. HE IF
MISS HARKNESS IS ON THE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. JUST A
MOMENT AYE AYE WE DO HAVE THE
WITNESS OF DIALING IN JUST ONE
MOMENT. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE DO
HAVE LAUREL HARKNESS ON THE
PHONE. OKAY. GLOBAL PARTNERS
CAN GO AHEAD. WELL MY KANSEN
I'M REPRESENTING A FEW OUTDOOR
RECREATION ALLIANCE I'M HERE
ALSO REPRESENTING MY TWO KIDS
ARE GROWN UP IN MOUNT SHASTA
HIKING MOUNTAIN BIKING SKIING
SNOWBOARDING KAYAKING CLIMBING
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HERE IN ABOUT A CONSERVANCY WAS
ESTABLISHED THROUGH LEGISLATION
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR AT THAT
TIME THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
QUEUE COUNTY WAS APPROACHED AND
INVITED TO BE PART OF THE
REGION THEY DECLINED BUT IF
YOU'RE NOT A CONSERVATIVE
ESTABLISHED THERE IS FOREVER
BEEN A SHARP AWKWARD AND THE
THING FROM THE REGION IN THE
NORTHWEST CORNER THAT REPRESENT
IMAGE OF FIFTY. FORWARD A FEW
YEARS IN THE- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MY CLASS IS IF YOU
COUNTY MORE OF THE- YOU KNOW.
SUPPORTED A- TO WORK LEGISLATE
TOWARD THE ADJUSTMENT OF THE
SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY
BOUNDARIES. TO INCLUDE SISKIYOU
COUNTY. THANKFULLY SENATOR
DOLLY WAS WILLING TO CHAMPION
THE BILL SB NINE EIGHTY NINE
COULD ADDRESS DEGRADATION
CRITICAL SOURCE WATERSHEDS
INCLUDING THE UPPER SACRAMENTO.
MCCLOUD AND PET WATERSHED LIVED
WITH YOU COUNTY BY INCLUDING
THEM AT LAST YEAR AND ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY REGION. IN
WATERSHED OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE TO WATER SUPPLYING
QUALITY HABITAT AND
BIODIVERSITY OUTDOOR RECREATION
AND FOREST CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. THE WATER SAID
THERE SIGNIFICANTLY DEGRADED
AND AT RISK OF FURTHER
DETERIORATION FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE. A BACKLOG OF WORK
MANAGEMENT TREE MORTALITY AND
DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS AND NOW
WITH THE PANDEMIC. AMOUNT
HAPPENED FIFTY COUNTY REGION IS
EXPERIENCING AN UNPRECEDENTED
THIRD AND VISITORS WHO ARE HERE
TO EXPERIENCE. CREDIBLE NATURAL
OUTDOOR RECREATION AMENITIES.
BUT RINGING THESE SORT SAID
UNDER THE NEVADA CONSERVANCY.
THIS BILL COULD PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE
CAPITOL. THE AT POTENTIALLY
THREE P. ON A VATICAN. WATER
SAID AND PROGRAM WHICH TO
APPROACH. ISSUES COMP AND
WORKING ON FIVE. GOAL HEALTHY
WATER THE BOY OF THREE.
COMMUNITY BY RECORD AND TOURISM
STRATEGIC PLANS COME. IMPACT
READ I'VE BEEN. THE WORK
ATMOSPHERE IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY ALSO ADVANCES
CRITICAL STATE PRIORITIES
INCLUDING MAKING COMMUNITY
THINK. ABOUT REDUCING EMISSIONS
INCREASING WATERFALL QUALITY
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY
DEVELOPING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN RURAL AREAS
AND HELPING THE STATE ADOPTED
CLIMATE CHANGE CLIMATE. IF YOU
COUNTY RIGHT FIFTY FIFTH OF
FIFTY COUNTY AND- MEDIAN INCOME
ALSO FIFTY COUNTY RANKED FIFTY
SEVENTH OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTING CALIFORNIAN PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTCOMES. PART OF THE
STATE BUT MEASURE BECAUSE THAT
ADVANTAGE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
IMPORTANT AREA BE INCLUDE IN
THE SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY
WOULD HELP US TO LEVERAGE.
TECHNICAL AND- RESOURCES
COMPETITION. THE DALLAS FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP I URGE I HOPE.
THANK YOU IS EASY MART THE NEXT
ON THE- I VERY ELIZABETH MARTIN
GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES IT IS IMPORTANT. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE ALL RIGHT MARTIN THE CEO
OF THE FUNDS WE'RE BASED IN THE
SIERRA AND OUR MISSION IS TO
RESTORE ECOSYSTEMS WILL
COMMUNITY RESILIENCY TO OUR
REGION. WE WERE SPONSORS OF THE
LEGISLATION ESTABLISHING THE
GROUP HERE IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR AND AT THAT TIME WE AIMED
AT CREATING A BADLY NEEDED
QUORUM FOR COLLABORATION
BETWEEN. YEAH COUNTY IN FEDERAL
BETTER GOVERNMENTAL A- THAT
SERVE THE SIERRA NEVADA. OVER
THE LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS THE
ZERO COULD CONSERVANCY HAVE
HONED IMPROVING ITS CAPACITY TO
DELIVER A GREAT PROGRAM THAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE THERE
WITNESSING FROM SENATOR DOLLY
MOST RECENTLY THE LEGISLATURE
HAS GIVEN THEM A VARIETY OF
TOOLS FROM FUNDING TO POLICY
THAT WORK. TO HELP SUPPORT THE
CONSERVANCY VISIONARY WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM AT THE TOP
OF THAT TO APPEAR AND DISAPPEAR.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE DATA. THAT
THE Y. THAT REPRESENTS THE TO
REACH IT IS VITAL TO EVERYONE.
SENATOR DOLLY AN EARLY
SUPPORTER OF THE TENSION B. AS
A VAN CAL LASSEN COUNTY SUPER
FIGHTER BRINGS THIS BILL
FORWARD WITH OUR SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THE
LEGISLATURE TO BRING THESE
DESPERATELY NEEDED. NEW
RESOURCES TO THE REGION
ADDRESSED IN THE BILL WHICH IS
THE EXTENT THE CONSERVANCY
BOUNDARY THAT ACCOMPLISH.
FEELING. TRINITY COUNTY. MAY IT
SEEM THAT THE L. A. E. JUST
PRODUCE THIS. THE NEW. CALL FOR
INCREASE HEALTH THREE TO THE
INVITE AND HAZARDS CAUSED BY A
DOWNED IN MIND. MANY OF YOU ON
THIS COMMITTEE KNOW THAT THE PR
FUND HAS BEEN RAISING THAT
ISSUE NOT BECAUSE MINING BUT
BECAUSE THAT THAT THE FOOTPRINT
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FROM. HISTORIC ACTIVITIES OR
THE MINE THIS REPORT CULTURE
BETTER COORDINATION TO ADDRESS
THE CRITICAL NEED. TO IMPROVE
THE PACE AND SCALE OF MINE
REMEDIATION. THE LEGACY MINES
ARE THROUGHOUT THE FOURTH AND
OTHER THAN THE TARGETED REGIONS
OF THIS LEGISLATION BRING TO
MIND GARDEN HEAVILY. LAND IN
OUR STATE MOST OF WATER. UNDER
THE COORDINATED ABOUT OF ABOUT
ACCOUTREMENT PAGE A FABULOUS
BECAUSE OF GOOD GUYS DOING
BECAUSE. THE BILL ABOUT THE
LEAD. FOCUS FOR PA DIRECTOR TO
THE STATE I DON'T HAVE WHAT IN
Q. WATER SHE- ALLEGED. HAS
ALREADY TARGETED THESE WATERS
CAN BE THE RISK LIKE THIS. CHAO
BY MR BLOEMEN DR. THEN ALLOW TO
CONSERVANCY TO TAKE HIS
INITIATIVE MOVEMENT ACTION IN
THESE CRITICAL WATERSHED BY
CALL FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
WANT TO THANK MISTER DALI FOR
CARRYING THE LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE IT'S- OF SB
NINE. EIGHTY NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. NINETY EIGHT NINETY
MAKE IT INTO THE QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD WE DO HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO THIRTY THREE
THAT PLANE TWO THREE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
STACEY HEATING RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I DON'T
THINK IT'LL BE JUST ONE MORE
MOMENT. THANK YOU ONE MORE
MOMENT FOR NEXT CALLING. LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO TWO NINE.
HELLO HEREBY ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND TROUT
UNLIMITED AND SUPPORT. THANK
THAT GENTLEMAN IF YOU ARE RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INSUBORDINATE SB NINE EIGHT
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF F. B. NINE EIGHT
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. NO ONE QUEUING UP
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'LL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NOTHING MISTER
DOLLY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I WANT TO JUST A THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND I WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR HELPING US IS PROCESS UNDER
THIS DIFFICULT TIME AND- I MISS
YOU ALL AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
AN IPHONE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WE HAVE
ROLL CALL PLEASE. SB NINE EIGHT
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED OVER. CAN
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN HI FLORA.
FLORA ALRIGHT CHAU. SO I
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GARCIA. AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY. MURATSUCHI
READ. RIVAS HI STONE. THE BILL
HAS SEVEN VOTES SEVEN VOTES
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN PRESENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT WAS NICE
SEEING YOU AS WELL I SEE
SENATOR HUESO FOR SB THIRTY NO
ONE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE KEEP UP THE WITNESSES
FOR SB THIRTEEN OH ONE WELL THE
AUTHOR GIVES HIS TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY. MY
TRANSMITTING HERE YES YOU ARE
COULD VERY WELL GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME PRESENTES BE THIRTEEN OH
ONE. I'D LIKE TO GIVE SPECIAL
THANKS TO YOU MISTER WOMAN FOR
AND OF COURSE YOUR STAFF FOR
THE NORMANS HELP IN HELPING US
TO IRON OUT. OF THIS BILL TO A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- FIRST OF
ALL I'D LIKE TO STATE THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING.THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF.
A COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN
PLAGUED BY. POLLUTION AND OF
RAW SEWAGE FLOWS THAT COME INTO
NOT ONLY IS COMMUNITY SUPPORTED
TO THE OCEAN OF COURSE AFFECT
SO MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES AND
CITIES AROUND THE COAST OF SAN
DIEGO ON AN AVERAGE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED GALLONS OF SEWAGE FLOW
FROM MEXICO INTO THE QUAN A
RIVER VALLEY TO INACTION AND
RAM PROBLEMS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL HERE IN THE US AND THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN I OFFERED SB FIVE OH
SEVEN WHICH AUTHORIZES ANNUAL
COUNTY TO CONDUCT A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT- ON ON THE CUENTA
RIVER VALLEY THAT REPORT WAS
RECENTLY RELEASED AND INCLUDES
A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY
IDENTIFYING TWENTY SEVEN
PROJECTS WHICH WILL GREATLY
REDUCE IMPACTS- TO THE RIVER
VALLEY. FROM TRANS BOUNDARY
FLOWS BASED ON STUDY- BASED ON
THIS STUDY USMC RECENTLY
ALLOCATED THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEY- THE PROJECT HOWEVER I
HAS IDENTIFIED THAT IN ORDER TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS WE NEED. A
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS DIVERTER THAT WILL
CAPTURE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
MILLION GALLONS OF RAW SEWAGE
PER DAY. THIS WILL ESSENTIALLY
STOP POLLUTION AFTER AFTER
ALMOST FORTY YEARS BUT-
UNFORTUNATELY ONLY PARTIALLY.
SO WHILE WE HAVE SOME RESOURCES
IT'S NOT ENOUGH AND IN ORDER
FOR US TO. DO THIS SUCCESSFULLY
WE REALLY HAVE TO GO BEYOND
WHAT A ONE SINGLE PROJECT CAN
ACCOMPLISH AND I'M WORKING VERY
HARD TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
COUNTRY OF MEXICO AND WITH THE
STATE ABOUT CALIFORNIA. AND ALL
THE OFFICIAL BUT HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE SEWAGE TREATMENT. OUR
SYSTEM AT THE QUANAH TO SEE
WHAT ELSE THAT WE CAN DO THAT-
IS MORE FEASIBLE. WELL WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO RESOLVE THE
MAJORITY OF THIS THESE
PROBLEMS. THE CITY OF TIJUANA
WE EXPECT WILL CONTINUE TO GROW.
AND OFTENTIMES THAT GROWTH
COMES WITH DISCONNECTION TO THE
SEWER SYSTEM. AND WE COULD
EXPECT THAT WE WILL CONTINUE AS
THE CITY GROWS THIS PROBLEM
CONTINUE TO GROW LYSIS
ADDRESSED. SO WE HAVE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL. WHICH
WOULD CREATE A- A MITIGATION
PROGRAM- ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER. THAT WOULD OF AN
ESSENCE CREATE A WATERSHED STE.
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY TO ENSURE
THAT AS OF THE CITY OF TIJUANA
CONTINUES TO GROW. THAT. THEY
TAKE MEASURES TO PREVENT RUN
OFF AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ASK
WELL HOW COULD WE WRITE A BILL
THAT WILL COMPEL MEXICO TO DO
ANYTHING WE REALLY CAT BUT WHAT
WE CAN. DO IS PUT UP CALIFORNIA
AND IN A POSITION. TO ADVOCATE
FOR THIS PROBLEM. AND AS WE
ALLOCATE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SOME OF THAT MONEY MAY
GO. TO BE SPENT ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE BORDER. THAT'S WHY THE
TIME THE BILL IS ESSENTIAL TO
GETTING THIS BILL OUT. IN THE
NEXT A FEW MONTHS. IS GOING TO
BE ESSENTIAL TO MAKE
MAINTAINING. SUIT TO GIVING
CALIFORNIA LEVERAGE ON HOW
THOSE FUNDS FUNDS ARE SPENT.
AND ADDING THIS TO ANY WORK
PLAN THAT WE CAN AGREE TO WITH
MEXICO WITH THROUGH THE
ALLOCATION OF THOSE FUNDS. SO
IF I CAN IT RE EXPLAIN THAT. IN
BEFORE WE INVEST A PENNY I'D
LIKE THERE TO BE A COMMITMENT
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER
TO RESOLVE THISPROBLEM ONCE
AND FOR ALL TO A LONG TERM
STRATEGY AND THIS BILL
ESSENTIAL IT WILL GIVE
CALIFORNIA THEM GOSHI EIGHTY
POWER JUST DOWN WITH WHAT THE-
REPRESENTATIVES MEXICO AND EAT
AND INCLUDE THIS IN A PACKAGE
OF A- OF RELIEF TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM. AND RIGHT NOW IF WE
WAIT ANOTHER YEAR WE'RE GONNA
LOSE THIS OPPORTUNITY. AND
POSSIBLY NOW REALLY DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN EVER TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IS A LOT OF
MONEY. AND AT ANY COULD GO
ENORMOUS OF WAY TO SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM AND I THINK THAT IF WE
DO IT RIGHT WE CAN SOLVE THE
ENTIRE PROBLEM WITH THESE FUNDS
AND ADDING THIS. ADDING THIS
BILL TO THAT NEGOTIATION WILL
REALLY HELP US SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM ONCE AND FOR ALL SO I
WE DIDN'T WE HAVE A SUPPORTERS
BUT BECAUSE OF THE PROCESS
WE'VE WE'VE- WE HAVE TO.
DECIDED NOT TO HAVE THEM-
PRESENT. AND I'D LOVE TO HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS REPORT
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP NOT
ONLY ONE OF THE MOST TREASURED.
ECOLOGICAL AREAS IN OUR COUNTRY
TO DECLARE VALLEY A RAMSAR SITE.
AND HELP TO- IT CLEANER OCEANS
BEACHES THERE ARE CLOSED. TO
AND FIFTY OF THE YEAR BECAUSE
OF THIS RUNOFF. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I'M SURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FIRST
FOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN OH ONE. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A CEILING AND- OKAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN- IF YOU
ARE IN. ARE WE ON SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION AND VERY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THREE ZERO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF F.
B. ONE THREE ZERO ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND.
TWENTY NINE NINE TWO TWO NINE.
EARLIER WE ON BEHALF OF AUDUBON
WHICH HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BUDGET ACTIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ISSUE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PROGRESS BEING MADE
ON THE POLLUTION ISSUE FROM THE
TIJUANA RIVER AND INSTRUCTED
PORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. GO TO MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX LINE
TWO THREE SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBER ID REQUEST
WITH THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AS A REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE THREE ZERO
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YES NO
ONE QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE ANYONE ALONG THE LINES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY NO ONE.
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN OH ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN IF ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IAN
OPPOSITION PRESS. ONE THEN IF
ZERO FOUR S. B. ONE THREE ZERO
ONE OPPOSITION. PACER ANYBODY
QUEUED UP. WE HAVE NO ONE
SHOWED UP ON THE PHONE I THINK
YOU WILL HOLD ON TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING HOW MUCH YOU
MISTER SENATE AWAY SO YOU HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. SB THIRTEEN OLD WILL
TIE ALL THE LOOSE ENDS- AND- WE
WILL DO SO BY. MAKING SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM THANK AYE I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CAN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. SB THIRTEEN
OH ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI FLORA.
FLORA ALRIGHT CHOW. CHOW ALL
RIGHT CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN GARCIA
GARCIA FIVE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI RIVAS. RIVAS
AYE STONE. SO I SIX VOTES SIX
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU IT
SENATORS AUTO OUT. OUTSIDE I.
CONSENT CALENDAR YEAH WHEN WE
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
MOTION AND A SECOND FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ROLL CALL.
OKAY CONSENT CALENDARS SB EIGHT
NINETY FIVE AND SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED A- COMMITTEE WITH
CONSENT RECOMMENDATION FRIEDMAN
HI FRIEDMAN HI FLORA. FLORA I
CHOW SO I CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI LEAVE US
RIVERSIDE STONE. SIX VOTES SIX
VOTES ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ROLE OPEN AS
WELL. WE'RE WAITING FOR SENATOR
TITLE IS US SENATOR STERN IS ON
THE PHONE LINES WE WOULD. GOOD
TO HIS BILLS. OPERATOR DO YOU
HAVE SENATOR STERN ON THE PHONE.
LET ME CHECK JUST A MOMENT. AB
SENATOR WIENER CAN HEAR US IF
HE COMES WE WILL TAKE HIM AS
WELL. I DO NOT SHOW SENATOR
STERN AT THIS TIME. OKAY. I CAN
PRESENT HUNDRED SENATORS. TURNS
SB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. OF
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE THE WITNESSES UP FOR
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT AND I WILL
ASK MY COACH HERE TO CHEER WHY
FLIGHTS ARE. PRESENT THE BILL.
THANK MANAGER WE CAN DO THIRTY
TWENTY STERN ACTUALLY THIS IS
THIRTEEN FOR EIGHT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FARM. THANK YOU
MEMBERS BILL MAKES MULTIPLE
CHANGE IN STATE LAW TO AN THE
BILL THE STATE FIRE PREVENTION
EFFORTS THE BILL EXPANDS THE
AREA WHERE FIRE SAFETY BUILDING
STANDARDS APPLY BEYOND THE VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES IN THE
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
MAJOR FIRES HAVE OCCURRED IN
THE HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES SUCH
AS THE TUBBS FIRE THAT
DEVASTATED FOLKY PARKINSON ON
THE COUNTY. CURRENTLY BUILDING
STANDARDS ARE NOT REQUIRED IN
THOSE AREAS. EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN HEADWATERS ECONOMICS
REPORT FOUND NEGLIGIBLE COST
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN A TYPICAL
HOME AND HOME CONSTRUCTED USING
WILD FIRE RESISTANT MATERIALS
AND DESIGN FEATURES. DECADES OF
RESEARCH AND POST FIRE
ASSESSMENT TO PROVIDE A CLEAR
EVIDENCE OF BUILDING MATERIALS
AND DESIGN. COUPLED WITH
LANDSCAPING ON THE PROPERTY ARE
THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTORS
INFLUENCING OUR HOMES ABILITY
TO SURVIVE A WILDFIRE. STAFF IS
WORKING ON AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
DISCRETION ON WHAT PARTS OF THE
MODERATE FIRE HAZARDS ON TO
EXPAND THE STANDARDS TO. THE
<c.green>UILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION</c>
SUPPORTS THE BILL AND THESE
CHANGES. THIS BILL MAKES IT
EASIER FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DO LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT
INCLUDE PROVISIONS COVERING
ADJACENT PROPERTIES REMOVING
RESTRICTIONS ON THOSE
ORDINANCES AND INCLUDING
PROVISIONS ON ADJACENT PROPERTY
FUEL MANAGEMENT IN THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S MODEL ORDINANCE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
THAT THE ONE HUNDRED FEET OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE FROM A
STRUCTURE WHEN THE PARCEL LINE
IS LESS THAN ONE HUNDRED FEET
AWAY. THIS BILL CREATES A
TRAINING PROGRAM TO UTILIZE
VOLUNTEERS TO DO DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AND HOME HARDENING
ASSESSMENTS. WHICH WILL HELP
UTILIZED HELLFIRE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE RESOURCES MORE
EFFICIENTLY. AND TUITION ENSURE
VOLUNTEERS AND HOW FAR ARE
SHARING A CONSISTENT MESSAGE ON
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HOME
HARDENING. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES A REPORT FROM CAL FIRE
ON THE STATUS BENEFITS AND
SUGGESTED IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS COMMITTED
BY SB NINE OH ONE. WHICH
APPROXIMATELY HALF IS ALREADY
BEEN SPENT. ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS LOSE
FOUGHT FOR US FORSBERG WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND PAUL
MANSON FROM THE PACIFIC FOREST
TRUST. RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE WITH OUR FIRST WITNESS
LIST BY PHONE. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
LEAD FOURTH BURKE AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR POLICY FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BAKE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS THE STATE HAS
MADE SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE WILDFIRE RISK.
INCLUDING A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
COMMITMENT TO FOUR TOP AND FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS. HOWEVER WE
CAN DO MORE TO PROTECT PEOPLE
AND NATURE IN THE FACE OF
QUALIFIERS BY TOLERATING FOREST
RESTORATION IN CREATING FIRE
RESILIENT COMMUNITY. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE AKE
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE PRONE REGIONS
MORE RESILIENT BY CREATING AND
MAINTAINING DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AROUND HELP. SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT MAKES IMPORTANT CHANGES
TO IMPROVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS AND HIGH FIRE RISK
AREA WE CREATING A TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR VOLUNTEER. HELP
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET
WILL BE THE FACT THAT AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION EFFORT. WE
MUST ALSO IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
FOURTH. SB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
WOULD FURTHER FORCE RESTORATION
THE STATE BY ADOPTING A PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWS LANDSCAPE SCALE
PROJECTS TO HAPPEN ON NATIONAL
FOREST LAND. IN FACT IN OUR
FEDERAL COURTS TO RESTORATION
WILL NOT ONLY REDUCE FIRE RISK
BUT ALSO INCREASE THE ABILITY
OF OUR COURTS PROVIDE VALUABLE
PUBLIC BENEFITS. INCLUDING
WATER SUPPLY CARBON RICH
WILDLIFE HABITAT AND
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
WILL ALSO SUPPORTING LOCAL JOBS
AND KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
WITH A CUTTER STERN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITH THIS PLEASE. THANK
YOU AT THE PALMETTO DESERVE
FOREST I REALLY LIKE THIS ECHO
MUCH OF WHAT BOB IS FORT BURKE
IS ALREADY SAID WHAT THE WITH
THE TRIGGER HAS ALREADY
CONVEYED ABOUT THE BILL. IT
REALLY IS A NUMBER OF FAIRLY
MODEST- BUT COLLECTIVELY VERY
IMPORTANT. TO OUR HOW WE'RE
BUILDING AND HOW WE'RE
INSPECTING HOMES AND HOW WE'RE-
INSURING THAT WE'RE DOING THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN TO TRY AND
MAKE HOMES MORE SAFE FROM
INEVITABLE WILDFIRES WHILE ALSO
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN. GET
BETTER. AFFECTIONATE FOR WITH
SOME OF INVESTMENT THAT WE ARE
MAY TOWARD MAKING. AND
COMMUNITIES MORE SAFE WITH SOME
OF THE INVESTMENTS WE'RE
MAKING. PURSUANT TO THE BILLION
DOLLARS FROM SB NINE A ONE WAS
MADE A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. SO
IN THE INTEREST OF BREVITY I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE ARRIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN WITH US ON THE
PHONES. NOT A MODERATOR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION ONLY PLEASE. THANK
YOU- IF YOU WISH TO YOU UP ON
THE PHONE YOU WILL PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN YOU WILL PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO WE HAVE MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR.
LINE TWO FOUR FOUR. YES THANK
YOU HI THIS IS BOB RAYMER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND AS THE
CHAIR IS INDICATED- CPA IS NOW
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT. WE THINK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AND
ADVISERS OFFER HELPING IS A
WORK FOR. THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND. TWENTY FOUR
NINE TWO TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS MARK THANKS
COMMITTEE ON OF CALIFORNIA OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
INSTRUCTORS FOR. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE POINT TWO FOUR FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ACCORDING AT ANOTHER SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY LINE Q. FIVE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI NATALIE MAC WILL
BE HAPPY TO CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS WORK. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE AT NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE LINE TWO
FOUR NINE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CLAPPERBOARD WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO LINE AT TWO FIVE TWO.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BURKE DEBBIE MICHAEL ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE GET A FULL UTILITY
DISTRICT AT THE PARK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR LINE
TWO FIVE FOUR. I'LL BE WAITING
OPPOSITION GROUP COME IN AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ONE THREE FOUR EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
THREE FOUR EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER
IN SUPPORT SEEN NINE. MOVED
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION BY PHONE.
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ONE THREE
FOUR EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION SB ONE THREE FOUR
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND. FIFTY FOUR ONE TWO FIVE
FOUR YES SIR. SO K. LOGGERS- IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION- WE
BELIEVE THIS IS BEINGHANDLED
FOR FORESTRY OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND- NOT QUITE PROPER
TIMING FOR THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL I
CHECK AGAIN- FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE THREE FOUR
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS YOU ALL HEAR
ME WE HAVE YOU. AWESOME GREAT-
ROBERT SIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED ON SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR STERN- I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY THANKING CHAIR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND BE SENATOR
PER EVENING OR EARLIER CONCERNS
AND WORKING TOWARD A SOLUTION
THAT BENEFITS NOT ONLY TO
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS. BUT ALSO
CALIFORNIANS IN THE AGENCY THAT
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROTECTION OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
POSITIVE CHANGE TO WHICH WE
APPRECIATE. IN CONCERNS OR
SPECIFICALLY WITH SECTION OF
THE LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD
CREATE A VOLUNTEER TRAINING
PROGRAM BUT IN DOING SO WITH
FURTHER LACKS THE REFINEMENT OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
VOLUNTEERS AND MUDDIES THE AREA
HOME WOULD ACTUALLY BE
CONDUCTING THE CONSULTATION
SECTIONS. WE BELIEVE THE
LANGUAGE WITHIN SECTION TEN
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO DIRECT CAL
FIVE DEVELOP A PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWS QUALIFIED IMMUNITY TO
AUGMENT THE DEPARTMENT'S
DEFENSIBLE SPACE HOME HARDENING
EDUCATE PERCHED. EVEN THEN IT
SHOULD BE MADE SURE THAT ANY
RECORDING TO HELP OUR OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE FOR HOME PARTY
PROJECTS ON A PROPERTY AND
REPORTED BY A VOLUNTEER SHOULD
BE VERIFIED BE A QUALITY
CONTROL MEASURES TO ENSURE THE
DATA IS ACCURATE. THE PROGRAM
IN ANY DATA SHOULD BE DECIDED
EIGHT QUALIFIER IN DIRECTING
THEIR LIMITED INSPECTIONS
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES TO THOSE
WHO ARE NOT NEEDED TO DEFEND
CHOIR MEN'S AND EDUCATION
RESOURCES OTHERS MAY BE
INTERESTED IN THE PROGRAM. IS
TO MAKE IT. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
INCOME LAST YEAR THIS LANGUAGE
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT TO THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THEEIGHTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN LANGUAGE PROVIDES THE
NECESSARY CHANGES THAT WE NEED
TO ALTERNATELY REMOVER
OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT I THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY WE WILL COMMIT TO
FURTHER REFINING THE
LEGISLATURE. EXCUSE ME FURTHER
COMMITS REFINING THE
LEGISLATION IS NECESSARY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION JUST NAME AN
pORGANIZATION PLEASE. AND THE
OTHER REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FERAL IF YOU ARE OPPOSING
UP S. B. ONE THREE FORTY EIGHT
AGAIN WHY NOT BEEN ZERO. YOU DO
NOT SHOW ANYONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NON WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANYBODY FROM THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE
MANAGER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. WELL AS THE GENTLEMAN
FROM THE FOURTH FROM THE FARM
BUREAU STATED I'M SURE THAT
SENATORS FROM WOULD AGREE THAT
TAKING LANGUAGE FROM A FRIEDMAN
BILL AND PUTTING IT INTO
ANOTHER BILL IS ALWAYS A GOOD
IDEA. YEAH I'M SURE HE DID WANT
ME TO CONVEY THAT HE'S AWARE OF
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION DOES NOT DISAGREE
WITH THEM AND COMMITS TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITHTHEM TO
GET THE BILL IN A PLACE THAT
THEY FIND HELPFUL AN
ACCEPTABLE. WITHOUT QUESTION I.
SHE DOES. SICK PLEASE CALL
PLEASE. OKAY SB THREE FORTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HI FLORA NOT LOADING FLORIDA
NOT VOTING CHOW CHAO HIGH
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN GARCIA
GARCIA HI MATHIS. MATHIS
NONVOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI RIVAS STONE. THE
LAST FOUR VOTES. VERY MUCH WAS
IT ON CALL. THANK YOU WE ARE
GOING TO GO BACK TO M. S. B.
NINE SEVENTY FOUR FROM SENATOR
HER TITLE. MISTER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MATTCHAIR MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO START OUT BY
SOMETHING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW MADE A
SMALL ROCK AND DISTRICT AND
BEYOND HAVE EXPERIENCE DRY
WELLS- DURING CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORIC DROUGHT AND NON
DROUGHT YEARS AS WELL AFTER
THESE COMMUNITIES UNDERTAKEN
WATER QUALITY PROJECTS SUCH AS
POLICY COOK ISLANDS ARE TIME.
AND COST PROHIBITIVE THE CITY
OF ARBIL IS ONE EXAMPLE WHERE
THE PROCESS TOOK FIFTEEN YEARS
TO COMPLETE. FIFTEEN YEARS TO
GET SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR
THAT COMMUNITY. THE
CONSTRUCTION ITSELF TOOK AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO COMPLETE SB
NINE SEVEN FOUR CREATES A
NARROW STATUTORY EXEMPTION FOR
WATER PROJECTS IN THESE AREAS
ESPECIALLY FOR SCHOOL CHILDREN.
THIS BILL HELPS REDUCE COSTS
AND SAVE TIME ON PROJECTS THAT
ADDRESS DRINKING WATER
CHALLENGES FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN ACHIEVING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO WATER WHILE
ALSO PRESERVING THE
ENVIRONMENT. I'VE SPECIES AND
PROVIDES JOBS. I COOPER WITH
THE TREAT AND WE HAVE COME TO
MUTUAL AGREEMENT SET OF
AMENDMENTS THAT ENSURE PER WAGE
AND REQUIRING SKILL AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
SPONSORED BY SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES AND RURAL COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE CORPORATION. AND
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE SHEAMUS A
GRIN FROM SOME FROM SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. AND BECKY CAN
TANA WHO WORK HERE TO TESTIFY.
THE WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
OPERATOR IT WITH WITNESSES ON
THE LINE. THIS IS FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN A ONE. I'M SORRY SB
NINE SEVENTY FOUR. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND ACCORDING TO
WITNESSES YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
SHRINK. I HAVE IS FAMOUS FIRST
SEVEN OKAY SEAMUS KIERAN AND
BECKY QUINTANA BECKY CANTATA
ALSO GOING TO BE TESTIFYING.
YES BUT OUR PRESIDENT BACK IN
TIME I CAN GO FIRST. FOR
THEY'RE BOTH ON THE LINE YOU
MIGHT BE NEEDED ON YOUR END
THANK YOU. I AM READY TO GO
OKAY WE'RE READY FOR YOU
WELCOME. OKAY HELP HELP WELCOME
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BECKY DATA. THAT MY FAMILY HAS
LIVED IN THE BILL SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. THE BILL
IF MOSTLY FARMWORKERS COMMUNITY
OF ABOUT A HUNDRED HOUSES IN
ARBITRARY COUNTY. FOR THE PAST
DECADE I HAVE BEEN PART OF THE
COMMUNITY FOR BETTORS TO BILL A
GROUP OF RESIDENTS WHO ADVOCATE.
FOR IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WE ALWAYS HAD A
PROBLEM WITH OUR WATER
INCLUDING BACTERIA AND NITRATE
CONTAMINATION. BUT THE WORK
CAME EVERY SUMMER BUT WE WOULD
RUN OUT OF WATER WE JUSTDIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH WATER AND ARE WELL.
AND IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ARE WELL
COMPLETELY FAILED AND WE HAD NO
RELIABLE READY WATER FOR THE
ENTIRE SUMMER. OUR COMMUNITY
ADVOCATED FOR SEVILLE AND THAT
IT. INCLUDING FOR EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER NEARLY A DECADE AGO. I
MET PEOPLE FROM EASTER GROCERY
AND WEST GOSHEN WHO STRUGGLED
WITH CONTAMINATED WATER RUNNING
OUT OF WATER JUST LIKE A THE
BILL. FINALLY THIS YEAR AFTER
DECADES OFWORK BY RESIDENTS
AND OUR PARTNERS OUR WATER
SYSTEM HAS BEEN UPGRADED AND
OUR WORST PROBLEMS ARE BEHIND
IT. BUT I CHALLENGE EVERYONE TO
LEARN SOMETHING FROM THE
EXAMPLE OF OUR COMMUNITY. HOW
CAN WE DELIVER SOLUTIONS MORE
EFFICIENTLY OUR COMMUNITY IS
LIKE THE BILL NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME IS JAMIE GEREN AND I'M A
SENIOR COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALIST WITH POP UP ON OUR
PRIDE THAT IN NINETEEN THIRTY
FOUR SELF HELP ENTERPRISES HAS
WORKED WITH RURAL LOW INCOME
FAMILIES CAN VALLEY COMMUNITIES
DIRECTOR WATER CHALLENGE. AND
WITH OUR FELLOW CODE FONG WILL
COMMUNITY IT DIDN'T CORPORATION
WE ARE THE TWO LARGEST
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE
DOING THIS WORK THANK YOU
CHALLENGE IT I'M WE NEED TO
LEARN THE LESSONS THE BILL AND
COMMUNITIES LIKE IT IF WE DON'T
HOW MANY MORE YEARS HOW MANY
DECADES. IS A BLANK BRIDGE
GROVETOWN CONTINUE TO GO
WITHOUT A DRINK WATER ONE OF
THE WAYS WE CAN EXPEDITE THE
FINAL PROJECT IT SB. NINE SEVEN
FOUR. BUT GOOD AND IMPORTANT
PLOT AND IN MANY WAYS PROTECT
COMMUNITY AND THE WEALTHY AT
WELFORD THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT
HOWEVER APPLYING THINK WHETHER
THE RELATIVELY SMALL TO WATER.
AND DISADVANTAGED THERE CHANGE
ARE AND POPPED UP AROUND
COMMUNITIES LIKE HELP HANNAH
HARDWICK IN PLAIN VIEW CANNOT
WAIT ANY LONGER AND CANNOT
AFFORD TO PICK AT WHEN STATE
FUNDING RUNS OUT AT THE NINE
SEVEN FOUR ESPECIALLY WITH IT
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT IS
TAILORED TO MEET ONLY THE
GENUINE AN URGENT NEED OF SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
LOCAL AND STATE BEARD AND A
THOUSAND DOLLARS ALONG THE WAY.
AS A RESULT ALL MORNING AND
RESIDENTS TO DO COMMUNITIES
WILL MORE QUICKLY FINALLY SAFE.
DRINKING WATER YEAH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH READING A WITNESSES
SUPPORT ON THE LINE OPERATE.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT S.
B. NINE SEVEN FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN
THAT FOR SUPPORT AT SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE GIRL I'LL IF YOU ARE
ALREADY IN THE QUEUE AND YOU
WISH TO UPHOLD PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO TO REMOVE YOURSELF.
AND THAT THAT FIRST THE PORT.
AND ALTHOUGH CAROLINE EIGHTY
ONE CRITICAL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WOULD BE THE ONLY GATHERED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
CLEAN WATER SUPPLIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS WHAT. AT HOTEL
WHY ONE TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU BOTH SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS OF THIS IS MICHAEL
LOPEZ BUSINESS MANAGER OF YOU A
LOCAL ONE ONE FOUR IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY WE STRONGLY.
SUPPORT THE NINE SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WELL NOT THE GOLD COIN
B. ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN MATT KREMIN
SHALL BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA THAT
COOPERATIVE OPERATING ENGINEERS
WEREN'T SUPPORT THANK YOU. WELL
NOT TRYING FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WANT ME TO DO SO
DRAWSTRINGS WRITERS AND WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE ABOUT
SIXTEEN AD THE KEEL WILL NEXT
GO TO LINE Q. THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL I HAD. THE MANAGER
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO BE A BUT-
DEFENSE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
WELL NEXT QUARTER FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CAN KATE
ON HUGE AROUND THE HELL STATE
PLAYED AND IN WE THANK YOUNG
FOR HER ON ISSUE. ONE NEXT DOOR
LINE Q. THREE FOUR PLEASE AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS BRIAN HOLD PROUD
MEMBER OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THANK
SENATOR PER CALL FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK. WELL NOT QUITE A
LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY FORTY EIGHT THIS IS
DAVID HANSON YOU A LOCAL THREE
NINETY EIGHT AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ONE THAT
ORDER LINE TURN NINE CALL I.
CARL YEAR THEY ON BEHALF OF
AUDUBON IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE THAT GO TO LINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANNY THERE GO
PRESS SECRETARY TREASURER FOR
LION OUT LABOUR'S LOCAL TO
TWENTY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WELL NEXT BUT ONLINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I AM SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
WELL NEXT MOVES TO ALIGN Q.
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBER
ADAM ROBIN WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. WELL NEXT MOTEL NINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS EARL HAMPTON
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE ON
BEHALF OF IBEW LOCAL FIVE NINE
FIVE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. WHAT WHAT I NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LOCAL TO
FIFTY BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
BEEN. WELL NOT QUITE ALIGNED TO
ALL FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JOHN MORALIS A VICE
PRESIDENT BUT TEAMSTERS LOCAL
EIGHTY SEVEN PER KERN COUNTY
MONO INYO COUNTY WHERE TRUMP
SUPPORT. FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
WELL NEXT MOTEL LINE AT SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MEDIC MOTEL LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TILL
NINE TWO THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS SEMANTIC CAMARO CEO MODERATE
BANKERS COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR. WELCOME BACK MOTEL
NINE ONE THIRTEEN IN CLEVELAND
I HAD. AND ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE YOU MAY
WEAKEN AREA. PETER YES WE CAN
AREA OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS WHEN TIME TO
REFINE YOUR WITH THE PLASTER
CEMENT MASONS LOCAL SIX HUNDRED
AND RETAIN SUPPORT OF TENURE
WOULD FOLLOW IN SB NINE SEVEN
FOUR THANK YOU. THE ONE ACT
MOTEL AT FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
ALL RIGHT TO ALMOST TO LINE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. I AM TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
BE NEEDED. ARE YOU TO OUR NEXT
MOVES TO LINE TO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO TURN
MEMBERS THIS IS RACHEL NET FROM
WORLD COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION AND WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
THANK YOU. WELL NEXT MOTEL LINE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVENTY TWO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY MY NAME IS CHRIS
MATTER WHAT THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR AND US IN OUR POINT OF
THE NUMBERS ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE BILL SO THANK. ADULT
PLEASE PASSAGE THANK YOU. ONE
ACT MOTEL LINE TO SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE
JOURNEYS APPLE THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION IS
CAPITAL ALSO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE NEXT MOVES TO ALIGN Q.
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
APPEARS YOU MIGHT REALLY
REPRESENT DISCOUNTS PAYER
KNOWLEDGE TRADES RETAIL THE
CURRENT BUILDING TRADE WITH THE
COURSE OF BILLS BY TWENTY FOUR.
ONE THAT MOTEL Q. SIXTY NINE
PLEASE CALL I HAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON NAME IS SAM CROCKETT
REPRESENTING DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES AND WE STAND WITH THE
CURRENT BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
SEVEN FOUR. ONE ACT MOTEL LINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HE MAY BE NEEDED. MAXIMO
TIELINE TWO SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL I HAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
SPAULDING NOT REPRESENTED
CARTER DID YOU AND MARK COUNTY
PUBLIC RECORDS RIGHTS COUNCIL
AND WE STRONG SUPPORT. THIS WE
BEHIND SEVENTY FOUR WE THANK
BETTER CAR HER ARE. THANK YOU
SHE- HOLE NEXT MOTEL. TO ONE
PLEASE GO OUT. HI MY NAME IS
RANDALL NAY NEVER DISTRICT
COUNCIL THINK PAINTER AND
ALLIED WE STAND WITH THE-
BUILDING TRADE THROUGH THE PORT
OF THE SENATE BILL NYE SEVEN
FOUR THANK YOU. ONE NEXT. LINE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DANNY RIGHT
BOMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS UA
LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX AND FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THAT SPEECH THAT
NINE SEVENTY FOUR. WELL NEXT
MULTI LINE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. M. SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED. ALL
RIGHT NEXT TO THE MOTEL LINE TO
TRY AND RETRIEVE GO AHEAD.
ECLIPSE DAY REPRESENTING
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES. WE
STAND WITH THE CURRENT BUILDING
TRADES AND SUPPORTED SB NINE
SEVENTY FOUR THANK. WELL NEXT
MOVES TO LINE THAT Q. SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON HE JOHN HUGHES WITH
DISTRICT SIXTEEN CREATORS
KNOWLEDGE TRAITS WE STAND WITH
THE KERN BUILDING KERRY CAN
SUPPORT SENATE BILL NINE SEVEN
FOUR THANK YOU. MACKSVILLE
MOTEL AT THIRTY ONE BECAUSE I
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARK TO THE OF THE HEATING
PROCESS LATER SPOKE SIXTEEN WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY FOUR. NACTA MOTEL LINE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS RODNEY
COBLE'S WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PIPE TRADES
REPRESENTING TWELVE COUNTIES IN%
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
CURRENT AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
THANK YOU. MAXIMO KALAW ONE OF
REPRIEVE AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU.
AND AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR S. B. NINE SEVEN
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON NOW AGAIN SUPPORT
FOR S. B. NINE SEVEN FOUR ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. WE NEED TO
HAVE ABOUT FOUR AND MAKE YOU A
LITTLE BOTTOM LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS RJ
FERRARI YOU A LOCAL THIRTY
EIGHT SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. WELL NEXT MONTH AT
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS NAMES I REPRESENT YOUR
WITH A PLASTER CEMENT MASONS
AND WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU. WELL
ALMOST TIMELINE TO SIXTEENTH
PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS RYAN-
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THANKS.
WELL MORE CAROLINE SEVENTY
SEVEN VEHICLE I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRANDENBURG WITH YOU
A LOCAL PEOPLE ARE SICK AND WE
JOIN THE STATE MEDICAID AND THE
BOARD OF SB. NINE SEVEN FOUR.
WELL MOST OF MY- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINEIS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED
ON YOUR SIDE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIN BOSTON. BUMMER'S IN
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR EIGHT
FOUR INVENTOR A- WE STAND
STRONG SUPPORT. OF SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU. NEXT THE
MOTEL NINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS JIM ELROD I'M THE
BUSINESS MANAGER OF
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
WORKERS LOCAL FOUR TO EIGHT AND
KERN COUNTY WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR ALL TUCKER TALKED
OVER THE CONTINUOUSHARD WORK
FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY
RESIDENTS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. NINE SEVEN FOUR. THANK
YOU. A MAXIMUM OF TEN Q.
SEVENTY FIVE. YEARS AGO I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CARLOS WILL BE RUNNING THIS
COUNCILS BANNERS AND ALLIED
TRADES AND WE STAND WITH
CURRENT BUILDING TRADE IN ORDER
SENATE BILL NINE SEVEN FOUR.
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B. NINE
SEVEN FOUR CLEAVE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN SUPPORT FOR
S. B. NINE SEVEN FOUR ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. LOCAL TRYING
FORTY THREE PLEASE APPLY HAD.
THANK YOU FOR NINE. LINE FORTY
THREE LINE AT OPEN. HI THIS IS
PROGRAMMERS. ONE WILL HELP OR
DEPARTMENT OR- KNECHTEL NEXT
LINE HUGE NINE APPLY. AND THEY
HAVE DISCONNECTED AGAIN NOT TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B. NINE
SEVEN FOUR. PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE ON NOW AGAINST THE PORT
FOR AT B. NINE SEVEN FOUR ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE DO
NOT SHOW ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FROM
THE QUEUE THEM UP PLEASE ON THE
PHONE LINES. SURE AND IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSED S. B. NINE
SEVEN FOUR. PRESSONE THEN
THEIR NOW AGAIN TO UPHOLD AT B.
NINE SEVEN FOUR ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. I NEED YOU HAVE ONE IN
THEIR QUEUE LOCAL TIMELINE. ONE
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
IT'S HI KIM STONE ON BEHALF OF
OFFICIALLY THE BUILDER THE
COUNTRY OF NORTH CALIFORNIA
THEY RESPECTFULLY WE HAVEN'T
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AFTER
THAT PROVISIONS THAT ENCOURAGE
A PROJEC LABOR AGREEMENT THANK
YOU. AND AGAIN THAT TO OPPOSED
AT BEER NINE SEVEN FOUR ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN. TO UPHOLD
THE S. B. NINE SEVEN FOUR ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW AND TO
CLARIFY I HAD A GOOD AFTERNOON
I HAD A WITNESS RICHARD MARX
AND WHO'S GOING TO GIVE
TESTIMONY SO IF RICHARD MARX
AND ON THE PHONE IF HE COULD HE
DOESN'T JUST HAVE TO GIVE HIS
NAME HE CAN GIVE TESTIMONY AS
WELL. MADAM CHAIR RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. WE CERTAINLY DON'T
OPPOSE CENTER HER TODDLER'S
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE A CLEAN
WATER OR THE STATUTORY
EXEMPTION UNDER CYCLIC. OF FOR
THESE PROJECTS HOWEVER. THE
LANGUAGE THAT QUITE FRANKLY WAS
IMPOSED UPON HER- WHICH IS
REPRESENTED BY THE THIS THE
STRONG SUPPORT THAT THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED FROM ORGANIZED
LABOR WILL MAKE IT. VERY
DIFFICULT WE BELIEVE OF FOR THE
WATER DISTRICTS BUT TO COMPLY.
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS IT'S
SOMEWHAT SIMPLISTIC TO SAY THAT
THE BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE.
HOWEVER THAT IS DEFINED IN THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS CODE. AS
REQUIRING THAT 60% OF THE
JOURNEY WORKERS WHO WERE
EMPLOYED ON THESE PROJECTSMUST
HAVE GRADUATED FROM AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM- WE
THINK THAT THIS PROVISION IN
ITSELF IS GOING TO RESULT IN.
THE LOSS OF A JOB SUPPORT
DURING WORKERS- THE LOSS OF
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES OF
FOR LOCAL CONTRACTORS AND THAT
ALL THE WORK FOR DOING THESE
PROJECTS IS GOING TO GO TO BAY
AREA AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS. WHO CAN COMPLY
WITH THE 60% GRADUATION RATE-
AS MR OWN POINTED OUT THERE IS
ALSO- PILLAY LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THAT WE OPPOSED TO WE'VE
ACTUALLY SPOKEN TO SEVERAL
WATER OF PROVIDERS- IT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHO ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS AND SAID THAT- THE
ADVANTAGES FROM HAVING THE
STATUTORY EXEMPTION FROM SEEK
WORK. WILL BE LARGELY OFFSET BY
THE WORK FOR REQUIRE. AND FOR
THAT REASON. WE COULD IS A TO
THE MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND IF ANYONE ELSE
THE POTUS AT ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SB. NINE SEVEN FOUR ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT OFFERING
IT TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. MISTER MATHIS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR ONE
ADELINE. THANK YOU FOR THE
CONTINUED EFFORTS I KNOW IN OUR
DISTRICTS- IN THE VALLEY. MANY
OF OUR- COMMUNITIES GO
UNNOTICED AND HAVE GONE WITHOUT
FOR TOO LONG. I KNOW DURING MY
TENURE IN THE ASSEMBLY WE'VE
WORKED TOWARDS THESE GOALS AND
I APPRECIATE YOU. WORKING ON
THEM AS WELL. I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR
WITH YOU IN THIS EFFORT TO HELP
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD AS IT
GOES THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY. YOU
KNOW FOR TOO LONG WE SEE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SUFFER WE SEEN MIDDLE
STARTED OUT WITH. THE SUPPORT
OF A WHEN I GOT ELECTED WE SEEN
SEVILLE STILL GOING THROUGH
THINGS WE SEE THE STRUGGLES
WITH COOLEY VILLE- EASTER ROSY.
FOR TIME YOU CAN GO ON AND ON
AND ON. AND THIS IS AN ISSUE
SHE WAS IN A HUGE HUGE HURDLE
FORGETTING. QUALITY WATER TO
OUR PEOPLE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE. AND I WOULD LOVE TO
PRESENT ON THE ASSEMBLY FOR YOU
AS WELL THANK YOU. FIRST THANK
YOU ANYBODY ELSE. SEE NEW
OTHERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WITH THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION THE SECOND-
CANAVERAL CALL PLEASE. SB NICER.
SB NINE SEVENTY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI FLORA
FLORA ALRIGHT CHOW CHOW HI
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
AYE GARCIA. AYE GARCIA AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I'M YOUR TUCCI. RIVAS
RIVERSIDE STONE. BILL HAS EIGHT
VOTES ACT WANTED TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO S. B.
TEN TWELVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START OFF BY TAKING THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
ON PAGE FIVE AND SIX. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AND I JUST I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY SURE DO YOU-
ALSO- COMMITTEE NOT TRYING TO
REMOVE THOSE MOMENTS AT A LATER
DATE. WELCOME TO MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE MAY BE
OPPOSITION I MEAN I'M I WOULD I
WOULD LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK. WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND- AND COMING TO CONSENSUS
AND AGREEMENT ON ANY FUTURE
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS IF NEEDED
BUT IN TERMS OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO UNDERSTAND THAT IF
THOSE AMENDMENTS OR REMOVAL
PEOPLE. COLD CALLING THE BILL
BACK INTO COMMITTEE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT OKAY. SO YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO REMOVE THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT IS NOT MY
INTENTION OKAY THANK YOU. SO
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TEN TWELVE WHICH IS STEP WHICH
IS A PROGRAM FOR THE PLUGIN AND
ABANDONING OF HAZARDOUS OR IDLE
DESERTED WELLS THE COMMISSION
TO ASSOCIATE FACILITIES IN THE
SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY- THIS
YEAR I SAT WITH CONSTITUENTS
DOWN AND KERN COUNTY RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK OF
RESOURCES IN OUR REGION. AND
YOU KNOW LOCAL LEADERS AND
ADVOCATES SHARED THEIR STORIES
ABOUT HOW UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BE
NEGLECTED WHEN IT COMES TO
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION JOBS
AND MOST OF ALL PUBLIC HEALTH
WITH YOU KNOW UNEMPLOYMENT AS
HIGH AS SIX POINT FOR WHEN THE
REST OF THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
THREE PERCENT- THIS IS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- THAT THE
RESIDENTS OF KERN COUNTY FEEL
REALLY STRONGLY ABOUT. I'VE HAD
HONEST CONVERSATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT HOW TO
TACKLE ONE THINK A PUBLIC
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
IN ADDITION TO OUR
CONVERSATIONS THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY REPORTED THAT THERE
ARE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACTIVE AND IDLE OIL AND GAS
WELLS IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS
INCLUDES FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY WALLS IT MAY HAVE
NO VIABLE OPERATOR. OR AT HIGH
RISK OF BECOMING ORPHANED IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. ARE THESE IDLE
AN ORPHAN WELLS CAN RELEASE
TOXIC EMISSIONS TO THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
CREATING HEALTH CONCERNS FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WITHIN
THAT AREA. TODAY AS WE ARE
FACING A WORLD HEALTH CRISIS
TOGETHER DUE TO COVER NINETY.
THE ISSUE STILL OCCURS OVER
COMMUNITIES OF KERN COUNTY AND
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. SB TEN
TWELVE REQUIRES CALCIUM TO
PARTICIPATIF OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WILL TAKING REASONABLE STEPS TO
RECOVER PLUGGING AND
ABANDONMENT COST ASSOCIATED
WITH DECOMMISSIONING ATTENDED
FACILITIES. FROM OPERATORS WHO
HAVE. NOT REPORTED. ACTIVE
OPERATIONS IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. SB TEN TWELVE ALL
REQUIRES CALCIUM INCLUDE IN
THEIR ANGER REPORT AN UPDATE TO
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH INCLUDE
SPECIFIC LOCATIONS OF CAPITAL
WEALTH AND FACILITIES THE
REGISTERED OPERATOR AND WHETHER
THE OPERATORS ARE COMPLYING.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LAW. AND
TODAY I HAVE DOCTOR DEBTS IN
OUR END- THE MAYOR OF OUR BEEN
WHO SIT JOSE COROLLA AT THAT
ARE HERE TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
BRING THE ARE AT THE A DR. BOOM
HOWEVER- ON TO THE LINE. YEAH
AND DOCTOR DOOM HOLLERED AT
MINUS OPEN. WONDERFUL ABOUT
THAT THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
HONORING ME WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY. MY
NAME IS JORDAN HOW ARE AND I'M
AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR IN THE
ECONOMICS DEPARTMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO. I'VE BEEN STUDYING ORGAN
AND I DON'T WELL IT'S USED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AS A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY A POST
DOCTORAL SCHOLAR CANTERED. AND
NOW A MEMBER OF THE UCSD
FACULTY. I WAS THE LEAD AUTHOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY REPORT
WORKING WELDING. AN INITIAL OF
THE STATE'S POTENTIAL. TO PLUG
COMMISSION WORKS IN OIL AND GAS
WELLS I'M HAPPY TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE TODAY. I WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT I'M NOT HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR OR AGAINST THIS
PARTICULAR BILL- BUT I WAS
INVITED TO PROVIDE EXPERT INPUT
I'M VERY HAPPY TO DO THAT- AND
TO ANSWER. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE IF I CAN IF I CAN BE
HELPFUL. SO ROUGHLY SPEAKING
THERE ARE ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACTIVE AND IDLE OIL
AND NATURAL GAS WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA. EACH OF THESE WELLS
WILL EVENTUALLY NEED TO BE
PLUGGED WITH CEMENT ANY
ASSOCIATED SIR. MEDIATED
ACTIVITIES PERFORMED ONE WELL
THE NO LONGER BE USED IN ORDER
TO ALLOW THE RISK OF GROUND AND-
METHANE WE AND OTHER IN AND
HEALTH COSTS. THESE ARE CALLED
PLUGGING AND STEPS REQUIRED BY
LAW. HOWEVER IN CASES WHERE THE
RESPONSIBLE OPERATORS HAVE
BECOME FINANCIALLY INSOLVENT OR
SIMPLY CAN NO LONGER BE
LOCATED. IDYLLWILD MAY BECOME
ORPHANED WELLS OR WELLS WITH NO
RESPONSIBLE OPERATOR TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR PLUGGING AND
DECOMMISSIONING. CALIFORNIA
REQUIRES OPERATORS TO POST
BONDS THAT CAN BE USED TOWARDS
CLOSING COSTS WHEN WELL THEY'RE
OPEN. IN GENERAL THE AMOUNTS OF
THESE BONDS ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
SMALLER THAN PLUGGING AND
DECOMMISSIONING COSTS. THE RISK
OF BECOMING AN ORPHAN WELL AS
HISTORICALLY THE HIGHEST FOR
WELLS OPERATED BY SMALL
FINANCIALLY WEAK COMPANIES. AT
THE SAME TIME TO RETHINK
COLLAPSE IN CRUDE OIL PRICES TO
COVER NINETEEN AT ILLUSTRATED
HOW INDUSTRYWIDE SHOCKS CAN
THREATEN THE FINANCIAL HELP
WITH EVEN VERY LARGE OPERATORS.
IN OUR REPORT MY CCSD CO
AUTHORS AND I PERFORMED AN
INITIAL ASSESSMENT OF WATER
WELL IN CHOOSING CALIFORNIA.
BASED ON READILY AVAILABLE DATA
FROM THE DIVISION OF OIL GAS
AND GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES. WHICH
OF COURSE IS NOT OURS CAL JAM.
THIS ANALYSIS WOULD BE
COMPLETED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
TO GET THAT THE THERE WERE FIVE
FIVE HUNDRED WELL THE CHILD HAS
LIKELY ALREADY BEEN ORPHANED OR
THE DATE HIGH RISK OF BECOMING
ORSON WELLES. YEAH THE STATE
LIABILITY ALSO THE COM MILLION.
WILL CALCULATED NUMBER OF
OTHERS TO WHICH AE IN THE
REPORT. ARE REPORTED AND
ATTACHMENT MORE. STUDIES
REQUIRED TO MAKE DEFINITIVE
STATEMENTS ABOUT ANY INDIVIDUAL
WELL OR OPERATOR. WE ARE
COMMITTED SEVEN EVERY IN WHICH
AREN'T TO SHOULD BE EXTEND. A
FEW OF THOSE THAT ARE
PARTICULAR TO QUESTION A
INCLUDE. BUDGET FRIDAY WELL.
COMING OFF WELLS. IN THAT THE
IN. CONSEQUENCE OF OUR WHILE.
IN ANALYZING. AND ARE EFFECTS
OF INCREASED BARBARA. SO THAT
I'LL BE HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU IF YOU CAN JUST
REMAIN ON THE LINE IN CASE THE
COMMITTEE HAS ANY QUESTIONS FOR
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WILL MOVE OUT TO THE
SICK OR GROW. FROM. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BY NAME MISSILES THAT
WOULD ALL THE AND I'M THE MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF ART IN INCOME
COUNTY ARE THAT IS THE TOWN OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE TWENTY FIVE ACTIVE
OR IDLE WELLS WITH AND SQUARE
MILE. AND MICHAEL IN ORBIT AND
A LOT OF THE SITUATION KERN
COUNTY AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SUFFER FROM ADVERSE ECONOMIC
IMPACT. FOR AIR QUALITY WATER
CONTAMINATION AND THE RISKS OF
BE VITAL ABANDONED OR
POTENTIALLY ORPHAN WELLS- CAN
BE DETRIMENTAL TO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY. OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ALREADY START BURKE AND
OUR MENTAL ADVERSE IMPACTS AND
THE POPE IT. AND THAT MIGHT HAS
ONLY. THE NEED FOR TO TAKE CARE
OF THE PUBLIC AND SAFETY OF THE
RESIDENTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND I I'M WORSE I'M SPEAKING
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATOR WILL
PROBLEMS SB THANKS WELL. IT'S
WHAT MAKES THAT BE IDLE AND
ABANDONED. ARE PROPER TAP AND
PROPERLY ABANDONED AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE RESIDENTS ARE
FACING THE FRONT LINE-
ATTENTION WE NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
OF WELL RECEIVE THE PROTECTION
THE PUBLIC AND SAFETY THAT THEY-
AND ACT PROMISE OF IN A- BOOK
ALWAYS ALLOW MYSELF. ARE THOSE
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THIS IS GOES TO SHOW THAT
ON THE TO THE COMPROMISE. AND A
WIN WIN FOR BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISSUE AND I STRONGLY URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO- AND I VOTE OF
APPROVAL FOR IT. AND BOUGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU OPERATOR
CAN WE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF WITNESSES POLICE JUST CAME
AN ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND WHAT
DO YOU. SUPPORT YOU A YOU ARE
IN. AT PLEASE SET PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELL. KEYPAD
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF F. ONE ZERO
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD WILL GO
TO ONE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN. LINE ONE EIGHT SEVEN.
CHEN MEMBERS THE LEGACY OF THE
WORKERS THERE FOR. BUT I DO
NEED TO CLARIFY LEVINE BELIEVE.
ALL WE ARE LOOKING SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND HAVE SUPPORTED THE
BILL. TO THE SENATE OUR
PROCESS. HOWEVER WE ARE NOT IN
SUPPORT AND MUST OPPOSE THE
CANADIAN BUT- SO I WAS CLARIFY
WHILE WE THE BILL IN PRINT IN
OUR LIVES IN SUPPORT. WE DO NOT.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT AND
WILL BE REVISITING RPG. AS WE
REVIEW THE MEMBERS MORE DETAIL.
THANK YOU NEXT COLOR. BLIND TWO
AND. FIFTY EIGHT NINE TWO FIVE
EIGHT. THAT MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOONS PROBABLY ALREADY
HAVE THE KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- SIMILAR TO THE
PREVIOUS ONE AS WE HAVE THAT
AND- SUPPORT- WHAT HAPPY TAKE A
LOOK AT THE INEVITABLE LET-
ASSEMBLY POLITICALLY ANYTIME WE
KNOW WHERE CURRENT IS THE BILL
GETS CLOSE TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. IN MIND OR IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT. OF SB ONE ZERO ONE
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE ZERO
ONE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. OKAY WE HAVE A ONE PERSON
IN THE QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT.
OKAY WE HAVE LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE NINE TWO
TWO ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK
YOU CAN MEMBERS MELISSA ROMERO
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION BETTER
I THINK THE POINT THEY REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS- OPEN
THAT PARTICULAR COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT AND WE WILL BE TAKING
A CLOSER LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE-
CURRENTLY NEUTRAL BUT
CONSIDERING SUPPORTING WITH THE
AMENDMENT. THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IF WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE ZERO ONE Q. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU FOR OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
HAVE ALFREDO ORIGINAL AND LEARN
COLON. WE CAN HAVE THEM PLEASE
FIRST AND THEN PLEASE QUEUE UP
THE OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
DO WE HAVE A OPPOSITION
WITNESSES OPERATOR. WE DO HAVE
MISTER ALFREDO ARE ENDO ON THE
LINE I'M SORRY WE DO HAVE THE
LIGHT MUTED I LET ME GET IT
LINE OPEN I DO APOLOGIZE THAT'S
OKAY. MOMENT THANK YOU. YEAH
SORRY ABOUT THAT JUST A MOMENT.
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES YES
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
AROUND OKAY. I GET UP AND
ENTERTAINMENT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS OLD BUT I
DON'T KNOW AND I'M PRESENTING
FAILED. OF STUDENTS. ENTERING
IN ADDITION IT'S BEEN TRACKING
ENGAGING ON ALL OF THE
IMPENDING ISSUES WILL COME TO
THE PARKING BENEFIT OF WILL UP
IN CALIFORNIA. AS SOON AS AN
OPPOSITION OF THE- IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. OKAY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES CLEARLY ARTICULATE
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT DR
OPPOSITION AND ADOPTION OF THE
AMENDMENT PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE. WOULD REMOVE. OUR
OPPOSITION TO NEUTRAL. BUILDING
ISSUE THAT TO BE. FOR IT HOW
STATE TAXPAYERS. AND BEING LEFT.
THE LIVE. TO PLUG IN THE BACK
WELLS. WITH A CURRENT OPERATE
FAILED KEEP UP THE AND BARGAIN.
THE REASON PICK UP THE- BY. THE
ARE C. THE LARGE OPERATOR GOAL
OF WELCOME. COUPLED WITH
LIGAMENT. THAT LED TO THE
HAVING TO PUT THE BILL OVER
HUNDRED EIGHTY. DOLLAR THE
COMMISSION IN A BAND. BY FROM
ALL YOU AND THE TOTAL WELL.
PROVIDE COMFORT WE'RE GETTING
THE WORK COMPLETED. THE
RESPONSE. TO NOT WE- BURDEN ON
TECH. THAT ONE EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS CAME DIRECTLY THE BEACH
CON. AND IS WELL KNOWN WOULDN'T
WORK THIS ECONOMICAL. THEY WILL
NOT BE IN THE TO BE ABLE MORE
ALL COMPANIES FROM THE OUTLOOK.
WILL TO PLUG AND WELLS. THE
ORIGINAL COMPUTER. ON THE ISSUE
A PLUG BANNON OF WELL. THAT
WOULD. WITH THE DOCTOR AND
STAFF. YEAH WE APPRECIATE THEIR
AND HAVE IT BECAUSE- GIVEN THE
TRUNCATED TIME. THAT WE'RE
WORKING UNDER WELL THE
COMMITTEE IN THE YOU KNOW
RESOLVE ALL WORKING. WITH
ADOPTION OF THE CAN AMENDMENT
APPROVED WILL REMAIN WITHOUT.
WITHOUT IT UP LIKE MANY
AMENDMENTS WE OPPOSED AND WITH
A NUMBER. I THANK YOU FOR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS AN OP.
WE WERE LOOKING FOR LARA LAUREN
COHAN. YES I CAN HEAR ME ON THE
LINE YES THIS COLUMN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT I GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I THE LORD COLUMN WITH BEER
CLUB CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
THE ADDED. THAT THE COMEDIAN
AND THEN BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT AS THE BILL CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. IT WOULD. CAL GEMS OF
FORTY RECOVER COSTS A IN
ABANDONING DECOMMISSIONING AND
REMEDIATION SITE. SPECIFICALLY
REFERENCED THE UNDEFINED TERM
CURRENT REGISTERED OWNER IN
SECTION TWO SUBSECTION II THE
TERM DIFFERS FROM THE TERM
PERATOR WHICH IS THE FIND OF
THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
SECTION THREE THEIR THEIR
ONLINE. THE TERM OPERATOR IS.
THROUGHOUT THE PRC WHERE THE
TERM OWNER IS NOT THEREFORE
WITHOUT BEING AMONG THE BILL
CREATES AN INCONSISTENCY AND A
POTENTIAL CONFLICT INTERFERE
WITH CALTRANS ABILITY TO
RECOVER CALL. FOR A PATH
OPERATOR. YOU'RE DATING A MAN
THREAT SOUTH OF TALK OIL GAS
WELLS THE STATE THERE ARE NO IN
USE. CALIFORNIA A MAJOR OR GOT
STATE WE OVERTAKE FIVE ONE WELL
ARE A ORPHAN OR AT RISK. AT
HIGHER OF BECOMING ORSON WELLES
IN THE NEAR FUTURE ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY THE
STATE ALREADY IS LIABLE FOR
MORE THAN. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN CLEAN UP
COSTS FOR THOSE FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED WELLS. ALMOST SEVENTY
THOUSAND OTHER WELL THERE
EITHER CURRENTLY IDLE OR
ECONOMICALLY MARGINAL AND ARE
AT INCREASED RISK OF BECOMING
ORPHANAGE BRINGING. THE TOTAL
COSTS OF FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE PLUGIN ABANDON.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND IN OUR-
CALIFORNIA. MORE THAN NINETY
DOLLARS. CALIFORNIA OIL
INDUSTRY IS IN DECLINE IT WOULD
INCREASES THE CHANCES THAT
COMPANIES WILL GO OUT OF
BUSINESS. IN LIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION'S RECENT BANKRUPTCY
FILE FILING AND THEY'RE NEARLY
EIGHT THOUSAND I'M- UNPLUG I
DON'T. HELP IT IS NOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER TO ENSURE
THE CALIBER CAN'T HOLD PARTY
RECOVER COSTS. PLUGGING INTO.
WELLS AGAIN WE- DR HOW DECIDED
ACCEPT THE ABOUT TO REMOVE THE
PUT. IT TOP CREATE BUT WE STILL
NEED TO RAISE THAT MEN AS WELL
ANY OTHER. ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THE SENATE PER
CAPABLE WE CAN WORK BURKE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PLEASE A
BRING THAT OTHER WAY. AND I.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION SB ONE ZERO ONE
Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF F. B. ONE ZERO
ONE Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
LINE TWO EIGHT ZERO. PLEASE
GOING. GOOD AFTERNOON CAME
ALONG. I ONE CAL. AS WELL AS
FOR EXTRACTED IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OUT IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL- PARTIES THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF F. B. ONE ZERO
ONE Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IT WE HAVE LINE Q. EIGHT
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD WE'RE
GONNA GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
JUST ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD TO EIGHT
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT SHE
REMEMBER SEAN LONG TIME FROM
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THAT
SENATOR HER TADO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. UP TO THIS POINT-
BUT BUT HE ADDED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT THAT SHE'S TAKING
TODAY- WE NEED TO REVIEW THOSE
WE ARE NOT IN SUPPORT OF THOSE
STILL GOING FOR. GOING TO HAVE
TO LEAVE YOUR- VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT COLOR. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE ZERO ONE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU LET ME BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO HAS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MATHIS THANK YOU.
SENATOR ANDREAS. INTERESTED
BECAUSE I MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH ALL OF THE INMATES THAT
ARE BEING TAKEN AND WHY THEY
NOW HAVE CONCERNS. WELL FIRST
OF ALL SAID WHAT. RUSSIAN OF
THE CHAIR. FIRST AND FOREMOST
I'D LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
BILL IS NOT SPONSORED BY ANY
PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION AT THIS
IS. A BILL THAT IS SPONSORED
BY- BY ME AT RIGHT AND- IT WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE YOU KNOW THE
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. AND SO- THAT'S
THAT'S ONE THING I WANTED TO
CLARIFY THE OTHER THING IS THAT
THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE OF NATURAL RESOURCES.
ARE PROVIDED AMENDMENTS- THAT
THEY FELT THEY WERE DEFEATED
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT I'M ABOUT IN TERMS OF. WHY
DOES IT WORK IN SUPPORT NOW IN
THIS THEY DON'T FIT WITH THE
AMENDMENT I'M TAKING HERE TODAY.
OKAY. YES CENTER- I SHADOWS
BILLS BEEN INTERESTING FOR YOU
BUT IT ALMOST SEEMS LIKE THIS
BILL DID A ONE EIGHTY. PRETTY
MUCH EVERYBODY THAT WAS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE NOW
COMING OFF ORIGINALLY RIGHT
BECAUSE OF THESE AMENDMENTS
GOING TO POSE IT EVERYBODY WAS
OPPOSED BECAUSE THE MINISTER
NOW SUPPORT. SO FEELS LIKE.
WHAT YOU WANTED TO DO WHAT YOU
WANTED TO DO IS NOT GETTING
WHEN I GET IN THERE. IS THAT
CORRECT. WELL I MEAN THE
VERSION THAT I MOVED FORWARD IS
NOT MOVING FORWARD BUT YOU KNOW
AT THE END OF THE DAY TO ME
WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT IS THE
PEOPLE I REPRESENT AND ALTHOUGH
IT'S THAT. THAT WE REPRESENT
TRAIT THAT I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE
THAT REPRESENTS AT PEOPLE THAT
ARE NEAR IDLE BALLS AND SO. I
THINK- THAT THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT TAKEN AND THEN TRYING
TO MOVE. THE CONVERSATION
FORWARD AND SO HAVING THAT IN
MIND. I JUST. OKAY THANK YOU
QUITE FRANKLY I DON'T KNOW IF I
HAD THE SUPPORT TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD. AND I THINK THAT
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING
ON WITH COBIT AND- AND WITH
VALLEY FEVER JUST RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER AND THESE THINGS
THAT ARE JUST COMING TOGETHER I
MEAN. TO DO I MEAN I WANTED TRY
TO MAKE IT TO IN ANY POSSIBLE
AND SO WANTED TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION- EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE NOT THE MOMENTS THAT I
BROUGHT FORTH. OUT OF. MAKE
YOUR HEART WAS IN THE RIGHT
SPOT WITH TWENTY TO HELP. TODAY
I THINK IT'S JUST A BIT THIS.
THAT IT JUST FEELS KIND OF
HAVING TO LOOK MEMBERS DISPLAY
THE GAME AT THIS BILL GOT
FLIPPED ON ITS HEAD. SO I
APPRECIATE YOU AND I WAS HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT EARLIER AND I'M
JUST NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO.
CHECK THAT. ANYONE ELSE
COMMITTEE. I'LL JUST SAY I WANT
TO FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH ON THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT AREA TO TRY TO
LEGISLATE IN AND CERTAINLY HAVE
A COMMUNITY THAT HAS A LOT OF
IMPACTS. A FROM IDLE WELLS. AND
WE HAVE IMPACTS MODEL ROLLS
AROUND THE STATE THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT TAXPAYERS
ARE IN ON THE LINE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN WHEN I DON'T WELL.
CREATES AN ISSUE OR EVEN WHEN I
TO WELCH'S LEFT BEHIND IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN OF.
GROWING IMPORTANCE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR BEING WILLING
TO WORK WITH US I KNOW IT'S A
DIFFICULT PLACE TO BE WHEN YOU
HAVE A BILL THAT HAS
OPPOSITION. AND THE POSITION.
PLACE BUT AT THE SAME TIME-
THIS COMMITTEE FELT THAT IT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE A BILL
THAT DIDN'T INCREASE THE
POTENTIAL FOR LIABILITY
SHIFTING. FROM OIL PRODUCERS TO
TAXPAYERS AND THAT'S WHY THE
AMENDMENTS WERE PUT INTO PLACE
AND THAT'S WHY THE BILL
INDUSTRY. IS HAVING CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL AS WRITTEN. THIS
COMMITTEE'S JOB THOUGH IS TO
PROTECT THE TAXPAYERS. AND THE
FOR THE RESIDENTS- AND SO THAT
WILL ALWAYS BE THE- POSITION
THAT WETAKE AND KIND OF THE
SIDE THAT WE TAKE. AND THAT'S
WHY THE AMENDMENTS ARE THERE
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR-
BEING WILLING TO. I TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS. AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO FOR
YOUR COMMUNITY I THINK IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND- YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S
DEFINITELY LOOKING OUT FOR
THEM. SO WITH THAT DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. HEY WE HAVE A MOTOR AND
WE HAVE A SECOND. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I APPRECIATE THE
TIME THAT THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE TAKEN TO
WORK WITH ME ON THIS. IMPORTANT
BILL FOR MY DISTRICT AND FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
GOT A CALL PLEASE SB TEN TWELVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED
AND PREFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HI FLORA. ANOTHER CHAO CHAO I
COMING. EGGMAN EGGMAN I. GARCIA
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY ALL RIGHT MATTEUCCI.
RIVAS RIVAS AYE STONE. BILL
BILL AS SIX SIX VOTES LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN PERHAPS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE ARE MOVING ON TO.
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY I'LL BE
PRESENTING FOR MR STERN OPERATE
IF YOU CAN PLEASE QUEUE THE
WITNESSES UP. AND ALSO- CENTER
WINNERS HERE I KNOW- SENATORS
TURNS ON HE LINE RIGHT NOW. SO
WE'VE ALREADY A- AND HE'S GOING
TO OKAY A MOMENT BUT THANK YOU
AND ARE WE PASSING THE GAVEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
THAT PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AS CALIFORNIA
SEEKS TO NAVIGATE ITS PRESENT
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WERE
ALSO STARING DOWN ANOTHER
CRISIS. THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY
THAT THREATENS VIRTUALLY A
CORNER OF OUR LIVES. THE
EFFECTS HAVEBEEN WILL COME IN
EVERY. LEVEL WE SEE THEM
INTERNATIONALLY WERE RECENT
RESEARCH RECENTLY RESEARCHERS
FOUND OUT THAT ONE BILLION
PEOPLE WILL BE DISPLACED OR
FORCED TO INDOOR INSEPARABLE HE
FOR EVERY ADDITIONAL 1 DEGREES
CELSIUS TEMPERATURE RISE. WE
SEE THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL
WHERE RISKY BUSINESS PROJECT
ESTIMATES EIGHT TO TEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF EXISTING PROPERTY
WILL BE UNDER WATER. BY TWENTY
FIFTY WITH AN ADDITIONAL SIX
BILLION TO TEN BILLION DOLLARS
AT RISK DURING HIGH TIDE. AND
WE SEE THEM AT THE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL LEVELS WHERE FOR EXAMPLE
RISKY BUSINESS ESTIMATES THE
INLAND EMPIRE WILL LOSE UP TO
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION PER YEAR.
AND ON DECLINES IN COTTON
YIELDS. WHAT THE AVAIL RESEARCH
THROUGH PROJECTS LIKE RISKY
BUSINESS CLEAR IS THAT
VIRTUALLY EVERY CORNER OF OUR
LIVES WILL BE UPENDED BY THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. BUT DESPITE THE
VALUE RESEARCH CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
REQUIRE A SYSTEMIC REVIEW OF
OUR CLIMATE LIABILITIES. THESE
OUT ANALYSES ARE NOT ONLY
POSSIBLE BUT CRITICAL SO THAT
WE CAN PINPOINT PRECISELY WHERE
WE HAD MOST VULNERABLE ACT
AGGRESSIVELY TO REDUCE RISK. SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY WILL FILL THIS
GAP BY PROVIDING FOR THE
REGULAR PRODUCTION OF OUR
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT. REQUIRING
THAT THE ASSESSMENT STUDIES
IMPACT ECONOMIC IMPACTS
ALONGSIDE THE RISK OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. TO OUR STATE'S BUILT
NATURAL AND SOCIAL SYSTEMS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
REQUIRE OPR TO ASSESS POTENTIAL
ADAPTATION AND MITIGATION
RESPONSES AND THE FINANCIAL
COSTS AND BENEFITS OF ACTION
READ REPORT. EXAMINATIONS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
AND THE UNIQUE RISK POSED TO
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES AND DECISION
SUPPORT TOOLS AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR PLANNERS AND
DECISION MAKERS. ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT DROPPING THE REPORTS
ON THEIR DESK WITHOUT
GUIDELINES OF HOW TO TAKE
SUBSTANTIVE ACTION. THE BILL
ALSO ENSURE OPR WILL COORDINATE
WITH REGIONAL AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TRIBES AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. THIS YEAR WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A FISCAL SHOCK
THAT REQUIRES US TO SPEND MORE
AS WE TAKE IN LESS REVENUE.
THAT CHALLENGE OF A CONTRACTING
ECONOMY AND EXPANDING NEED FOR
COLLECTIVE IN STATE ACTION IS
ALSO CENTRAL TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS THE BY UNDERSTANDING
WHERE RISK LIES WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO INVEST BOLDLY TO
AVOID THAT HAUNTED FUTURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY WITNESSES TO
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. NOT A
MODERATOR I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
MISTER PARKER FREE ON THE PHONE.
SENATOR AND THERE'S ONE OTHER.
AND THE SENATOR PER. THANK YOU-
JONATHAN PARKER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CLIMATE RESOLVE
HEADQUARTERED LOS ANGELES AND I
DO NEED TO DISCLOSE AND I'M
ALSO AN APPOINTED MEMBER THE
GOVERNOR'S TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COUNCIL ON CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION AND NOT I AM NOT
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THAT. AT
ONE OF SENATOR STORER FOR
TWENTY TWO MOM. IN STATUTE I
CAN TO SETTLEMENTS THESE
ASSESSMENT HAVE BEEN HAPPENING
IN BY IT MINISTRY OF ACTIONS
ABOUT. THOUSAND THE-
MEMORIALIZATION OF THESE
CLIMATE ASSESSMENTS. OF CLIMATE
RESULT OF WAS THE SISTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AND ENACTING THE FOURTH
ASSESSMENT. AND WE'VE SEEN
HEALTH NEEDS ASSESSMENT. I AM
THE DATA THAT THEY PRODUCE GET
USED- ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
AGENCY- HAS PASSED THE THIRTY
EIGHT WITH CONCRETE CHANGE AND
THEY USE THE DATA FROM. THE
START. IN THEIR PLANNING THE
COW ADAPT. I HOPE YOU'RE FROM
WITH THE HAS THE VERY DATA FROM
BEFORE ASSESSMENT THAT GETS
USED BY BUT SAY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IN THE
RECENT PROCEEDING RELATED TO
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES-
RANKING CLIMB AT RISK AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS USE THIS DATA FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR
CLIMATE ASSESSMENTS AND PLANS-
FOR EXAMPLE OUR ORGANIZATION.
IF YOU THINK THIS DATA IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE L. A. COUNTY
ACCOUNTABLE IF DOCUMENT AND BY
STATUTE WHAT EVER MANAGE TO
UPDATE THEIR LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS AND THEIR NO
PLANS. AND STATED. NOW I WANT
TO CALL TO SECTION FOUR. ****
THEN APPLY PERCENT YEARS UP FOR
THE CLIMATE IS TOUGH TWENTY TWO
FIFTY TWENTY HUNDRED. AND FRANK
HAD WE TRIED TO CHECK CERTAIN
PATH AND PRIOR VERSIONS AND
THIS IS THE FAULT CLIMATE IS
THE AVERAGE OF WEATHER-
EXPRESSED IN A POX NOT IN
SPECIFIC YEARS. AND WE WERE
HOPING THAT THE LINK WHICH
WOULD BE CHANGED EVERY FOR.
THIRTY YEAR TIME PLACES RATHER
THAN SPECIFIC YEARS BECAUSE IT
ACTUALLY IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
PREDICT WHAT THE. WEATHER WOULD
BE LIKE. AFTER YEARS BUT YOU.
OPT WITH MUCH GREATER ACCURACY
TRY TO DEPICT WHAT THE FUTURE
CRIME THE AVERAGE APPEARS WITH
THE FAMILY TO ONE ALSO CALL
ATTENTION TO SECTION FORTY
WHERE THE CURRENT LANGUAGE-
ACTUALLY MAINTAIN SENATOR STERN
TO RITUAL INTENT FOR THE STATE
TO PERFORM ECONOMIC ANALYSES-
AND WITH THAT WE- CHAIR UP. AND
THE FOLLOWING TO BE. THE BEST
SELLING BOOK ON INHABITABLE
EARTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
KNOW INTERACTION NEEDED DAVID.
MISTER DAVID WALLACE WELLS ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. LET ME CHECK
TO SEE IF HE'S ON THE LINE JUST
ONE MOMENT. IT'S NOT METAL
MODERATORS CENTER STERN ON THE
LINE. I'M HERE WITH YOU. THE
AREAS. I'LL HANG TIGHT. WAIT
FOR MISTER WALLACE WELL THE
SECOND I MOSTLY REMEMBER
FRIEDMAN SAID SAID IT ALL THERE
SO I MOSTLY JUST WANT TO BE
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
HELP WITH ANY TECHNICAL SORRY I
CAN'T BE THERE IN PERSON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER. YOU'RE
WELL AND I'M GOING TO BE
OPENING OF MINE I DO APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT. NO WORRIES. AB ONE
MOMENT. OKAY WE DO HAVE STATE
MISTER DAVID WALLACE WELLS WITH
US NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR WEALTH. THANK YOU TO
SENATOR CENTRIC LEADING MAN
THANK YOU TO ALL FOR LISTENING
I JUST WANT TO START BY SAYING.
FOR A VERY LONG TIME CLIMATE
CHANGE HIM TO BE A VERY
DIFFICULT THREAT ARRIVING
SLOWLY IT'S BEEN HARD FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO MAINTAIN
OCCLUSION AND MOST AMERICANS
BUT- EVEN HERE MOST DON'T
APPRECIATE AND HAVE NOT
PREPARED FOR. EVEN THE
TRANSFORMATIONS ALREADY
UNFOLDING BEFORE THEIR EYES.
THE COLORATIONS MAASTRICHT WITH
WILD- HER. BACKYARD PERGOLA
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI THE YEAR HE
WAS BORN TIRES BURNED THROUGH
SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES IN THE
STATE YOUR HE WAS ELECTED IT
WAS. SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
ATTEND TOLD INCREASE REELECTED
IT WAS ONE POINT TWO MILLION
AND YOUR BEFORE WE SPOKE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT WAS ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION. A 50% INCREASE YEAR
OVER YEAR RELEASING ENOUGH
CARBON FREE ATMOSPHERE ENTIRELY
WIPED OUT THE PROGRESS THE
STATE HAD MADE WITH ALL ITS
GREEN ENERGY AND FUEL
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS AND TODAY
BILLIONS OF POINTS ARE ALREADY
LIVING IN BUILDING HOUSING IN
VERY HIGH. WHAT PART AREAS. THE
LONGTIME ADVOCATE OF CONNECTION
SPOKE ABOUT IT IS A MORAL ISSUE
NOT A MATERIAL ONE AN OPPONENT
SPOKE ONLY ABOUT THE COST OF
ACTION NOT ITS BENEFITS THAT
MEANT ALMOST NO ONE IN THE
PUBLIC. APPRECIATED JUST HOW
ENORMOUS THE BENEFITS THE END
ARE ENORMOUS. SOMETIMES
THANKLESS BELIEVE WARMING COULD
REDUCE GLOBAL DP BY AS MUCH AS
2230% BY THE END OF THE
CENTURY. AND DECARBONIZING THE
ECONOMY COULD ADD AS MUCH AS
TWENTY TRILLION TRIPLE GDP BY
THE TWENTY THIRD INTO ANOTHER
START THE CAR. JUST PMR
ELECTRIC JUST COULD ADD FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY MILLION JOBS OVER THE
NEXT. DECADE VERY LONG TIME WE
HAVE RALLIED TO TRY TO AVID
WARMING TO LIMIT EMISSIONS OF
THE DAMAGES THAT INEVITABLY
COME FROM CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT%
DRAMATIC CHANGE IS ALREADY HERE
AND THERE'S MORE WARMING COMING
WE CAN'T CONTINUE LIVING IN
IGNORANCE. AND HOPING FOR THE
BEST AND WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE. THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
WILL BE AVOIDED WE HAVE TO
BEGIN TO ADAPT AND THAT
REQUIRES SEEING THE PROBLEM
UNDERSTANDING THE THREAT AND
RESPONDING WITH KNOWLEDGE. THAT
KNOWLEDGE ON THE FORECHECK THE
COMES WITH IT IS WHAT THIS BILL
PROMISES WHICH IS WHY I SUPPORT
IT ENTHUSIASTICALLY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF YES. SB ONE
ZERO ONE I'M SORRY SB ONE THREE
TWO ZERO FOUR SUPPORT YOU WILL
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN FOR SB
ONE THREE TWO ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
YOU WILL PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE LINE
TWO NINE ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOKYO SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI AND
COMPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY TWO LINE TWO NINE
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS ERIN RODRIGUEZ UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX LINE. TO NINETY SIX.
REBECCA MARKETS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE LINE TWO TWO ONE.
MONTEREY MARYLAND THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. IF ANYONE ELSE
WISHES TO QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ONE THREE TWO ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TAIL KEY PAD AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THEN IF ZERO. EIGHT DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU SIR STERN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING
CLOSE- JUST BEFORE WE MOVE ON.
I I'M I'M GOOD FOR NOW I THINK-
DAVID WALLACE WELLS AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MR PARTRIDGE
SAID IT ALL SO BRING SOBERING
ASSESSMENT HERE SO I'M JUST
HERE I'M HERE FOR QUESTIONS
AND- TO HELP WITH ANY CLARITY
NEEDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN THE RIVER.
C. N. NINE. THEY WANTED
OPPOSITION. MADAME MODERATOR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES YOU ARE THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF F.
B. ONE THREE TWO ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ONE THREE TWO ZERO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. BUT NO ONE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. ROOM SEEN
NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. YES I THANK YOU I AM
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY I THINK. HAVING AN
ASSESSMENT ON A REGULAR BASIS
IS A GOOD IDEA BUT I DO WANT TO
URGE THE DOCTOR. I TO THINK
ABOUT BEING MORE INTENTIONAL OR
TALKING ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES ARE MORE
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING TO BE IMPACTED WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE- WE BEAR THE
BURDEN ON POLLUTION ALREADY AND
WE KNOW THAT AS TIME MACHINE
HAVE BEEN WE HAVE. THESE P.
ALLEN'S GOING TO WORST IN THESE
COMMUNITY I THINK IS THE EASY
THING TO. ARE EIGHT ARE GOING
LEAD ON THE- I WITHOUT A BEING
EXPLICIT ABOUT IT TYPE THAT'S
WHAT. ON THESE PA HAVE WE HAVE.
A RESPONSIBILITY TO LAY IT OUT
THERE MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE
DEPARTMENT THAT THEY SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED SEEN. THESE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
HAVING ASSESSMENTS- THAT
SUFFICE HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
BE. EVEN MORE BURDEN THAT I
THINK IS OUT THERE IN SUCH AS
LANKFORD. WORK WILL FIND THAT
THIS BILL WHICH IS BUILT IN
GENERAL AS WE TALK ABOUT. AS WE
TALK ABOUT PRETTY MORE EQUITY
IN OUR POLICIES AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS OUT THERE BEING
INTENTIONAL AND SO THE CURRENT
CULTURE- IF WE LOOK AT THE
PATTERN. WE ARE OFTEN AFTER
THOUGHTS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
AND WE DO THE MINIMUM- UNTIL.
JUSTICE WANTED TO MAKE THAT
COMMUNIST AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS BILL BUT- I THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
AND I AM HOPEFUL THAT. TIME
BEFORE THE DISCUSS THE FLORAL
HAS. NOT TOO LITTLE BY SPECIFIC
FOR. ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITIES
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO ENGAGE
WITH THEM AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SINCE YOU'RE
ON THE PHONE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF OTHER AGENCIES ALSO DOING
ASSESSMENTS. HOW DOES THIS ASK
FIT IN WITH ALL THOSE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- THE GOAL HERE IS TO TRY
TO DECIDE LOW A LOT OF THE
ANALYSES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
GOING ON SAY WITHIN AN AGENCY
LIKE CALTRANS OR THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION ABOUT THE
VULNERABILITY OF OUR ENERGY
GRID OR OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM OR IT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT- NAGRA CULTURE
IMPACT ON OUR CROSSES TO. OR W.
THE RISKS TO OUR STATE. I THINK
IT'S SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY BILL
DOLLAR ARCS TO PASTA IN ONE
YEAR SUPER DISASTER
POSSIBILITY- ALL THE ALL THE
MASSES THAT EACH OF THOSE%
AGENCIES DO DON'T END UP IN ONE
INTEGRATED FORMAT AND REALLY
DON'T APPEAR ON OUR BOOKS IN
THE BUDGET. SO THESE ARE
UNFORESEEN OFTEN LIABILITIES
THAT WITHIN THEIR SILOS THEY
ARE FORESEEN SOMEWHAT BUT I'M
REALLY HOPING THAT INTEGRATED
ASSESSMENT- PUTS THAT MATH
TOGETHER SO WE DON'T GET
BLINDSIDED IN A IN A BUDGET
WHERE ALL OF A SUDDEN IT TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR HIT COMES
THAT WE DIDN'T SEE COMING IN
WE'VE GOT TO CUT. OUTPUT AND
MEDICARE AL BECAUSE THAT WE GOT
IT WITH A FIRE IN A FLOOD THE
SENIOR. BUT THE GOAL HERE IS
TO. TRY TO GO LEVEL TO REALLY
FOR SOME OF THAT MATH IN YOUR
DECISION MAKING IT INTEGRATED
BASIS. OKAY SO THIS DOES SOUND
LIKE A GOOD PLACE THEN TO
INJECT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR ADDRESS IN AN OVER
ARCHING WHY WITH ALL OF THE-
OTHER AGENCIES BECAUSE THE
AGENCIES HAVEN'T REALLY. BEEN
WILLING ALWAYS TO SPECIFICALLY
LOOK AT IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
AND IN THE SAME WAY SO THAT
WOULD BE I THINK A VERY GOOD
CONCEPT TO AND INCLUDING.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THAT AND
WELCOME THIS COMMITTEE OR
SIMILAR IN REGARDS TO YOUR OR
YOUR- SUGGESTIONS OR THE
COMMUNITY ITSELF- I KNOW
THERE'S A LINE IN THERE. THE
EMIGRATE VIEWS RIGHT IT JUST
SAYS REPORT ON ISSUES OF
STATEWIDE SIGNIFICANCE
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
CONSIDERATIONS BUT- I THINK WE
COULD BE MORE POINTED AND MAKE
CLEAR TO THE- THE VULNERABLE
WHO ARE GOING TO BE HIT SO. I
WOULD WELCOME THE SUGGESTION
EVEN BEFORE THE FLOOR OKAY I
THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THIS COMMITTEE TO.
TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN. THANK YOU
SO THE RESURGENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN THANK YOU FOR A-
JOINING US TELEPHONICALLY I
KNOW YOU HAVE A SOME PERSONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT PREVENT YOU
FROM BEING A BOTH HERE
YESTERDAY AS WELL AS TODAY- YOU
KNOW I WAS. IN MY OFFICE EATING
MY LUNCH AND I WAS INSPIRED TO
ASK THIS QUESTION THAT- YOU
KNOW JUST CAME OUT OF THE BLUE
BUT- YOU KNOW DOES YOUR BILL
WELL WILL IT. THE SECTOR TO DO.
ENOUGH DETAILED INFORMATION SO
THAT WE GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE STAKE IN
OF OUR CLIMATE CHALLENGES I
MEAN I AM THINKING IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT YOU KNOW OUR
INVESTMENTS. AND CALPERS AND
CAL. AND HOW WE NEED TO HAVE. A
MORE CLEAR UNDERSTANDING IN
TERMS OF- PRIVATE EQUITY-
EXPOSURE TO THE RISKS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT HOW YOUR BILL WILL BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO GET US
BETTER INFORMATION. THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND THANKS FOR. TAKING TO COME
BACK TO COMEDIAN DIGGIN ON
THIS- I THINK THE BILL COULD BE.
MAYBE A LITTLE MORE SPECIFIC IN
THAT REGARD- SO I'M OPENING I'M
OPEN TO YOU TO MAKING THE BILL
A LITTLE MORE GRANULAR ABOUT
TRYING TO. ACCESS THAT KIND OF
DATA WE KNOW THAT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER LAST
YEAR CALPERS AND CAL STIRS ARE
STARTING TO DO SOME OF THEIR
WORK AS SHAREHOLDERS IN
CORPORATIONS AND TRYING TO PUSH
FOR MORE DISCLOSURE OF CLIMATE
RISK IN A NUMBER OF. LARGE
MULTINATIONALS NOT JUST THOSE
BASED IN CALIFORNIA BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT JUST THOSE PENSION FUNDS
THAT ARE AT RISK BUT IT'S YOU
KNOW ANYONE WHO HAD A FIRE
INSURANCE POLICY WE WANT TO
BETTER RIGHT. AND OUTSIDE. INCH
MORE WE WANT TO KNOW. HE KNOW
WHAT KIND OF A- SOME OF OUR
LARGEST CORPORATIONS HAVE AND
WHETHER THERE WE CAN KEEP
LEANING ON THEM OR WHETHER THEY
HAVE UNFORESEEN RISKS SO I
THINK. I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY
MORE WE CAN DO- TO INSURE THAT
WE GET NOT JUST THE PUBLIC
SECTOR DATA FROM THE AGENCIES
BUT ALSO- MAKING SURE GETTING
THAT FULL SORT OF PICTURE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK.
C. NINE SIX ABOUT IT SHOWED
LIKE CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FOR MR
STERN THANK YOU A SECTOR PLEASE
CALL. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HI LAURA. LARA NO CHAO CHAO HI
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS MATHIS
NO MCCARTY MCCARTY I AM HERE TO
G. R. TO GI RIVAS RIVERSIDE
STONE. STONE HI. HAS EIGHT
VOTES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE MOVING ONTO OUR LAST BILL
TODAY. WHICH IS S. B. TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER WINNER. AND
IF THE OPERATOR PLEASE START
QUEUING UP TO WITNESSES FOR SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. THE BILL. AND
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AND TO COMMITTEE ON A
VERY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFFS ARE
INTENSIVE WORK WITH US ON THIS
BILL AND ARE HAPPY TO ACCEPT-
THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS I COLLEAGUES AS P.
TO RADIATE- WILL JUMP START
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS AS AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FROM THE COVER
NINETEEN ECONOMIC COLLAPSE
UNLIKE UNLOCKING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
AND EXPEDITING CLIMATE FRIENDLY
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO THE LAKE COMMONSENSE
PROJECTS THAT CREATE JOBS
REVIVE LOCAL ECONOMIES IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION CONNECT
COMMUNITIES IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. THE TERM
PANDEMIC HAS LEFT OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS AND
FINANCIAL RUIN- WITH SYSTEMS
EXPERIENCING DRAMATIC DROPS WE
NEED TO TAKE A CREATIVE
APPROACH INSURANCE TO ENSURING
THAT PUBLIC MONEY GOING INTO
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
HAS A DUAL PURPOSE OF PUTTING
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND
REALIGNING THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
DECISIONS OF CLIMATE AND EQUITY
AND STABILIZING- THESE SYSTEMS.
ARE THE BILL EXPEDITE APPROVAL
OF THE FOLLOWING TYPES OF
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS BY STREAMLINING THEM-
TO SEE WHAT- INCLUDING
PEDESTRIAN AND BIKE FACILITIES
INCLUDING BIKE SHARE-
INFORMATION DISCOVERY FOR
PEOPLE WHO WALK BIKE OR TAKE
TRANSIT SIGNAL PRIORITY
ENTRANCE A PRIORITIZATION FOR
EXISTING SYSTEMS. INCREASING
BUS RAPID TRANSIT BUS OR LIGHT
RAIL SERVICE ON EXISTING
PUBLIC'S RIGHT AWAY PUBLIC
RIGHTS OF WAY- AS WELL AS ZERO
EMISSION BUS CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN ADDITION-
THIS BILL EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF
THE EXISTING EXEMPTION OFFERED
BY TRANSPORTATION PLANS FROM
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO TWENTY
THIRTY REST OF THE BILL OF WILL
BYERS I IN TWO YEARS I IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY OF TWENTY
THREE. THE PROJECT ARE
CONTRACTED OUT WHO'S- ON BE
SUBJECT TO PROTECTIONS. ARE
FURTHER ANY SIGNIFICANT PROJECT
WITH A BUDGET EXCEEDING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. MUST
BE INCORPORATED INTO A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN OR THE
EQUIVALENT THAT IS UNDERGOING
GONNA PROGRAM LEVEL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT AT
SOME POINT IN THE PRIOR TEN
YEARS. AND THE LEAD AGENCY MUST
ALSO COMPLETE A RACIAL EQUITY
ANALYSIS TO ENSURE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE SURROUNDING AREA.
AFFIRMATIVELY BENEFIT FROM THE
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECT- THE BILL HAS ROBUST
COMMUNITY INPUT OUR PROCEDURES
AND IN FACT THESE COMMUNITY I
IMPORT PROCEDURES ARE
FREQUENTLY EARLIER IN THE
PROCESS AND EXISTING. ASI POT-
COLLEAGUES- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ON BOTH. WITH ME TODAY AND
SUPPORT R. TWO WITNESSES LARA
TO COUGH UP WITH US SPUR AND
MICHAEL TURN. WITH LOS ANGELES
METRO THANK YOU. IF YOU CAN
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND THE FIRST
WITNESSES WILL BE LARA TOLE
COUGH AND MICHAEL TURNER. IF
THE LINE. HERE MISTRAL CLASS
AND MR ARE ON GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS FLOOR TOTAL
COSTS I'M HERE FOR SB Q. EIGHTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE BILL CO
SPONSORED. BY THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL AND THE TELECOM BALLY
LEADERSHIP GROUP. WE WANT TO
THANK SENATOR WIENER THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
SALE. OVER HERE THINKING HAVE
TO TABLE AND TIME SENSITIVE
PROJECTS ARE OFTEN DELAYED
EXACTLY WHEN WE NEED THEM MOST.
FOR EXAMPLE PEOPLE LITIGATION
I'M TEMPTED TO CUT BY CLAN HELD
UP THIRTY FOUR MILES OF BIKE
LANES OVER FOUR YEARS. DURING
THAT TIME NINE PEOPLE DIED AND
OVER TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE
INJURED WHILE RIDING THEIR
BIKES IN THE CITY. TODAY THE
CITY FLOW AND PASTRY PROGRAM IS
APPEALED EVEN THOUGH IT IS A
CORNERSTONE IN THE CITY'S
COVERT NINETEEN RECOVERY PLAN.
BOTH OF THESE ARE NOT BASED ON
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT BUT ON
PARKING AND TRAFFIC IMPACTS.
SORRY LIKE THESE ALL OVER CAL.
MORE THAN TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE I UNDERSTAND
THE URGENCY AND THE COR AT B.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. I THINK IT'S
VERY OPEN WE ARE THINKING A
MAJOR UPTICK IN DRIVING AND
CONGESTION NOW IS THE TIME TO
REALLY DOUBLE DOWN AND BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MAKES IT
SAFE AND CONVENIENT FOR PEOPLE
TO WALK BIKE AND TAKE A BATH IN
THE BIKE ROUTE. OUR ENVIRONMENT
OUR HEALTH AND OUR ECONOMY
DEPEND ON IT. IF WE DON'T IT
WILL CONTINUE TO HUNT STATES
BLACK AND LATINO POPULATION-
ALREADY SHOULDER
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF THE
STATE AIR POLLUTION FROM
VEHICLES. AND HAVE HIGHER RATES
OF THE CONDITIONS THAT MAKE.
COVERT NINETEEN ACTUALLY
DANGEROUS. IN AREAS WHERE
TRAFFIC CONGESTION IS RAPIDLY
RETURNING BUT THEY'RE STUCK IN
TRAFFIC OR PACKING PEOPLE UP T
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING. THIS
UNFAIRLY IMPACT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ON WHOM WE DEPEND. IN
CALIFORNIA THIRD OF ALL
POTENTIAL WORKERS RELY ON
TRANSIT TO GET WHERE THEY NEED
TO GO. SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THE
COURT CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY BY
PROVIDING TARGETED EXEMPTIONS
ARE TO GO UP TO COMMONSENSE
PROJECT. I THINK YOU EIGHTY
EIGHT IS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
PROJECT THAT TRULY BENEFIT
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IT INCLUDES
IMPORTANT NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR
COMMUNITY LED DECISION MAKING
ON LARGER PROJECTS. LIKE
ENSURING THAT PRODUCT BY THIRTY
EIGHT COMMUNITY EARLY AND
ANALYZE DISPROPORTIONATE
BENEFITS AND BURDENS OF THE
PROJECT THROUGH RACIAL EQUITY
ANALYSIS. INCLUDE HIGH
STANDARDS FOR LABOR AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. SB TWO EDA AND NO
COCKTAIL LED TO THE STATE SB
TWO A COMPLETE PROJECT MONEY
AND PUT PUT DOLLARS AND PEOPLE
TO WORK MORE QUICKLY. HE DID
BACK MAKE THEIR JOBS AND HAVE A
FIVE TO AN ECONOMIC RETURN AND
DIRECT AND INDIRECT SPENDING.
WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR WIENER
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK TO
BE CALIFORNIA OUT OF THIS
CRISIS. I PUT THE STATE LEVEL
TRANSPORTATION AT THE CENTER OF
OUR RECOVERY I'M HAPPY TO TAKE.
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YEAH MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL TURNER WITH DELHI METRO.
CAME MISTER TURNER GOING ON
BEHALF. THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE L. A. COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY BOARD
OF DIRECTORS I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THIS BILL
WOULD EXPAND THE SPLIT THE
STATUTORY EXEMPTIONS UNDER
SPEAK WITH PER KEY
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. WHILE
STRENGTHENING PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE EQUITY PUBLIC AND PUBLIC
INVOLVEMENT THE TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING ABOUT THE SHORTFALL
EXPERIENCED BY TRANSIT AGENCIES
IN CALIFORNIA THREATEN THE JOBS
OF TRANSPORTATION WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
SERVICES ARE CUT. AND CAPITAL
PROJECT CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
ARE PUT ON HOLD. THIS BILL
WOULD SIX SAVE CRITICAL TIME
AND MONEY BY CREATING STATUTORY
EXEMPTIONS FROM SPEAK UP FOR
PROJECTS THAT MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER FOR WALKING AND BICYCLING
AND SPEED UP BUS SERVICE AND
THE PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY. WITHOUT
ADDING NEW AUTO CAPACITY.
MEASURE HAS PRIORITIZED THIS
PROJECT AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A COUNTY WIDE RECOVERY PLAN
THAT WOULD SPUR JOB CREATION
IMPROVE TRANSIT OPERATION FOR
WRITERS AND EXPAND BUS RAPID
TRANSIT THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY.
DIVERT MEDIA BALDWIN IN SUPPORT
COMMUNITY LED PLANT LOCATED
CALL TO PROVIDE EARLY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION GREATER RACIAL
ACT DOLLARS. BITE ONGOING
DIALOGUE DURING THE
CONSTRUCTION. PHASE THAT THESE
PROJECTS HAVE NO THINKING AND
ON THE AND- PROJECTS MUST ALSO
BE LOCATED IN AN URBANIZED AREA
BE LOCATED ON EXISTING PUBLIC
RIGHT AWAY AND THAT THE MENTION
CANNOT ADD NEW AUTO CAPACITY.
WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE-
INCLUSION OF ZERO EMISSION
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR-
BUT- SERVICES THIS IS ALIGNED
WITH OUR GOAL TO CONVERT OUR
BUS FLEET OF TWENTY THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED BUT THE- TWO ZERO
MISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY UP TO
TEN YEARS AHEAD OF THE STATE
CAN'T THEY- BUT ALSO LIKE TO
MENTION. THAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE REQUEST OF INGLEWOOD TO
AMEND THE BILL TO INCLUDE
PEOPLE MOVER SYSTEM AS WELL.
WELL WE'RE JUST- LIKE TO SAVE
SPECIAL NOTE AND THANK SENATOR
WIENER AND HIS STAFF IN THE
SPONSORS FOR REACHING OUT TO US%
EARLY IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THE BILL. THIS BILL
IS TRULY THE RESULT OF A
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION.
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN
WE PLEASE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
YOU MAY GET IN THE QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE GO TO ONE
NINE ONE ONE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON HE
BALK APARTMENT VISOR SO YOUR
GUESTS EXPECTED SUPPORT OF THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT. AND THE NAPA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THANK
YOU. FY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY LINE TWO FOUR ZERO. YEAH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THAT B. TWO EIGHT EIGHT JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING
VERY COLLABORATIVE%
COLLABORATIVE LEE WITH A- FIFTY
CARAMANICA TO THE BILL IT WOULD
ADD IN AN EXEMPTION FOR ZERO
EMISSION BY. CHARGING REFUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU SO
MUCH GIVE ME A PRIVATE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE LINE TWO NINE FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LARA THEY'VE LEFT THEIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS MADE TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND ONE LINE
THREE ZERO ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS HEARING MEMBERS THIS IS
ROTH BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF ST
BERKELEY OKAY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AMPHOTERIC COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINUS THREE
HUNDRED AND Q. LINE IS THREE
ZERO TWO. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SOVIET POLICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON
BREED IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I HAVE MY NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR LINE SEVEN FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON FAIR NUMBER SPOKEN
MODEL NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA AGAIN ME AND SUPPORT
THANK YOUNG. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND THREE
LINE THREE ZERO THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
BE HAPPENS SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL ALONG WITH
SPUR AND THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE A THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN LINE THREE
ZERO SEVEN. HE THANK YOU NOT A
JUG ROBINSON WAS SHUDDERING TO
SCHMELTER LAYING ON BEHALF OF
CALTRAIN AND THE SAN MATTEO
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY. GO TO MY NUMBERS
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE LINE TWO
FIVE FIVE. ASSEMBLY DJ FROM
BEHALF OF CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY NINE
LINE TWO NINE NINE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ENTERING EMPLOYEE WITH
CHARGER INTO EACH ALTERED LYING
HERE TO SUPPORT SB TWO EIGHTY A
CLEANER ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
RIGHT. WE HAVE LINE THREE
HUNDRED LINE THREE ZERO ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS UNDER US ARMY DOES ON
BEHALF OF OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT IS LINE TWO EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MARK SCHMIDT WITH THE
COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE LINE AT NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND. SEVENTY SIX NINE TWO SEVEN
SIX. HELLO MANY MYSTERE SHEET
ON BEHALF OF THE KALECKI
REGIONAL RAIL COMMISSION WITH
THE COR AT THE TWO EIGHT EIGHT
AND ALSO SUBMITTED A FORMAL
LETTER AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE IS. THREE ZERO
FOUR THREE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TELL YOU TO GO BETWEEN ALLIANCE
AND WE'RE IN FRONT THE PART.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE
AS PART ME OUT THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHT NINE THREE ZERO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RAPIDSHARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOEL GORE
HALL AND I AM WITH SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
THE COMMITTEE. COULD
CONSIDERATION DEMAND EXPERIENCE
STRONG SUPPORT. TAKE YOUR TIME.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE LINE TWO SIX
FIVE. THANK YOU- BUDGET NUMBERS
THE COMMITTEE CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND SIX LINE THREE ZERO SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
AND AFRICAN BALLOTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF TAMPA BAY'S IN
SUPPORT. IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL. OF THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY
ENTER THE QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE
THEN IF ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YOU HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE SO PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU CAN WE
PLEASE NOW MOVES TO COLORS IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES LISTED TIFFANY ANG
AND BRANDEN DAWSON IF WE COULD
pYOU THEY ARE BOTH ON THE PHONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- MISS ANG AND
MR DAWSON. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS TIFFANY AND I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE OKAY HOUSE.
THE HOBBIT OPPOSED TO SB TWO
WOULD BE A ELECTED AS AMENDED
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW LARGE
SCALE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
TO BUS RAPID TRANSIT OTHERS YOU
BY PATCH CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PROPERTIES WHICH COULD RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACT AND OTHER IMPACTS SUCH
AS- THE DISPLACEMENT OF LOW
INCOME COMMUTING TO ME THE
COLOR. WE REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND THE BILL'S SPONSORS.
YOU FIND WAYS TO MINIMIZE SB
JUDY IT HARMS HOWEVER THINK I
WILL JUST BE THE TRANSPORTATION
JUST ADVOCATE. WE KNOW THAT
BECAUSE ONE OF THE FEW LEGAL
TOOL THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND COMMUTER CALLER HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROJECT WILL
NOT BRING ABOUT SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ANOTHER
IMPACT. WE'RE CONCERNED. IT
WOULD CREATE A TROUBLING
PRECEDENT FOR ADDITIONAL BILLS
THAT WE KEEP THAT PROJECT THAT
SHOULD IN FACT UNDERGO FULL AND
ROBUST PEOPLE PROCESS. THE
POLITICAL PROPAGANDA THERE
BECAUSE ALLOWED AJ COMMUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT. PARTICIPATE IN AND
IMPROVE THIS PROJECT THAT WILL
LIKELY IMPACT THEIR FAMILY
HEALTH. AND THEIR ABILITY TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. THE CALL READY.
A PUBLIC. AND VETTING PROCESS.
WE DO NOT SEE THE NEED TO
CREATE A SEPARATE PUBLIC
PROCESS. MOREOVER A PUBLIC
PROPERTY FORTY CENTER PROJECT
ALMOST MEANINGLESS SENATE THE
COMMITTEE WILL NOT HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS. AND
OTHER INFORMATION THAT THEY
NEED. IN ORDER TO EVALUATE THE
PROS AND CONS OF THE PROJECT.
SIMILARLY ALL THE PREVIOUS
AUTHORED ADDITION OF A RACIAL
EQUITY ANALYSIS. WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE CHANNEL
COULD NOT BE ENFORCEABLE BY LAW
IT CANNOT REPLACE. A PROCESS.
OR STOP POTENTIAL DISPLACEMENT
OF LOW INCOME CREATING COMMIT
THE COLOR. WE APPRECIATE
AUTHORS WITH AMENDMENT TO LIMIT
THE PROJECT THAT COULD LEAD TO
SOME OF THE GREATEST HARM. WE
DO BELIEVE THAT IN ORDER FOR SB
THREE. STATUS AND CAN YOU
RECOMMEND OF THE BILL BE
NARROWLY TAILORED TO ONLY APPLY
TO PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE
FACILITIES. AND BICYCLE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN. FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB TWO THE EIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON. HEY
LOOKING ENSURE MEMBERS
DISCIPLINE AND ALSO WITH YOUR
CALIFORNIA. PERSONA CAN TO
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN
THE AUTHORED THE BILL'S SPONSOR
FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL. WE'VE
HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SPONSORS ABOUT THE BILL AND
PROJECTED AMENDMENTS- AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROJECT
BUILT BY TO BEGIN REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
REQUIREMENTS AND- JUST.
GENERALLY GOOD FOR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS IN GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. HOWEVER WE DO
REMAIN CONCERNED FOR THE
REASONS ARE CALLING IT A WHOLE
JUST MENTIONED- AND SO WE WILL
MAKE A POST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CAN WE PLEASE
HAVE OTHER WITNESS FULL FIRST
HEARD ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. ACTUALLY SEE ONE
PERSON HERE NOW NOPE. OKAY THEN
CAN WE PLEASE GO TO CALLERS ON
THE LINE IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. IF ARE IN
OPPOSITE OF A- TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. OF PLEASE ENTER QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THEN ZERO. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY FOUR ONE SEVEN FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
DOLLARS DON'T ADVOCACY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHO- WE HAD AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED PROVISION
AS TO THE PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT PROVISION THANK YOU.
YEAH MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND.
NINETY EIGHT NINE TWO NINE
EIGHT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
SHARING MEMBER- MY NAME IS
JASMINE JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF P.
AS FAR AWAY AND I'M COR CALLING
TO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED SB TWO
ABA MICROLINER COMMON WITH THIS
BECAUSE LIKE I HAVE A FAIR
QUOTE- I DON'T LIKE TO REGISTER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT I MEAN START
OPPOSITION FROM THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS- THE FEDERAL
RATES PARTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND. TWENTY FOUR BETTER
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION IF YOU
HAVE COMMENTS YOU MAY ENTER THE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN IF
ZERO. AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION SB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IF ZERO. YEP NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- AND SENATOR WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I WITHOUT WILL GO TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MISTER SAID THANK YOU.
THANK CENTER WIENER FOR NOT
ONLY. PRESENTING YOUR BILL BUT-
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU BRIEFLY LAST NIGHT I
RAISE MY CONCERN- SPECIFICALLY
ON THE PROVISION OF THE BILL
THAT NOT ONLY. FOR POSES
EXEMPTIONS FROM SEQUEL FOR
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE PLANS.
BUT FOR POTENTIALLY MORE
SIGNIFICANT PLANS. THAT SAY HA-
ALSO HIGHLIGHTED- PROJECTS FOR
THE INSTITUTION OR INCREASE OF.
A NEW BUS TRENT TRANSIT. OR
LIGHT RAIL SERVICE INCLUDING
THE CONSTRUCTION OF STATIONS
WHICH I BELIEVE WOULD BE RAIL
STATIONS. IF THEY'RE ON
EXISTING PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY-
SO FIRST I WANT TO ASK. LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE IN IN MY DISTRICT I
I'VE BEEN A BIG SUPPORTER OF
EXTENDING THE L. A. METRO TO
THE CITY OF TORRANCE ONE OF
THE- UP POSIBLES AND PERHAPS A
MISTER TURNER WITH L. A. METRO
IF HE'S STILL. AVAILABLE YOU
CAN CONFIRM THIS BUT THAT ONE
OF THE PROPOSALS IS TO EXTEND
THE METRO LIGHT RAIL ON THE
EXISTING. ARE RIGHT AWAY- TO
GOING TO TORRANCE BUT OF COURSE.
THAT WOULD RAISE SIGNIFICANT.
CONCERNS IN THE COMMUNITY NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF. THE EXTENSION
THE LIGHT RAIL BUT ALSO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF STATIONS WHICH
I WOULD ASSUME WOULD BE A- HUGE
PROJECT- IN IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND TO HAVE A WHOLESALE. SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR- THESE
POTENTIALLY LARGE PROJECT. ON
HI I'M- ACTUALLY SURPRISED THAT
IT INTO EITHER I'M
MISUNDERSTANDING AND OR- OR I'M
SURPRISED THAT IT IT. WASN'T
RAISED AS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE-
BY THIS COMMITTEE OR BY THE
SENATE SO I WANT TO ASK THEM.
IF I'M UNDERSTANDING THAT
CORRECTLY AND- AND- SO- TO THE
CHAIR YES PLEASE YOU CAN THANK
YOU I THANK YOU- SOME REMEMBER
AFTER THE QUESTION OF F. SHOT.
LAST NIGHT SO COUPLE THINGS ARE
FIRST OF ALL THE BILL DOES NOT
APPLY TO HEAVY RAIL JUST TO BE
CLEAR- AND THEN IN TERMS OF
LIGHT RAIL IT HAS TO BE AN
EXISTING RIGHT AWAY. SO THIS IS
NOT LIGHT RAIL WHERE YOU'RE YOU
KNOW CREATING A NEW RIGHT OF
WAY HICH YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
BACK CAN CREATE CONCERNS WOULD
BE MUCH MORE DESTRUCTIVE IN
TERMS OF OTHERS EXISTING USES.
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY ALL BY.
AND IF THE PROJECT IS AT A
HUNDRED MILLION OR MORE AND
FRANKLY HAVING BEEN AROUND
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
FOR A LONG TIME. ANY DIFFERENT
THAN LIGHT RAIL PROJECT YEAH
AND YOU. YOU KNOW IS.
TRAGICALLY GOING TO PAST
SEVERAL AND SO IF SO THEN IT
HAS TO HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEARED WITH A
E. I. R. AS PART OF A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN OAKLAND
DOCUMENT WHICH WOULD HAVE HAD
PUBLIC PUBLIC PARTICIPATION THE
I. R. AND POTENTIALLY LAWSUITS
IN ADDITION THIS IS NOT IN ANY
WAY CHANGE THE NEED FOR FORMAL
APPROVAL SO L. A. METRO WHICH
OF COURSE IS A PUBLIC BODY
COMPRISES I UNDERSTAND THAT OF.
A LOT LARGE ELECTED OFFICIALS
WORSE IT WILL STILL HAVE TO
APPROVE THE PROJECT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DO MULTIPLE
PUBLIC MEETINGS AT A TIME
THIRTY ONE FOCUSED ON A RACIAL
EQUITY AND THEN TO PUBLIC MEDIA
PER YEAR FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF
GUARDRAILS AROUND US AT IT I
JUST A LITTLE IT WAS KIND OF
SITUATION- AND I ALSO
PURCHASED- PENSION I'VE WE'VE
WE'VE SPENT ALL TOP SE HAN I
RESPECT THE ORGANS AND TAKING
THEIR BACK AND TRYING TO. MEET
THEIR CONCERNS THE BILL HAS
STRAINED WRIST I'M CANNOT TEAR
DOWN WERE FROM PORTABLE HOUSING
RENT CONTROLLED HOUSING-
HOUSING- THAT IS RENTAL WERE
YOU HAVE OF WORDS OCTOBER THERE
ARE RESTRICTIONS WE DON'T BE A
DISPLACING OUR PEOPLE OUR
SERVER WHICH OF THOSE ARE
CONCERNS VERY SERIOUSLY WILL
CONTINUE OF COURSE TO LOG. SO
THE- YOU CAN FOLLOW UP ON SO.
THE PROCESS THAT YOU DESCRIBE
HAS BEEN TAKING PLACE IN A
MIGHT OKAY SENT INTO IN REDONDO
BEACH- MULTIPLE HEARINGS ARE
BEING HELD BY L. A. METRO BUT-
MY UNDERSTANDING AGAIN OF YOUR
BILL HERE IS SET UP. IS THAT
WHILE THE PUBLIC HAS HAD
OPPORTUNITIES TO- TO HEAR
PRESENTATIONS AND TO COMMENT ON
THE PRESENTATIONS THAT YOUR
YOUR BILL WOULD WOULD TAKE AWAY
THEIR LEGAL RIGHT TO CHALLENGE.
THE PROJECT- BY EXEMPTING ARMED
IF V. HELP METRO EXTENSION GOES
ALONG THE EXISTING RIGHT AWAY
YOU KNOW EVEN EVEN FOR ANY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
CONSTRUCTING- LIGHT RAIL
STATION IN. LIGHT RAIL STATIONS
ACTUALLY THE TWO THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED IN AND IN MY EXAMPLE
IN REDONDO BEACH AND IN
TORRANCE- DONE THAT AGAIN IT IT
SEEMS TO BE A SIGNIFICANT- TAKE
AWAY OF A LEGAL RIGHTS THAT.
THAT THAT MY CONSTITUENTS
CURRENTLY HAVE. TO BE A
CHALLENGE- THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF THESE PROPOSED
PRICES. YEAH TO THE CHAIR- A
COUPLE THINGS- THE GREEN LINE
PROJECT- SOMEONE JUST EMIND ME
AS A TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT THAT WOULD OBVIOUSLY
EASILY GOING TO CATEGORY WHERE
IT NEEDS TO OPEN A VIRAL CLEAR-
AS PART OF A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN WITH FULL
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
ANALYSIS. AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
A LAWSUIT IN ADDITION THIS IS A
COURTESY CALL EXEMPTION IT
DOESN'T BUY IT'S NOT A NEW
PROJECT SEACOR CHANGE AND SO
YOU CAN STILL APPEAL A SIMPLE
EXEMPTION. YOU CAN ALSO FILE A
LAWSUIT WANT TO SEE WHAT
EXEMPTION AND THIS ALSO DOES
NOT CHANGE ANY EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS- ANY OTHER
EXISTING REGULATORY OR
STATUTORY ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS AND IF THOSE ARE
BEING VIOLATED YOU CAN SUE ON
THOSE- SO THERE ARE STILL
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO CHALLENGE PROJECTS
WOULD THINK THAT THERE ARE
ISSUES- AND BUT IT DOES MAKE
THAT CHANGE- IN TERMS OF THE-
THE WAY THE SICKLE PROCESS
WORKS. I THOUGHT AN EXEMPTION
TO SEQUEL. MEANS THAT IT'S NOT
COVERED BY SEQUEL SEQUEL
EXEMPTION AND I AND I- UGH
GOING BACK TO MY DAYS ON THE
SAN FRANCISCO WERE SUPERVISORS
WE HEARD. PLENTY OF SYKORA
APPEALS BASED ON EXEMPTIONS YOU
CAN APPEAL TO YOUR ELECTED BODY
BASED ON EXEMPTION BASED MEGA
DOGLE CENTER BASED ON A FULL
YEAR BY ALL AND THEN YOU IF YOU
THINK THAT THE LAW WAS VIOLATED
YOU CAN FILE. A LAWSUIT AND
COURSE. PROJECT IF YOU BELIEVE
INVITE VIOLATES SUBSTANTIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL. STANDARDS IN OUR
WATER. YOU CAN OF COURSE ALWAYS
TO ON THAT SO. THEY BILL EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A- ITS STILL
PRESERVES A LOT OF THE POCKETS
OF RESERVE POWER PROCESS- AND
IT STILL GIVES PEOPLE- THEIR
DAY AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE. INPUT OR TO CHALLENGE
THE DECISION IF THEY THINK THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH IT.
THANK THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR WE I WOULD
BE HONORED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. OKAY WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE WITH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR THE BILL AS AMENDED. HE
WILL MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE. SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN ALL RIGHT
FRIEDMAN HI LAURA. FLORAHI JO.
JO HI CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN
HI GARCIA MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY THANK YOU MCCARTY AYE
MERE TUCCI. RICHARD SHE NOT
VOTING REVERSE RIVERSIDE STONE
STONE NOW. THANK YOUR SEVEN
VOTES THANK YOUR BILL IS OUT-
BEFORE WE MOVED TO BOOT SOME
BILLS ON CALL ON BEFORE WE
ADJOURN I DO WANT TO CALL THAT
OUR STAFF ARE EXCELLENT STAFF
FOR THE HERCULEAN EFFORT THIS
YEAR IN TRYING TO PARE DOWN AND
NEGOTIATED WORK ON BILLS- GIVEN
THE COBIT RESTRICTIONS AND
DIFFICULTIES NOT TO MENTION
THAT WORKING FROM HOME WITH
CHILDREN AROUND. SO MUCH ALONG
WITH FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF-
FOR ELIZABETH AND MICHAEL I
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR AMAZING WORK IN
IMPROVING A WHOLE BUNCH OF
BILLS WITH THAT WE HAVE ONE
ALONG CALL WOULD YOU MIND
CALLING THE ROLE FOR THE BILL
ON CALL. OKAY THE BILL ON CALL
IS S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT-
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. FOR THE
NOTHING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARE CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN
HI TUCCI. TO GI RIVAS RIVAS HI
STONE STONE HI. AND GOOGLE HAS
THE MEMBERS ON THE OTHER BILLS.
OKAY CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS ON
THE BILLS THAT HAVE PASSED
STARTING AT THE TOP SB NINE
NINE FIVE. THE CURRENT VOTERS
EIGHT TO ZERO GARCIA STONE.
STONE NOW. THAT VOTE IS EIGHT
TO ONE. SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CURRENT
VOTED SEVEN TO ZERO THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE COMING HAM. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE STONE STONE NOW
THAT VOTERS EIGHT TO ONE. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN TO ZERO THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE CUNNINGHAM.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MERE TWO G.
TO GI STONE STONE HI THAT
VOTERS TEND TO ZERO. SB NINE
EIGHT NINE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN TO ZERO THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE CUNNINGHAM. MCCARTY
MCCARTY ARCHIVE MURATSUCHI TO
GI STONE STONE HI. VOTERS TEND
TO ZERO. SB THIRTEEN NO ONE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TWO ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI- R. TWO
G. I.'S. STONE HI. TEN ZERO. SB
NINE SEVEN FOR HER TADO THE
CURRENT VOTERS EIGHT ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM.
MARTUCCI TWO G. AYE STONE STONE
NOW. NINE TO ONE. SB TEN TWELVE
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TO THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE CUNNINGHAM.
MARTUCCI IT'S ITCHY EYES STONE
STONE ARE. VOTERS EIGHT TO. SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY THE CURRENT
VOTE IS EIGHT TO THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM. VOTERS
EIGHT TO TWO. AND. THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE LAST- OR I'M SORRY
SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THE CURRENT
VOTE IS. EIGHT TWO ONE THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE CUNNINGHAM.
GARCIA THE VOTERS EIGHT TO ONE.
FINALLY THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH IS SB EIGHT NINETY FIVE
AND SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO THE
VOTERS SIX ZERO THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MATTEUCCI AYE STONE STONE ALL
RIGHT NINE ZERO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AND. THAT DOESN'T. IF
YOU LIKE TO TERMS WITH THAT WE
ARE TURN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LAWRENCE.